okay
good morning
good morning everybody thank you very
much for being here this morning I will
open our work session on house bills
so that I get them all correct house
bill is 608 House Bill 238 House Bill
317 and House Bill
642. all of these bills are related to
the developmental disability community
and the Bureau of Developmental services
so it seemed prudent to bring all of
these here to the table today while we
discuss while we discuss this very
important very pressing issue
yes I just have a preliminary thing that
I just noticed were they all noticed for
different times the bills no they were
not noticed for different times they're
all noticed for nine o'clock as a full
committee work okay perfect perfect I
just saw something here with things at
different times and I thought oh my gosh
oh okay
absolutely and thank you thank you for
checking to make sure that we're doing
things correctly I appreciate it I'm
three steps behind and I'm sorry about
that
uh so one of our largest challenges as
we're dealing with these bills is the
looming requirements to become in
compliance with some federal
requirements surrounding direct billing
and around the conflict the
conflict-free case management this has
been an ongoing process where there have
been waivers already requested
um there have been responses including
to the governor saying that um that some
some options are off the table however
we want to make sure that we can look
probe around all of the opportunities
and see what we can do to make sure that
we're able to proceed in a reasonable
way for the state and make sure that
we're also protecting these families in
the system that supports them for all of
us the last two years almost the last
three years have been incredibly
challenging and probably even more so
for this community so we want to make
sure that
we don't add more change before they're
ready to deal with it
um
so I don't know if anybody has any
particular questions that they wanted to
ask around these or if I should continue
to guide this to look at what the four
different bills are and how we would
what we're looking at as far as
potential amendments and our process
um yes the first one is the house bill
608 establishing a pilot program to
support the Bureau of Developmental
Services redesign this is the one that
um
that basically stops the process on a
lot of the things around the a m audit
it they are there are some air things
that are being included in this process
that are not not necessarily required to
come into Federal compliance and it's a
question one of the questions that I
have and that other people have both in
the community and in the committee is
whether proceeding with all of these at
the same time is prudent given that the
direct Bill change is so large and so
significant
then there's also House Bill 238
relative to the role of the quality
control and the developmental disability
service system that one was brought to
us by our long-term long time but not
this year Committee Member
representative McMahon
um this is one of those bills that's
trying to address the fact that the
community did not feel that they had
enough of a voice at the table and we
need to figure out the right way to make
sure that everybody can work together
towards the right Solutions as opposed
to
as opposed to having a lot of open
questions that hopefully that we can
either resolve or recognize has been
discussed and that there may be some
differences of opinion then there's
House Bill 317 establishing a commission
to transitioning to a two-tier waiver
system for individuals eligible for
disability services
right now in New Hampshire everybody is
under one tier of waiver one of the ways
that this is used is that in some states
they have one higher level of waiver
that is institutionalized care for very
high need families and high need
individuals and then there's another one
that offers a lower tier of services to
people who need supports to stay within
the community
um one of the things that we do in New
Hampshire that's really special really
beneficial and is also a fiscally
responsible is we keep people with their
families to a much greater extent than
some other states do this is a feature
that we want to make sure we do not lose
with any changes to the redesign because
having a supportive system at home with
the supports that you need is better for
the individual better for the community
and better for the state especially
because we know that institutionalized
care can become a problem especially
especially the way that it's progressed
in the past both here in I don't know
the whole history of the Laconia school
but I know that there's a reason it was
closed around the time I was born and I
do know that we have our own history our
more recent history with the sununo
center so
institutionalizing should be a last
resort
we do need to look at these tiers of
waivers and make sure that we're not
precluding families from getting care in
their family home and that we're not
prevent we're not doing anything that
will force people into an institution
when that is not the right choice for
them
and finally we have House Bill 642 which
is prohibiting the Department of Health
and Human Services from enforcing salary
caps for direct care workers this is
something that is seems to be somewhat
related to some settings and Excel
Fields but it also is a pressing concern
because I've spoken with plenty of
people at the area agencies and other
providers that the amount that they're
able to pay that the Direct Care in the
direct care providers is a problem and
one of the things that's challenging
retention and challenging getting these
services for these uh these very
important people in our community we
want to make sure that any choices we do
there aren't setting an obstacle in the
path while making sure that we are get
we are making making the correct choices
to provide care for it for these very
important community members
yes I want to get a feel of the room if
we want to just dig right into that 608
issue or if we want to talk about
um some other areas representative Weber
well I'm speaking only for myself here
but I'm I I wonder if we wanted to deal
with what I see as somewhat low-hanging
fruit here the the easy one for me is
representative McMahon's Council
um and it doesn't although it is
tangentially related to all of the other
bills it's not so inextricably wound up
that it's
um you know the gears are going to grind
if we don't do it right uh so I see that
as being somewhat freestanding I think
for me with respect to all the other
bills the conversations that I have had
with providers in my community not
families
um
indicate that the problems are ones that
really to me don't necessarily lend
themselves to legislative Solutions
and one of the things I have in my mind
just to throw out here is a possibility
would be to perhaps create a
subcommittee of the Health and Human
Services oversight committee to watch it
month to month to month to month because
what they can do is they can bring
people in to ask or or just have the
Health and Human Services Commission
committee
look at it month to month but a
subcommittee could do it more often as
to how far have you gotten what are you
doing what's happening now because
the things that are clear to me is
there's a critical deadline July 1st and
most of the people don't know exactly
what the guidelines are yet and
certainly don't have the software to
deal with them even if they did
um so you know what what
folks are hoping for is another
extension but an extension saying look
we're not just spinning our Wheels here
we have made x amount of progress and we
want to do this right rather than just
having a train wreck on July 1st so
that's that's one side of it
um and then
the other side that's difficult for me
is that the things with the salary cap I
listened to people when they came and
testified
and
people were very much it was all the
same problem people were very much
divided about whether this will solve
the problem so uh that worries me
because people who were very credible
came to very different and who have much
more experience with the system than I
do came to very different conclusions
which is a long way of saying I don't
know what to do here but but those are
the considerations I'm keeping in my
mind about concerns that I have going
forward
thank you representative Weber I
appreciate your long-standing knowledge
of the legislative process and when and
we when we should and shouldn't get
involved and I do have a very similar
read on the salary caps and some of
these other issues as well I guess my
one question to you with somebody with
with long-standing legislative
experience is whether it would be
helpful for that Health and Human
Services oversight committee to also
have a bill that's proceeding because we
do know that by the time that this would
be signed into law the deadline will
have come and passed for the federal
compliance but if having a guide map of
what we would like to see and what we
would like to have the department move
towards would be helpful in guiding that
process
and I guess my answer to that would be
I'd have to I'd have to take a look at
it because putting a guiding principle
into a statute is not really what a
statute is for and why I think of things
like the Health and Human Services
oversight Community because I think the
other thing that we're all very much
agreed on is that none of us wants to
just kick this can down the road and do
nothing for six months because that is
also not an option but
um I
[Music]
um
you know I'm one of the things I
definitely think about is that one of
the bills needs to be retained as a
vehicle so that if we need to make a
quick correction in January we've got it
ready to go
um
or and you know there is of course the
possibility of quick action on the part
of the legislature but to do that you
need very specific buy-in by not only us
but also the Senate and the governor so
um I think that that might be one thing
that would be prudent to do
um
and I don't object to sending something
forward what I what I'm concerned about
is what it would say at this point and
what it would direct people to do
because statutes normally do either
direct people to do something or forbid
them to do something and I'm not sure
that we can set out a nuanced
set of parameters
that I would be comfortable in acting
into statute
even even if we knew that they were
going to be revised Again by the Senate
because
sometimes the Senate just doesn't do
what we want them to do
darn
so again there's a lot of uncertainty
there and I wish I sure wish I had
answers but I really don't
thank you thank you I think that's why
we called this work session when
otherwise we could be working through
that list of bills to exec
um I I do agree that looking at this
low-hanging fruit of Representative
McMahon's bill first would be helpful
um I
I do also have one other parallel idea
that I do want to toss out there as well
as opposed to the the broad drafting
sorry
with us you were talking about the
two-tier waiver or were you talking
about the quality control I may have
mixed up my Prime sponsors
um
the one that I was talking about with
the McMahon bill was the one that would
that creates the developmental Services
quality Council 238 238 perfect just
it's just a council it's not
the council is the one that interacts
with the whole system it's not making
the system change thank you my confusion
was um around creating representative
Shapiro I think the council is already
there yes it's really
um being more specific about how the
council will be
interact with the process of change
in DHHS thank you yes
um we had another bill about giving a
opportunity for a roll call vote to an
advisory Council in another bill and my
my question would be would giving an
advice
giving this quality Council the
opportunity to have a roll call vote on
rules before they go to jailcar and to
have that vote be transmitted to gel car
be something that is helpful and would
that address the necessity to be
involved and be heard
that is an open question that's the
issue may be a lot deeper than simply a
yes or no vote on a proposed on a final
rule before it goes to gel car but I
thought that that was the most simple
solution that we might offer and I
thought that it would be up be a good
topic of conversation
um I would like to yes we have another
question representative Shapiro well I
just think that um
you know representative McMahon actually
brought the the um amendment that we
have
um
so he can probably talk better about it
than I but I was involved also and I
think it's broader than just the vote on
rules it's really uh you know it's
really involvement in a variety of ways
in
um
giving input for change including you
know the bidding process which some
people said was a problem for
contractors but I think
it's broader than just that so I think
we should not forego this Bill thank you
very much I think that that's a very
good point and I actually would like to
invite representative McMahon up if
you'd like to join with us in the
discussion about this bill and the
amendment uh because you've been so
involved in this whole process I'd like
to include you in this work session as
we try to figure out how to address this
challenge so
[Laughter]
we'll have you said over there we should
have had you substitute today
and I'll turn that on
okay you must still give a well just one
comment if I may uh in working for with
Cooperative collaboration to achieve
consensus is the goal here and not to uh
set a new a separate Target that would
be in conflict with our Department of
Health and Human Services in providing
the office not the oversight but in
carrying out this this very important
work to our citizens in the state
um the the quality Council was
established years ago uh because and I'm
just reading from uh it's if still have
a copy of the amendment that was
presented when this bill was offered to
you on the 15th of February February I
believe it is as I recall
um it was for systemic review and
Improvement
of the various services and that's to
have a functional participation in the
maintenance and my word Improvement of
where we are on on that given day and
how we move forward
so that's what uh has was not taking
place
as uh as in here to have a functional in
writing uh description of what the the
quality the service Quality Service
Council uh would be doing when they
carry out their work
and that's that's why this was offered
to you it's the again Cooperative
collaboration is the bottom line but
it's to meet the services that those who
are part of the
bureaucratic process and qualifying for
your the waivers and how they're
submitted is that then there's a
fundamental um
commitment to then meet what you have
were part of supporting uh in in the
field and that's
was that's the motivation for this and
that's we're asking
for a positive recommendation from the
committee on on this effort
thank you that's actually very helpful
do you think that the approval on
rulemaking would be enough or do you
think that all of these changes would be
necessary for the community to feel
appropriately involved and heard uh the
latter
it's not the these
these improvements wouldn't say they're
changes only because I think that the
intent is there it's now it's when their
uh the membership can change uh not
can't does change it's everyone knowing
what's the rules of how to win in this
effort and not having a learning curve
and that then extends the time for a
resolution of of the challenge at hand
now one um things that we worked on the
in the past uh the member with member
McKay and the Pats as well as is
providing the the appropriate services
with
families to maintain home and
community-based Care in New Hampshire
and I'm I'm biased I have a believer
that New Hampshire leads the nation in
that because we believe in
self-responsibility self-respect and
self-determination and we carry it out
by actually doing it
it's not to have it separated by a
bureaucratic wall to say okay now I'll
decide after I've
um not high but I mean an entity will
decide we need full open concept
um communication
because the commitment after the fact is
is where that challenge is and we can't
have uh in again my comment we can't
have families uh leaving this
responsibility and having the
institutionalization of individuals not
just the disability but are aggressively
mature as I say Elder Elders uh when
they need when they can be have Services
provided in the in the home and that has
is has happened in New Hampshire and we
can continue to improve that and um and
I'm and again my in the interest of
disclosure I lived a life I have a
civilian handicapped son we do it at
home ourselves and uh
and it does and working with the state
of New Hampshire and the tremendous
resources we have in our Personnel uh it
it is an added value this is to ensure
that the work they do that the citizens
of being a part of the process have that
commitment to meet what they said
they needed and that the solution is
what they all agree to
foreign
um I think it would be helpful to pass
for those of us who do need it are we
speaking zero four nine one
hey yes ma'am okay a representative yes
yeah apologize for that I I miss some I
thought you'd still have the copies I
should know better
how many documents you must handle some
of us have them some of them have them
us have them electronically but it's a
lot easier to make notes on them when
we're discussing them right now yeah
representative uh Shapiro can I just say
that when I went up to pick up those
amendments
um on the fourth floor they had another
amendment for on House Bill 238 but the
the woman up there said she didn't have
any idea whose Amendment it was but it's
printed so if anybody else
that that was my attempt at a potential
rules change so that we would have that
as something to look at if it was of
interest thank you
thank you representative bubber
I was wondering if we could talk a
little bit about the the issue I mean it
seems to me that the
real nub here is uh page two lines 26 to
29 so the significant changes proposed
relating to or may impact the practice
of policy standards rates budgets
funding formula or rights
that's that's the concern in a NAB and
then the question of
uh how to participate in the contract
and bidding process sounded to me from
the testimony like it was a little bit
more problematical both from the point
of view of potential conflicts of
interests
and from the point of view of how long
is this process going to take because
the last thing we want to do is add more
time to an already
lengthy and and involved process so I
guess I guess for me I'm I'm very happy
with the addition of number three on 27
to 30. but I wonder if we need to talk a
little bit more about section four which
is the bidding
the bidding process
um thank you that actually is one of
those areas that the department had had
brought up some significant concerns
around and knowing that
knowing that while we have while it's a
relatively large community it's a small
community as well yeah and if we have
people who are involved that are
precluded from offering Services because
they're part of a non-disclosure
agreement and a non-compete where they
can't participate in them
um I I personally question whether
that's going to end up serving the
interests more because if you're working
on the consulting or service contract
and then maybe up to up to bid on that
that that presents a lot of different
challenges and potentials for conflict
well representative Shapiro
microphone please I know that the two
issues here are um
from my experience with the dental bill
last year when I called to inquire about
how the bidding was going I was told we
can't tell you anything because it's a
totally confidential process and if if
if it gets messed up we have to start
all over from scratch on the other hand
I know that the this bill was written
and parked because there was a contract
written with this Consulting
organization and the council felt that
they had no impact no
input into how that was done
whether it was done who it was done with
and so there's kind of competing
um elements here
um I think
part of what drove this bill is that
they very much want to have some input
into
if another contract is created how it's
created with who it's created so I don't
know how we solved the problem but I
think that those are the two aspects of
the issue
my suggestion for drafting would be
to take to keep
the standard in in free which which
really talks about any changes coming up
they they get to comment on and keeping
the requirement on page three that when
the council has concerns the department
must respond in writing to those
concerns so that gets us part way to
being able to express a concern and
having a response to a concern if we
would people then be
comfortable taking out
the paragraph four about the bidding
contracts and
feel comfortable enough with what was
left
starting at paragraph five
and that that that may not be as much as
people want in terms of involvement with
the bidding process but the bidding
process being as it is
um I'm concerned that we create as Madam
chair said more problems than we
actually solve
thank you that that is a one point one
of the others I I wonder if there's a
way to carve out those where we're
Contracting with
out-of-state consulting services or if
that's really trying to address a horse
that's already out in the field and if
we're a little bit too late to bring
that into the discussion
I guess representative McMahon do you
have a feel on whether it would be on
what your thoughts are about leaving
that section 4 out
uh yeah well yes and I respect my my
colleague Madam Weber I was called but
representative Weber uh on the issues is
uh I have the same uh concerns in terms
of uh if there's an inherent conflict of
interest uh and so on and that would not
be a person who would uh that's it's
requiring not requiring requesting that
a council member be included is in part
of the process and that's that's um line
36 on page two
and that's the the intent the intent
here is to be part of the process and
not that again not having a conflict of
interest
uh but being participatory so that the
the issues of the reason that the
quality console was put together was and
with a substantial membership as you see
out there is that the interests are
spoken for when the contract then is is
promulgated and so that's why that's
that's there it's not circumventing not
to circumvent what the department is uh
Department of Health and Human Services
needs to deal with when when they uh are
choosing but it's to be part of the
criteria of the choice
because ultimately I mean one it's one
person on this
this this effort from the from the
council as you know that's not a
majority it's not uh it's it's still the
department that would uh be made
ultimately makes the decision but it's
but uh it's ensuring what did not take
place
with the choice of Alvarez and Marcel
there was no participation at all and uh
and whatever criteria that was done was
was not contributed to by the quality
Council which by the intent was to
ensure these the quality and service was
is being as being met
um uh as far as the goal so that's
that's what I offer some reason keep
that in I could modify the drafting
suggestion that I think might fix that
if we kept four
and we kept a which would be confer and
receive input from the Council on
Provisions to be included in a request
for proposal which is item a and we kept
that in
and we took out B which is including the
council member to be part of the
selection process because that's where
we get into the really sticky stuff
but
kept see
because C talks about what the
contractor is going to do after they are
selected and it's getting input
from the council once the contractor is
selected
and that way we keep the council out of
the stickier processes of the beginning
process but get them more specifically
involved at the beginning and after the
selection has been made
with that work for people as a
possibility representative Cushman
thank you I just wanted to say that I
had the exact same thoughts so thank you
for mentioning that I think that that is
a good compromise for that section
representative Shapiro I would second
that is a good solution and also
considering that the Senate will hear
this bill also and there'll be people
from DHHS here there at that when
they're considering it and if it has to
be tweaked a little bit more to make
sure there's no conflict it can be done
then
I think that's a very good point I know
that the department will be very
involved once it gets over to the Senate
does it look like with removing section
B which is lines 36 and 37 on page two
we have something that we feel
comfortable sending to the senate for
um off to the Senate yeah I'd be happy
with that if we just got that one
is there any anybody else who wants has
an opinion here fantastic I think oh
sorry representative Cushman
thank you um
I can't find word oh um just the the
exception to 91a still I don't support
changing what constitutes a quorum I
understand
um
you know
the
um our current law has been found by the
Supreme Court to you know comply with
non-discrimination laws and
um I think that we should keep
Quorum as it is in 91a so that's section
seven that's my only objection to the
bill now
uh thank you very much representative
Cushman that does bring up a very
important Point especially because as we
know being in a room together it's a
little easier to work through some of
the issues but we also it also would be
important to make sure that that people
can be involved especially if they're
going through a particularly challenging
situation they don't have the care
that's necessary to get to the meeting
representative
um I had another bill in another
committee 306 or 308 I'm sorry about
Quorum and remote meeting that it passed
through the committee and it passed
through the house
so uh if that passes through the Senate
and gets signed it allowed a third of
the group had to be in a location and
other people could
zoom in and create a quorum that way but
it did have that it had to be in a
specific location with a third of the
membership present so
that may take care of itself thank you
representative Weber and and that has
certainly happened with any number of
bodies including
performance oversight where somebody
tucked into a budget Bill
a reduction of the quorum to one-third
of the members being present there was
with that no provision for a remote
access but I think that but we have
in the context of legislative work and I
I don't normally like them but I think
that for this population this is a good
compromise between having people in the
room but also making sure that the
population served who may not be able to
get to the room are also included in the
process so we have other legislative
precedent for reducing quorums down to
levels that I'm not comfortable with but
um
it it
does it requires the actual half plus
one Quorum which I'd rather keep and I
think that we're all agreed we want to
keep but it allows for making up that
Quorum uh with people who may not be
able to physically get into the room and
I think that that's a a very important
point with this population if we're
going to be inclusive of the service
recipients rather than uh their
caregiver I mean their caregivers are
great proxies and an important voice but
we also want service recipients included
thank you that is a great point my
question would be if we were to amend
this section
um now section seven to keep the
language that says convened by the chair
or vice chair of the council because we
don't want to leave it to only be
convened by the commissioner of the
department
or their designee and perhaps leave the
existing language I don't know if the
correct wording would be notwithstanding
other statutes
um no the what's here is fine because
it's for the purpose of convening with
91a we're making an exception here
and I think the exception should be here
rather than in 91a because nobody's
going to look to 91a for that so I I'd
leave the I my preference would be to
leave this section exactly as it has
been drafted
my one remaining question would be that
if we already have that in the 91a if
we're if we're echoing it through other
areas whether that creates more
confusion or less if we have a new
standard it
the ability of 91a to convert create
confusion is Legion and various
legislative committees have dealt with
91a in very different ways in very
different places in the statute so if we
contribute our little might to Greater
confusion but also greater access for a
population who needs it I'm real
comfortable with that because I think we
have met the spirit of 91a which is
requiring a quorum and requiring a forum
for votes and requiring a place for
people to come and then we have a way
for people to provide their in input
um and and and it is limited to members
who are not able to be physically
present either due to their disabilities
or the disability of a family member
we're not saying that you can join from
your vacation on your cruise ship that
has Wi-Fi
um so I think that we're making a very
specific and very narrow accommodation
which I think we're probably required to
make under the Ada anyway
um so
um I think that that is useful in this
case and I think we want to have it
right there in the place where
the rules of the council are lodged
rather than somewhere else in the
statute thank you that's very helpful if
we end up having some remaining dissent
within that that's the sort of thing
that can be handled as one of those side
notes as we move this through the
committee process but thank you I think
other than uh potentially just looking
at that language I think we're good with
this one if we get that redrafted to
remove section B
representative Shapiro
I would just offer to have it redrafted
if
um you wish
I think that would be helpful thank you
lovely
no representative pulse off uh I just
want to ask if representative Cushman
has any
those objections to the changes in in
relation to 91a
I don't have any further objections
other than what I've stated
spell should we try to get this for this
afternoon if they could get it for this
afternoon then I think this should be a
very quick vote so that would be very
helpful okay thank you
they have been very resistant to Quick
turnarounds even when it's just excising
something very small so oh yeah good
luck their whole system around it is
very complex so one chain still is
embedded in a very large process so we
can be hopeful but we won't we won't
necessarily count count on it
um oh here yes please that would be
perfect thank you
foreign
yeah
fantastic
um I
so that one looks like we have had some
good success there
um
I guess we'll look at the uh I'll sit on
that we are all set on that one if
you're comfortable with that would you
like your name on that Amendment too oh
please if you could add representative
McMahon to it as well please and what
I'll do do I mean the collaboration with
the authority having jurisdiction over
here uh is I I will bring that myself
right over to them now and and to see
how quickly I can
maybe aggressively motivate a quick
response
so you can so you could have it
immediately you can be persuasive so
that would be very helpful thank you
that's my it's my uh confused the
Snowman days the working copy has to
come back to me because it's my only
copy
I have other copies for you right here
oh okay but uh no we'll do that
yeah
I'll get on in the media and advice
thanks thank you committee thank you
madam chair thank you very much
um thank you I guess now we'll talk
about House Bill 642 which is the salary
caps
um I'm wondering if this one maybe our
correct Bill to retain because we're not
sure really about the correct process on
this and if we do want to have a vehicle
in our pocket for January this might be
the right path I'm just curious if
there's any anybody who disagrees with
that path or wants to discuss it further
this is uh the house bill 642 is the
relative to prohibiting the department
from enforcing salary caps for direct
care workers
representative Shapiro for whatever it's
worth I will just say that I got stopped
in the hallway and said I don't
understand what your committee is doing
because everyone agreed on these bills
when uh seemed to agree on these bills
um
when the hearings happened so I I don't
know if you want to invite other
comments or not that's completely up to
you oh yes if there's other comment I I
absolutely welcome that
sorry representative Weber
I was just going to say that what I
heard was that everybody with that bill
specifically the salary cap bill
um and I'm having trouble finding the
copy that I took notes on but my
recollection was that everybody was
concerned about it but about half the
people affected said that they really
wanted this because things were bad and
half the people said they didn't want it
because things were bad and they were
afraid it would make it worse
so you know I'd be glad to hear
other comments oh thank you I think
there was some discussion back and forth
on that and a lot of this was around
putting those Protections in place but
currently there is no cap on these
um
and Our intention would be
to through the Health and Human Services
oversight committee to make sure that
they're not that the department isn't
engaging in any practices that will put
a cap on it going forward in these
rulemaking processes representative
Shapiro I have no opinion about this but
um
I think the person was talking about the
all three of the additional bills rather
than just one of them but oh thank you
so it's your your decision about whether
to let other people speak or not thank
you I do think that having a vehicle to
retain this um like
I I don't think that having salary caps
in rules would be consistent with the
legislation that's already in place and
that is an objection that I would raise
and gel car when the rules come through
so holding on to this while knowing that
we currently don't have them and there's
nothing that enables those salary caps
right now
um I think would give us protection at
least through January in order to make
sure that salary caps are not enacted
before then and if necessary we can come
back with this
representative Nagel so by holding you
mean retaining yes retaining this
potentially we don't need to make a
definite decision on this right now but
but that that seems like that might be a
good process that would allow us to move
other other portions further further
representative McLean no okay I just
think no I agree this is a great Bill uh
to retain I think everybody say hey this
has to be a way to modify these budgets
but what's the best way to do it so and
I think I think the only ones we have to
for sure get done because of the
compliance issues are 608 and 317 right
so those are the only two of this group
we have to absolutely get done
um 317 actually is not part of the
federal compliance so that was something
where there is more time this the
intention
the intention with that is to make sure
that they're involved in that process
and creating a new committee so if we
want to talk about 317 next yeah I would
favor retaining 642. okay fantastic
thank you so I I think that um I think
we're probably in favor of retaining 642
so that's helpful
can't take action on that for another
hour and 12 minutes but that's all right
um looking at the waiver system
um
three House Bill 317 this is about
creating a commission to study this
process
um my question would be
it's very difficult very complex
situation
um
whether this makes sense to then move
this forward so that this is continuing
it's one of those areas where there's
clearly a focus about having involvement
my reading of the equality Council would
show that they have the opportunity to
be involved in this discussion and this
planning I'm not sure if having a
separate commission makes more sense
than having this be part of the work of
the quality Council but I personally
find it to be an important topic to
discuss
I know we're not supposed to send on
notional bills but I know this is
something that needs to be addressed I'm
not sure if a commission is correct but
but
if the Senate believes if if the Senate
believes that it should be part of the
quality Council perhaps then it would be
addressed that way or that this is taken
up through oversight or already within
the the bounds of the quality Council
and their current power to do so so I'm
curious about any comments on that
representative Palmer
yeah as I was looking at this my thought
and and I remember thinking this the day
we were hearing these bills is that
there's so much going on that maybe this
should just be left left in the
background for now and and the quality
Council can take it up but not not start
a separate thing where people are trying
to figure this out before they even know
how the rest of everything's going to go
and so just sort of saying you know
bring this back after the dust is
settled from the major changes that are
going to start well sometime after July
1st I thought that was just my thought
thank you so your thought would be to
retain this so that we can see what's
necessary moving forward
thank you representative Weber
um well the
other thing that I have in my notes
is
um somebody's comment
about
um
not looking at the wrong button bucket
and the the service plan
is the issue not
I think that I think there's a huge
concern about the two-tier
stuff because we have currently a plan
that for all its faults
has an enormous amount of elasticity in
it
and yes it's it's elasticity of too
little resources
and too few workers to help and it's got
lots of problems
but
I think that the sense I was getting is
that people are very
concerned about
um
well this all goes back to the a m
report that people are very upset about
but uh the tears are something that I
think in that report was was
particularly troubling to people so I I
think that that was less I mean
please correct me if I'm wrong the sense
that I got that was less the uh wanting
to transition to two-tier system and
um how to how to do that than wanting to
be sure that either we didn't do it or
that we did it with the least harm
possible
so and I'm not sure that
and maybe there's somebody out there who
can help me with this that you know
whether whether or not this transition
is something that might be happening in
the next six months would be very much
determinative to me about what we did
about it
thank you I'm representative Nagle and
then yeah my my recollection of this was
quite profound that the consumers
did not like this system at all
and I understand that a counselor a
committee or whatever
it may come to a decision that's a
rotten idea but it's clear that the
people in the council
thank you representative Palmer yeah and
I was just saying my experience with
buckets both in the school system and I
was a on the school board and also
there's a system in Vermont that with
Medicaid that you can have some home
services or not and almost always people
don't fit in the right bucket and you're
stuck and they don't their only
alternative is to go to a nursing home
because they don't quite tick off all
the boxes so I kind of hate that that
approach
thank you I
I do see this also stemming from the
consultant report and everything that is
moving forward from that
um that's actually part of why I thought
it made sense to include these three
bills in this work session because it's
608 sort of seems to be the Super bill
that deals with this and that would put
a pause on the two-tier waiver system
along with anything else that is not
part of that so my question would be if
we would retain this and then look to
put a pause on the two-tier system until
after the other Federal compliance is
done through House Bill 608 so that we
don't start adding huge system changes
in while we're still trying to deal with
a direct bill and the conflict-free case
management of course the other side of
this is when you're already redesigning
it to make it work with account for the
free case management are you going to
build a system that's then going to get
torn down in order to revise it again so
we're a bit you know trying to figure
out which one's the chicken which one is
the egg but without a waiver we're left
dealing with the reality on the ground
I don't know if there's any other
comments on this one
foreign
would be specifically what are you
proposing because I
um I I too am stuck in the Chicken and
the Egg problem and it's not a problem
that I'm sure I see us
being able to deal with effectively
legislatively uh both because of the
timelines involved because uh something
has to happen by July and and
um
I don't know if there's anybody here who
could talk to waiver issues or or
anything like that but I I'd love to
hear it because that's that's what I was
hearing from the people who have talked
to me outside of the committee
um
in terms of the impossibility of their
being able to be up and running with
something that's going to work on July
1st so and and
I would love
to hear about that more fantastic thank
you very much thank you for being here
and being able to help us out with some
insight yes thank you so much for having
me I'm Melissa Hardy I'm the director
for the division of long-term supports
and services which the Bureau of
Developmental Services is a part of
so specifically to this bill here
um it is not part of any compliance date
for the 7-1 compliance for CMS so this
was
um like you said a recommendation from
the a m report
um that the state look at a two-tiered
waiver system
we heard from our stakeholders early
last year that you know there were
significant concerns about that process
and so we as the department
decided to put a pause on any
development as it relates to the
two-tier system so we can focus on the
federal requirements of direct Bill and
conflict of interest we have not picked
any work up as as it relates to the
two-tier system we haven't looked at it
since we put it on pause I believe in
may we don't have any plans of picking
it up anytime soon because of all of our
um
work with being in compliance with CMS
and certainly if it was part of a
discussion that we were going to move
forward we would engage our stakeholder
groups like we're doing with our other
pieces of the redesign so having the
area agencies providers individuals and
families be able to speak with us and
tell us does this make sense for New
Hampshire's families or not
so thank you representative Weber so my
question would be because we've now
moved on to 608 which is the pilot
program
um
how does the pilot program help or not
help the compliance issue
I would say the pilot program is post's
compliance issue so things that we would
pilot would be after our compliance
statement with direct Bill and
conflict-free case management so things
were currently developing new rates for
Service delivery we're developing new
waiver services in our waiver and all of
that work would be part of what we would
recommend at least as part of that pilot
work after 7-1
but
but I guess maybe maybe this just isn't
part of this conversation so I'll hold
it till Friday at Health and Human
Services oversight but
um
I got the sense that what we were trying
to do here was
to
help well was was to ensure that as we
were complying we were also not creating
more more problems or Worse system
um
if
If This Were Bill were to pass as it is
or slightly amended uh would it get in
the way
of the work that needs to be done before
July 1st let's let's start out that way
I believe so because of the bandwidth
that we have at the department in our
tight time frames to meet those two
Federal compliance issues that this is
not part of that compliance piece of our
work so it wouldn't be
um necessary to do
um and I I also believe that part of
this bill or this two-tier
um
recommendation from a m could be part of
either the piloting process in 608 or
part of that discussion
thank you um
do you believe will the compliance be in
place on July 1st and would be getting
this after that date of July 1st makes
sense so that once that compliance is in
place then there could be a turn and
focus to this issue yeah even after
um the compliance on 7-1 there's a lot
of steps that we would need to do in
order to make sure that compliance is
rolled out correctly so I think even if
this was on the agenda it would be far
down the line after 7-1 it's not
something that we're actively focusing
on
do you have any idea of what time frame
that would be
I mean I don't even think we would pick
it up until earliest 2024.
they feel that's helpful representative
McLean
just a quick question on the two-tier
system I mean we heard a lot about the
elasticity of the current system and a
lot of opposition from people to it so
what was the main driver in the a m
report
um that said you know you should go to
this
thank you for your question
um for in the a m report it talked about
people with different levels of service
need so creating a two-tiered system for
folks that have lesser needs that cost
less would be on one waiver
um and then our one tier and then people
who have more complex medical behavioral
health or need a higher level of care
would be on the second waiver
yes or tier so so I understand that part
you know but
um could that not be done within the
existing frame because there's a certain
amount of elasticity that you give up by
going to this yeah that's what we're
doing so right now that's what we do we
have the one waiver where folks um uh
are all on who who receive developmental
Services I think the other piece in the
a m report that you'll see is that they
suggested people on the lesser of the
tier and I'm not saying lesser needing
lesser Services would could possibly
have a cap on those services so I think
that was from families and individuals
if you're on a lower tier your budget or
you would be capped at a at a at a rate
or an overall budget and I think that
was the a major concern from families
with that suggestion from a m
thank you and appendix B of the research
provided by Christina jayer actually has
a lot of information on that background
I had help knowing that it starts at
page 17.
um are there yes representative Nagel
thank you
um am I supposed to say thanks for
taking my question it's more of a
discussion because it's a work session
you don't have to thank me okay anyways
I made it quite clear at the hearing I'm
not a big fan of a two-tier system I I
deal with Shades of Gray and I'm really
concerned about that but at the same
point um you know Consultants come up
with ideas not out of thin air there's
other places that have experience with
using this kind of system and I'm just
wondering if a commission
what would be the best way to look at
how other states other counties other
whatevers have used that kind of system
would it be in a commission or would it
be through already existing ways of
looking at decide whether that kind of
system has any value for us at all
I mean that's a great question I think
part of the a m report looked at other
states and how they have different tiers
and waivers now I'm not saying that's
the way New Hampshire should go or not
so
um just I think hearing the the
concerns and questions from families
there's a lot that we should address
before we consider
implementing any sort of two-tiered
system
thanks
yes representative co-fault sorry this
long table makes it hard
so I just want to be clear that I
understand so the so the bill is written
essentially would put a put a hold on
the current project and said say do do
this pilot project instead starting July
1st 2023
um am I am I understanding that
correctly or am I missing I'm not sure
if we're talking about 608 or three
seven I'm sorry we're still well I guess
um we're still sort of blending that
area yeah 2017. it seems to me might
prohibit um proceeding until there's
until this Council has a recommendation
um okay and I think 608 does as well so
I actually was asking about the language
in 608
um but the but the idea of a so so did I
misunderstand when you said sort of
doing a pilot program would be deferred
that's something that you really would
not be able to get to doing until 2024.
right okay yeah as we're focusing on our
compliance with CMS those are the direct
Bill and conflict-free case management
are a rail to
um work streams right now
um so anything that really isn't related
to those things are in the future and
would be part of the 608 pilot okay yeah
I guess my my concern is just to Echo
what representative Nagel said is that
there's there's a general sense that the
system isn't working for people and
there's a
um
there's a sense among people in the DD
community that
their voices are not necessarily being
heard and I think that's what I'm
grappling with I think it's a lot of
what a lot of people here are grappling
with is what is the appropriate way
forward to make sure that that happens
and so
um yeah I guess I'm I'm open to to
hearing suggestions as to how how that
could proceed I mean the the previous
bill that we just sent off an amendment
for I think would
increase stakeholder involvement and
ensure that there are some voices being
heard but that's the general concern I
think that that Echoes through all of
these bills and how do we make sure that
those people have a voice and
um I mean with with many of these
systems it's it's sort of necessarily A
top-down design process and that that
isn't anybody's fault it's just you know
it's it's we're dealing with large
complex systems that are applied across
a large population and nevertheless that
that's the that's what we're struggling
with so
um I guess I'm I'm open to hearing
suggestions as to how that could how
that stakeholder engagement could be
improved
so I think as the department we've been
really taking an active role in going
out into the community to talk to
individuals and families about their
concerns and we heard we hear them
um uh so I think you know I think we've
had over 200 different stakeholders
whether that stakeholder engagements
whether that's with individuals and
families with providers with area
agencies so we can be transparent with
this work and have them be a part of the
redesign process since it is their daily
lives and so you know I think again
where the concern is is that we have two
Federal requirements that we have to
meet by seven one or are funding could
our federal funding could be at risk and
then the other recommendations that were
in the a m
report could be piloted could be
discussed after you know that 7-1
deadline
I think representative Weber
I'm now back to really basic question
which is I'm I'm reading in 608 uh the
first paragraph
and it says the commissioner shall not
Implement a BDS redesign prior to July
1st 2024. so that
prohibits something happening
and my question is
are the two things that we need to do by
July 1st not part of the BDS redesign
are they not part of the total redesign
and if we say we're not going to do any
redesign until 2024 are we not
shutting down the work that has to be
done by July 1st and I think that's the
Department's concern with the language
in 608 because the a m report and we had
suggested and provided some
um uh
some suggested language for kind of
changing how 608 was written
um
so we at the department feel that
it's unclear in the in the legislation
if
whoever
um came up with it wanted the the two
CMS requirements part of this or not
um and the Department's standpoint is
that the CMS regulations were not part
of the a m work
um the a m work really was looking at
the two-tier waiver system looking at
the reimbursement system and how that's
how that can be improved so I guess it's
not clear to even us in this legislation
if the purpose is to stall the seven one
work or just not just but the work that
hasn't um that would be after the seven
one work
well I I guess my concern and and
um I'm hoping maybe that you would send
us again because I have lost somewhere
in the mall of either my emails or my
paper
the specific wording language is because
they're not stable to this so I can't
find them
um if or if somebody else has them
that's Grand uh but
the the real concern that I have is that
we're not using language that might
forestall
the work that we know has to be done
right by July 1st or
or something has to happen and I I I
implore the bureau to hear
the pain of the providers who are trying
to figure out how to implement it's it's
March and they're trying to figure out
how they are going to implement
something in July for which guidelines
have not yet been written and software
has not yet been bought
and
they're feeling true Panic
which is probably not news to you but
I'm going to say it again anyway
um about how they're going to deal with
that and how services are actually going
to get billed and paid for starting on
seven two so
um
but that's not this bill I just I'm
concerned that this bill may be placing
yet another roadblock in the way
representative Nagel do you have a
comment
s um
I'm just there were two separate
conversations about I mean now I'm at
608. about this bill within this room
and then out there and the emotions were
dramatically different
um I was told by one group of people
that we don't have a choice because of
seven one that this needs to pass and
then I was told by another group of
people mostly consumers
that um number one there was a lot of
anger over the A and M how they were
picked what their what their criteria
were everything
and they said that 608 is not necessary
we don't need to do it and I'm kind of
lost like what kind of deadline are we
facing what
um
that that's what's the problem is for me
because when I talk to the one group oh
yeah we better pass this now and the
other group said no so what do we do
yeah I would say we did draft some
language for an amendment for 608
um I don't know if the the group or the
committee here has that but what we as
the department would really recommend is
that we pilot to test the
recommendations of the a m report that
would include again we talked a lot
about the tiered waiver any tiered
reimbursement rates
and then looking at our I.T system so
that would exclude the work that is
necessary to be completed for our 7-1
deadline can I ask a follow-up yes so um
there was a lot of faith um put in the
possibility that the federal the CSM or
whoever would um give us a deadline uh
extend the deadline is that realistic
in our opinion no we've had multiple
deadlines since 20 uh multiple
extensions since 2017 to be in
compliance we have however I will say we
haven't specifically asked that question
to CMS but with all of the information
and feedback that we're getting we do
not anticipate them giving us an
extension
for seven one
thank you so uh yes representative Weber
so what's going to happen on 7-1 because
people say they just can't
they they're
really unclear and and you know the
people I've been talking to who are
doing the providing and the billing
as opposed to the service recipients but
it's going to impact the service
recipients
if there aren't
billing systems in place
so so and I'm sorry madam chair you can
rule me out of order because I
understand this is beyond the scope of
this bill but I really want to know
what's going to happen between now and 7
1 to fix the problem so we are having an
I I think that that's actually the core
of this bill because there's the fear
over how this is going to happen and
what's going to come from it so I can to
answer your question I can say that the
billing software
um through the state people the
providers can access that directly or
they can purchase their own software we
are focusing
um our efforts on the provider side of
the requirements for 7-1 at this time
whether that's enrolling them as direct
Medicaid providers which is part of the
direct Bill process
um talk I think today we're actually
having a provider meeting with the
department and the the providers of the
developmental Services System to go over
any sort of training needs concerns that
they have and walk them through any of
their processes that might need to be
altered due to the direct Bill process
thank you representative McLean
thank you so so the part that you're
gonna let's say that the pilot doesn't
even exist at this point so the part
that you're going to roll out for July
1st is what it's going to be the direct
billing uh how the area agencies are
compensated
um and uh rates is that going to be a
part of that too or just yeah so you're
exactly right so the direct billing
would be part of the 7-1 deadline the
other piece of seven one is
conflict-free case management where a
provider cannot be
um
cannot be in conflict with providing
services and be the direct biller of
those Services
yes what does that mean in
um so that means you know as far as the
conflict of interest you're talking
about yes
so the the air as of right now the area
agencies are the service coordinators uh
so they meet with the families
determined with the families
um the services that
um our family member an individual would
need and currently they also have all of
the billing processes that go along with
those services so CMS says you cannot be
a case man uh Service Coordination and
deliver Direct Services because there
could be a conflict of interest there
thankful that's um definitely helpful I
do know that there is also a waiver that
Medicaid that CMS offers and that is the
only qualified and willing bidder yes um
I had received some feedback back from
the Department that that was only a
one-term one year process but I was
reviewing some guidance documents from
CMS that suggested that because this is
due to rural areas like we have lack of
providers like we have that that
actually could be an ongoing waiver to
allow those conflicts in those cases and
so my question would be if we could
pursue a longer term waiver about the
only willing and qualified in order to
deal with this conflict especially in
those regions where there is an issue
can I ask my bureau chief to come up and
answer the question she's she knows more
about the only willing and provider oh
only willing provider
hi I'm Sandy Pharos I'm the bureau chief
at the Bureau of Developmental services
and thank you for the opportunity to
speak with the committee um with regard
to the only willing and qualified
provider waiver or allowance
it is up to a year and in New Hampshire
we have very select areas that qualify
as rural we have a map that we reference
that includes which areas are considered
Rural and the challenge
prior to the pandemic
I think only willing and qualified
provider definition would have
been more challenging because now we
have the option to provide remote
support so the argument could be made
that there are willing and qualified
providers that can provide services in a
remote
way
so I would have to demonstrate to CMS
that there are no willing and qualified
providers
that could be remote or in person so
with that allowance it it widens our
provider Network so to speak and so
every year we will go back we'll review
Who falls under that criteria under that
policy and then renew it if needed so we
could certainly extend an existing
waiver or renew it for another year but
we do have to demonstrate that there are
no willing and qualified providers to
provide the service
uh representative Weber and is part of
that determination
also ensuring that the recipient is able
to receive the Services remotely because
that's a real bar
in a lot of our rural areas and frankly
I don't need to live in that rural of an
area and it's a bar in my area big time
yes it's it's better now that we have uh
fiber optic installation in our town but
for many towns that have not taken that
route
there are an awful lot of houses and
pretty
unrural places that have no meaningful
access to remote treatment options or
remote supervision options yes okay good
representative Nagel thank you thank you
you may have already answered my
question but um I actually have two
questions the first one is who actually
determines if there's a conflict
if there's a cut well we would take a
look at the individual receiving
services and determine if the same
agency provides a direct service and
Service Coordination to that individual
currently we're asking area agencies to
self-report how many people they have in
conflict and we have a pretty
significant bell curve some agencies are
not unconflicted at all and some have
significant conflict and so that
self-assessment and self-report is
coming from the area agencies to the
bureau
and um you had mentioned that there was
an amendment that you'd prepared for 608
where is that now I've actually sent a
copy of that I found it in our email and
I sent that to Christina I'm not sure if
you could print that out I probably
should have let you know that I emailed
it to you thank you
see so this is uh definitely important
information trying to figure this out I
have another question for you as well
how much of the a m report has already
been implemented in the state
or is anything been implemented from
that
should I just
I would say that the
waiver the assessment of waiver Services
is underway we have a couple of
different work groups that are looking
at a m recommendations specifically the
rates work group and then we have the
waiver work group and then we have those
two work groups reporting up to an
advisory committee that looks at the
work of the two work groups and makes
recommendations to us at the bureau so I
would say the rates work is underway the
waiver work is underway
their recommendation around I.T
development is underway we're working
with Deloitte which is our contracted
agency to manage New Heights which is an
existing system to make updates to that
system to allow for
direct Bill and for other updates
to happen and so that is underway and we
have Myers and stoffer who is another
contractor that's working on rates with
our rates work group
there are other recommendation around
its capacity is a little behind the
other work but we are
working towards that as well to try to
build capacity in our state
that is definitely helpful my other
question is actually reminding us back
to 317
when I'm looking at this it looks like
it's actually not just the two-tier
waiver system if you look at on page one
line 25 it says the commission shall
study the feasibility of transitioning
from the current single waiver to a tier
two-tiered waiver system and other
recommendations from the review of the
New Hampshire developmental disabilities
service system by Alvarez and Marshall
public sector Services my question would
be if that passed and this commission
was in place would you adopt any more of
the recommendations without consultation
with that commission for any of the a m
changes and not just the two-tier waiver
system
I know I'm putting you on the spot I
apologize this is such a complex topic
that we're all trying to learn the best
we can to to do the best we can and not
mess things up
so the question is if the commission is
established would we move forward with
the other work outside of the two-tier
waiver piece if the commission is
established which is charged with the
waiver and other recommendations would
you implement any additional
recommendations and make any significant
changes with the rates waiver in it
without consultation of that Commission
um well I I we would move forward with
the work if there's no opposition to it
there's
there's stakeholder work groups that are
engaged in the work at this time and we
have taken their recommendations
on board specifically regarding the
two-tier waiver where we were finding
that lots of our stakeholders didn't
really understand home and
community-based Care waiver requirements
or many of the practices that we've done
for years at the state so we were we
realized we were doing education through
stakeholder engagement which really
required putting a pause on the
two-tiered waiver so
relative to our other work if we needed
to take a step back and review it we
would take that on board from our
advisory committee
and I think you know like you pointed
out in in 317 the concern that we would
have
as far as any other recommendations that
would be limiting us to like like Sandy
said building capacity in New Hampshire
for bringing people back who have
intensive treatment needs so there were
other
um recommendations in the a m report
that we would want to move forward with
such as building that capacity in New
Hampshire so people who need intensive
treatment services can receive them in
New Hampshire rather than us paying and
sending people to Florida or Nebraska to
receive those services so that line that
you pointed out representative Leon is
concerning if it's not just about the
two-tier system
um
I guess I'm trying to understand why if
something's not contentious of it coming
to the commission and them saying great
this is wonderful please proceed versus
having a concern to address how that
would would limit any of these consensus
recommendations as opposed to finding
those where there's opposition
so I think we have we are we already
have an established advisory committee
that
um could you actually tell me the makeup
of that advisor what it's called in the
makeup of that because that's
it is called the BDS systems work
advisory committee and you might know
the the makeup better than I do but it's
comprised of Area Agency representation
providers
um individuals with disabilities
families
um that have
um and loved ones with disabilities and
some of the other advocacy groups on our
website at lists who is a part of each
of our committee and what their role is
so that's a department commission it's
not a right it's not a legislative no no
you won't find it on our website it's on
our website yeah yes and is there an is
there any specific oversight of that
with the oversight committee
to actually representative Weber might
know that better do you have do you have
a working relationship with that group
through oversight not to my knowledge
but I don't have knowledge of all of the
um do you come is that one of the things
that reports to Health and Human
Services oversight
on a regular basis I didn't think so no
however we do as um part of the quality
Council that we were talking about
before has representation
um on the advisory committee
but we do not report out any right thing
to Health and Human Services as far as
the advisory committee less were asked
thank you that is absolutely helpful
um but I I noticed that representative
Pearson is in the back and probably
listening carefully yes
and it's the chair of the Health and
Human Services oversight committee and
also somebody who's worked a lot on this
process so if representative Pearson if
there's anything where you have Insight
that you want to share with us let us
know so that we can bring you up
thank you
fantastic okay so this one would so
looking at 317 that would be
something that almost would be working
similar to what you've already
established as a department commission a
department advisory Council and this
would be one that's involving the
legislature within that
thank you that's that's helpful for us
as we understand this process now thank
you for indulging me to bounce to 317
getting back to 608 and looking at this
pilot pro project so basically right now
the only checks on the implementation of
the a m process is that internal
department advisory Council and the
decisions within the department
or are there other checks that I'm
missing
no I would say you're correct in you
know as we either make decisions
at the bureau level or have decisions to
be made they are brought to the advisory
committee
thank you and are those brought to
Health and Human Services oversight as
well not currently okay
I'm going to have other questions but
I'm sure there's other people as well
representative McLean
so I mean so I think what you're
advocating then is if we're going to
Pilot something we're going to Pilot the
a m recommendations after the
implementation
right after yeah it would be after the
seven one yeah July
um so so so the Cs the CMS part which we
talked about that has to be July one you
know and in in the absence of a pilot
um
what work are you doing
you know are you planning to yes I'm
going to have this stuff done by May
30th and so we're going to have a month
of debug and we're working with the area
area agencies and providers on this so I
guess what is the rollout plan prior to
July 1st if you're not
having the pilot
so in our advisory committee most
recently we did kind of lay out some of
the concerns that we have or or
potential roadblocks for 7-1 and what
our contingency plan might be for some
of those roadblocks so for example if
there's a provider that didn't get their
application in on time to be able to
direct Bill what would we do as a
department
so we had that robust conversation with
our advisory committee to talk about
what would be a contingency plan so
services are not stalled or changed for
the individual in the community so
something like that we would either stay
status quo with the area agency's
billing knowing that that's not in
compliance with CMS or we could do
something as quick as getting somebody
as in our provider enrollment Department
to focus on that one provider to get
them enrolled within a certain time
frame
um so that won't be one of the issues
yes thanks so so what you're saying if I
understand it is that if there is a
breakdown in the rollout on July 1st
then the default remains in place
and CMS is okay with that
I don't know if I wouldn't say CMS would
be okay with that I think from our from
our standpoint as the department it's
the right thing to do for the individual
and family uh we would certainly take it
on a case-by-case basis we're not we're
not expecting a big implosion but if
there are concerns that come up we want
to make sure that the services are not
interrupted for our families
representative Shapiro
yes in regard to 608 is there any reason
why the department can't do
um
pilot programs on some of these new
ideas without this legislation
no so what does this legislation do does
it prevent you from making permanent
changes without doing the pilots
I would I would think so I think that
was the this I didn't we weren't part of
the drafting so I you know I think
that's probably part of the spirit of
the bill
um you know but we are very open and
have communicated that you know anything
that's not related to 71 compliance
we're willing to Pilot and have
stakeholder feedback and you could do
that without this legislation correct
thank you thank you representative Weber
so
um going back a question before
representative Shapiro's
um reminded me that one of the things I
was told when I was talking to people
outside of this room was that one of the
things that the area agencies have been
able to do in the past
which may actually be some of the things
that we're concerned about with respect
to conflict of interest but what they
were able to do that was very practical
is because they have a cushion of
funding
they were able to pay providers and wait
for
them to be reimbursed and one of the
concerns that I'm hearing out there is
if you're a small provider in your
direct billing and as we have heard from
say the ophthalmologists nobody pays you
for six months and you have to pay the
people who are actually doing the work
what is this system going to do about
that at that point
um so we we have talked about having
um I don't know what we would call it a
contingency fund where we would either
pay if they the provider wasn't able to
um bill on time or there was a billing
issue due to the system's change that we
would pay them
um what happens now is there's a whole
prior authorization process that goes
through the area agencies then the area
agencies then pay the providers and we
recognize that because of some of the
I.T and Personnel issues on the
department side that process is very
manual with these system changes it
makes it more automated in our new
heights system to push payments out
quicker so part of Again part of the
redesign is is addressing that concern
with the area agencies could be sitting
on hundreds of thousands of dollars from
waiting for us to push through that
paper process to pay them and then what
they have done is and gratefully so that
the area agencies have passed on the the
payment to the providers pending
anything pending from us
okay
um in my reading of discussing with this
with people outside of this and in my
reading of the CMS guidelines
um it seems that another one of the
possibilities and I'm from the financial
world so sorry for throwing finance and
another possibility is to create a
Statewide Fiscal Agent that works in
collaboration with the organized
Healthcare delivery system and that then
having that entity that wouldn't be
dealing with are severely overburdened
Department in a process that could be
outsourced would be a way for them to
basically indemnify the timing of
payments and allow that to function as a
fiscal intermediary and billing system
which really seems to be what that job
and role would be and trying to work
with that in order to get to have an RFP
for a fiscal limited Fiscal Agent to
implement the system because then a lot
of those other processes become
contingent upon them and the contract
that that's created and so we're not
dealing with people in the department
who then can't Implement something else
that's necessary or deal with another
process that we have and so I'm curious
about the willingness of the department
the willingness to look at it to do an
RFP and pursue a path of a limited
Fiscal Agent instead of trying to do it
all in-house
can you answer that
so I can speak from the bureau's
perspective I I have been a part of the
procurement process and it is very
time consuming I don't know if we could
turn that around by July 1 which is our
our compliance date I don't think that
would be completely off the table
um I do just want to kind of reframe if
if we look outside of the Bureau of
Developmental Services the state of New
Hampshire has a system where providers
are Medicaid enrolled and they bill mmis
directly so we're not building something
from scratch right now per se we're
expanding our existing platform to allow
new providers in and so that's been
helpful because we have a great resource
in Deloitte to train providers to bring
them online to really align them with
practice amongst other providers across
the state of New Hampshire there's
always challenges relative to provider
payment that we understand and we want
to try to solve those issues whether
that be on the side of the department or
on the side of the provider not
submitting a clean claim so so that
education piece is very important
and that's really where we're putting
our Focus right now
but if we want to explore that it
wouldn't be off the table oh thank you
it does seem like we do have limited
resources and especially personal
resources I'm not sure how many hundreds
hundreds of positions remain unfilled
overall representative Weber
and I'm I'm just exploring the
countervailing argument to that because
I'm not necessarily opposed to that
depending on how it's structured but the
the things that I have seen over the
course of my time here is we have a lot
of things that we contracted out to
people who have their own Workforce
problem I'm thinking of service link for
example where they simply do not have
the capacity to meet the tasks they've
been given and so the services that they
are providing to our
constituents although useful are nowhere
near as useful as they might be if they
actually had enough people to implement
them the other concern I have with
shopping it out is for example I have
seen the shopping out of an education
accounts program where 10 percent of the
money is going into the price process
into the pocket of the people who are
administering the program and and that
seems to me to be
counterproductive so
um
it's it's it
from my perspective if you're looking at
it it needs to be very carefully
implemented and and implemented in a way
that they can actually deliver the
services that we're Contracting for
or that we're hoping
um
but luckily that's one we don't have to
actually solve today
yeah well and one of the fortunate
things is this is more of a financial
instrument and a financial product as
opposed to trying to it is Contracting
with our different service providers
within the state but that's a much
smaller discrete base than trying to
look at this is true looking at
educational processes so the margins
would be far smaller for that which
would be appropriate
um I still I still remain concerned with
these waivers and seeking another waiver
this is a lot for us to do and when I
was looking at the history of the
waivers I know the Department's been
overburdened but it doesn't the amount
of progress in the statements to CMS
just leaves me a little bit concerned
that we'd be better served seeking
another two-year extension with a
specific plan in place where we've
enabled that we're we're going to be
pursuing this path this is how we're
going to achieve compliance and we need
to take these specific steps with these
specific action not dates not with
creating the process but the actual
implementation steps and I think that
that might be a lot safer for our entire
community and also you know we don't
know what the specific Workforce issues
are going to be within the department in
the next couple months let's say let's
say we have a little Reawakening of
covet and we have people out again that
might end up being the thing that ends
up derailing this compliance and being a
little more forward-looking with the
process I think would be reasonable is
that something where the department
would be willing to pursue another
waiver with a specific plan to achieve
true compliance at that two-year date
I think we'd have to take that back to
our senior leadership because of all of
the investment we've made all leading up
to this so I don't think we can speak to
that at this time but we can follow up
thank you that's helpful representative
Palmer yeah and and my question would be
are you particularly all the
stakeholders are you far enough into
this where if you back off now and then
say we're going to wait another they're
all going to be even more
thrown off
then if then if you're already thinking
that you can meet these two goals by
July 1st mostly and get that out of the
way
I mean that has certainly been our
message to the stakeholders and the
providers that we feel that we can meet
71 not to say that it's going to be a
perfect implementation but to meet our
you know minimum federal requirements on
7-1 and then look at some of these other
a m recommendations other
recommendations from the advisor
advisory committee after we work out any
concerns from that compliance date
and my understanding would be with the
waiver that we don't have to wait until
that last possible date that if we had
the waiver and we were able to implement
it a week later or six months later that
there'd be nothing to prohibit us from
from coming into clients sooner is that
correct or
I would have to look into that I think
it probably gives a kind of Drop Dead
date but you could probably get it done
sooner than probably
um they would allow that thank you
representative Weber
and I'm just going to add my two cents
because I I find myself very much in
agreement with representative Leon on
this um you know what we're hearing is
oh yeah we're going to be compliant by
July 1st except that we aren't and we've
got systems set up to
just you know we're going to have people
who are not going to be in compliance so
we're just going to muddle along a
little longer and from this side of the
bench
it it feels a lot safer getting a waiver
in that circumstance rather than saying
oh yeah we're going to meet the waiver
except that some people aren't uh which
feels to me to be really risky
um as a as a way of approaching the
problem so
um and I realized that that's really
outside of our wheelhouse but it's it's
a matter of huge concern I know
certainly in our communities and the
people we're hearing from are
very much on on that same page of
compliance is really hard when you don't
know exactly
what the guidelines are yet and maybe
that's happened since I talked to
somebody but you know the it sounded
very much like there was an awful lot
that was going to have to get into place
before
they could figure out how to set up the
systems to meet the guidelines that they
have to meet by July 1st so
there's certainly a lot a lot of moving
parts to being compliant on seven one
and part of our conversations with the
stakeholders was based on you know their
concerns about just what you said if
they're if something goes wrong what is
the contingency to make sure that
individuals and families still receive
service so that's you know we're hoping
that doesn't happen we know with a big
you know redesign are there are there
instances where
um the system might not work because of
either an I.T issue an enrollment issue
a paperwork issue so we're planning for
those uh contingencies but and that's
part of our reality and rolling out
something as large as this right and you
know I'll just add I mean it goes
without saying but the bottom line for
all of us everybody in this room is to
ensure that people who need Services get
the services that they need and that
that isn't interrupted correct in any
way more than it's already interrupted
because of other factors great
representative Nagel thank you thank you
um this has been a long and very good
discussion and um I'm coming to almost
the conclusion that everything in Bill
317 and 608 is already happening
whether or not we pass it and I'm almost
getting to the point that neither of
these bills is necessary
am I wrong
that that's probably more of a
discussion with executive session I I
don't think that they're precluded from
doing anything in these bills but I I
think the reason why these bills are
here is because there are people that
don't believe that this is this is
happening and is the focus of the
department yeah and I think you know in
the previous hearing on these bills I
think you heard from stakeholders and
families you know the concern about how
how the a m report was completed and
rolled out and I think you're we're
seeing that in some of this legislation
where you know they felt like their
voices weren't heard and that there was
a plan developed without them and I
think that's what we see in these bills
thank you um and I I actually do think
that our federal compliance part is
relevant and completely germane to the
608 because that was one of the big
issues that was presented to us when
this bill was introduced that there were
the issues around compliance and then
everything else that was coming along
with it
um so to me trying to address this and
see what's necessary is actually
Germaine important and part of the same
intention
um
so we we can look at this and figure out
how to craft it my other question was
with the Holman community-based waivers
and the technical guide from CMS that
one says that all the providers need to
be able to direct bill but in the
specific guidance from CMS it doesn't
say that they have to direct bill
and retaining that option for those who
do not want to do that and do not want
to take the risk and I didn't see
anything in the guidance that requires
them to even have a direct billing
number with CMS so getting Clarity and
trying to figure out how we can do that
I think would help retain that and maybe
pull some other people into this into
the provider Network that may not
otherwise be a part of this because I
would rather have somebody who just
wants to doesn't want to direct Bill and
provide some services so that's
something that I think would be very
important for us to address because it
seems like the very path is the path
especially because you're dealing with
that uncertainty of bringing this into
these State programs is to try and put
everybody into a more similar funnel
just for administrative for the
administrative benefits because of your
resources so that's one of the things
that I think we probably should look at
as well to make sure that that
flexibility and the maximum flexibility
within CMS guidelines is retained I
don't of that if there's anybody any
problem with that here on the committee
with that idea
so I think maybe we'll try and figure
out some way to redirect 608 to make
sure that we're moving towards towards
requesting waivers and understanding how
we're going to get this process done I
know we're limited on time again I know
I don't see how we do that legislatively
I mean with a piece of legislation as
opposed to the kinds of discussions
we're having here which I see as being
really useful and helpful and it it's
certainly at a minimum helps us
understand and enables us to have far
better informed conversations with all
of our constituents no matter where
they're situated which is you know our
function
um but I'm not sure how
a piece of legislation that likely isn't
going to be signed until after July 1st
helps us with the July 1st process so
which I think is a good reason to not
have a subcommittee but if on an ad hoc
basis some people come up with some some
language for an amendment where they
believe that it'll meet the need we can
look at that next week I'm I'm more than
willing to look at anything anybody
comes up with but I am skeptical that
there is legislation that can address
what happens between now and July 1st
that will be enacted prior to July 1st
so
I think this has been incredibly helpful
we've just scratched the surface do we
have some more input from
okay
so what will be real quick if we can
have you come up so that we can hear you
for the YouTube thank you thank you
thank you very much
uh thank you madam chair we represent
the 10 area agencies my name is Alex
katrubis with me is our executive
director Ellen McCann and one of our
members Matt Cordero from Portsmouth
if I could I just I just want to talk
about 6 42. I know you're you're talking
about potentially retaining that that's
a really important bill to the area
agencies uh the department just
presented to division three in house
finance yesterday that only 65 of the
people who are getting services in DD
right now are actually fully in
programming getting those services so we
rarely see 642 as an opportunity to
create more tools to give the department
the ability to redirect funds that may
be available the bill doesn't
appropriate any funds it only
and representative Robert you brought
this up at the health and human services
oversight committee uh about a week and
a half ago can we use dollars that
otherwise aren't being spent that the
legislature has appropriated for
developmental Services can we give the
department tools to better
deploy those resources to budgets that
are chronically out of date that's
putting pressure on the providers not
because they're not able to properly
reimburse their staff so we're not
talking about asking for more
Appropriations from the legislature
we're just talking about giving them
more tools to manage their budget so I
would if you want to retain one of these
bills I would look at potentially
represent retaining representative
stringham's study legislation that may
be a better option so I would
respectfully ask that you consider that
there was a couple of comments at the
hearing you know the DD Council had a
couple of concerns with 642 uh but we
really it's not so much about the salary
cap it's really that second component of
the bill that that gives the the
department the ability to deploy
resources that that might not be used or
with lapse or would build up in our
dedicated fund
can we take a portion of those and
redirect it so that we can we can get
folks in program there's going to be a
public Hearing in reps Hall next week
hundreds of people are going to are
going to come and ask to be a part of
the DD system if we're only getting 65
of the job done I mean that that's not a
good a good situation so we see this as
a tool it doesn't require the department
to necessarily do anything but it gives
them the ability to manage their budget
better and and we think it can be a
helpful uh process going forward
representative Weber
so I'm now looking at 642
and
my recollection and again I don't have
my notes in front of me but my
recollection where there are a lot of
people who were
unhappy with the way things are and
thought this would make it better and
then there were some who were unhappy
with the way things are and thought it
would make it worse but
um I'm wondering if
first of all is is there
a limit
now is there a limiter cap in place now
there there is not a limit in it there's
not a limit or a cap in place however
the department does have the ability to
deny funding requests that they think
are unreasonable but there is not a
specific cap
in in the spreadsheet as someone I think
had brought up earlier that has been
taken out okay so if I may have a couple
of follow-ups Madam chair
um
this so the first sentence just says
it's not going to establish or or
enforce a limiter cap
on the direct wages so that
so that may limit your ability to say
this isn't reasonable
would it well it the intention of that
sentence was they can't just have an
arbitrary cap which was like 16 and uh
so it pro
so so this just says that you can't have
a threshold a one-size-fits-all
threshold if you read the bill it talks
about a reasonable negotiation based on
the individual's family circumstances
their disability their family situation
so the intention of that first bill the
first sentence in that bill is is to not
have a one-size-fits-all cap which is
what had been done previously
right but there isn't one now that is
correct but but it could come back I
mean it could I mean we could do all
kinds of things and they could come from
us or it could come from you so I get
that what I'm driving at is
um if we just uh
amended this down to allow
to the department she'll use existing
budget Appropriations to negotiate
reasonable wages and appropriate service
budgets with area agencies and service
providers and lost the first two
sentences does that get us to where we
need to be in terms of
the use of the funds available from our
perspective the SEC the the first
sentence is not as important as the
section that you just read
to us the flexibility to give the
department the ability to better manage
their budget and again I don't want to
sound like a broken record but we're
only doing 65 percent of the job right
to me that's a failure so again this
puts the the tools in their hands if
they don't feel that it's reasonable if
they don't feel that they can uh they
feel this is going to make them
overspend or the dollars need to be
somewhere else we can have that we can
have that discussion but right now as
you heard at the hearing unless there's
a significant life change there's no
mechanism to move these dollars so this
just gives us the mechanism on the table
so yes the second part of the bill is in
my opinion much more important than the
pro the prohibition on the cap which is
in the title of the bill which I think
is why folks are focusing on that aspect
of it but it's really the second half
but we could change the title we could
yes absolutely we do it all the time
uh representative Murphy and then
representative Freitas great thank you
so much um I was looking at my notes and
it really was HHS did not really have an
opinion on it it was stated that there's
really no wage cap as you mentioned
right now
um that the budgets are pretty much
Legacy budgets that are somewhat archaic
and they're functionally used from your
perspective
um in that when somebody brought up
there was a pretty this may be a
premature bill it was basically saying
because there's going to be a redesign
of the budget going forward so my
question is
um
will this if you had this to me is what
you're asking for is a specific tool
within your budget that you may or may
not use but with this in any way impact
negatively or positively or change the
process going forward for the new budget
if you're speaking about the rate
redesign
I don't think that it would necessarily
negatively impact that process because
we we all know that we have these
ambitious deadlines and time frames we
don't know exactly when that's going
going to happen I think this could be
integrated into that process and
certainly in the meantime it will be a
useful tool to help us Implement and
fulfill the budget so I certainly don't
see it as precluding anything with the
the new rate system
when that happens is it going to be 2024
is it going to be 2025
but you know we I don't think we have
the answer to that as you've all heard
this morning I said many times to this
committee we need to be focused
laser-like on Direct Bill and conflict
free for July 1st that is the primary
Mission all of those other issues the
two-tier waiver all the other issues
that you've talked about the rate review
the CIS
uh supports intensity to scale all of
those other issues are really things
that the department is is undertaking
not under the corrective action plan
they could be things in a m they could
be other initiatives that we've looked
at
so so the rate rate redesign that's
something that that is not required by
uh CMS it may or may not happen we don't
exactly know what form it may take so I
don't see this as in conflict with that
it it could be I suppose uh but but I
really don't see how I mean it it's
really just giving them another tool to
manage their budget and deploy resources
quick follow-up yeah thank you um so
this would not really impact your budget
except giving you a different tool in
which to to to work with right now it
would allow us to take funds that are
not being expended and redirect those to
Old budgets that may have been set 10 20
15 years ago right 30 years ago would be
specifically you know how would this
impact
positively or negatively if this bill
were not to go forward given the
flexibility that it may put into your
budget if this bill doesn't move forward
it will put increased pressure on the
providers because they are going to have
to live in an environment for another
two years where the budget is set
the budget was set 10 or 15 years ago
and it just doesn't meet the financial
realities and I believe that there's
going to be dollars that are going to be
unused
so so why not direct it to the need
that's really all this is is the same
and well
um I representative Freitas had a
comment as well catch something to say
thank you for taking my question
um my concern was about the rates
there seem to be any activity in
increasing or changing the rates it
seemed to be an issue that day from the
people that were receiving services
yes so that this would allow those
budgets
those rates to go up you're speaking of
using on expended funding we would take
the unexpended funds and we would raise
those older budgets thank you that's the
intention and that just for
clarification what I said in Health and
Human Services oversight is okay we only
have 65 of the positions that we already
have authorized and funded filled
so if we used some of the money that was
authorized to up the reimbursement rates
maybe we could get to a point where
within our existing budget we could get
80 percent filled which would certainly
be better than where we are now and then
if we need to look at more budget
requests down the road but we already
have that money authorized and the one
thing it's not doing anybody any good is
sitting in a bucket waiting for a person
to come along with the right skills to
match the right person and willing to
take the job so
that gets me back to the question of if
we were to just keep the last sentence
does that get us at least part away the
way across the game perspective it's
much better than holding it for a year
because that's not going to do anyone
any good right we would support
retaining the study on the two-tier
waiver if you want to hold a vehicle
well we can't we can't divide we want a
different Bill though okay yeah
representative stringham's building
study in the two-tier waiver that could
be held versus this this bill we're
talking about right now
representative McLean thank you manager
thanks for taking my question I'm just
I'm just curious so I understand what
you're saying so we have excess dollars
they're not being used we want to direct
them to you know Legacy budgets where
there's people are being under
compensated but what's the mechanism for
that how much do you know how much to
put to here is there
you know a legacy budget is 20 so how do
you know how much to give to each of
these Legacy budgets because they're not
all going to be the same that's true I
mean that's really implementing their
budget I mean that is the conversation
that the area agency and the department
will have to have I mean I think that's
really kind of getting into into the
weeds a little bit about what the
providers and and the department are
going to discuss but again this just
gives them the tool to they need to
model that out they we need to get a
list of how many of these budgets need
to be addressed which ones are the the
most chronically in need and and we're
going to have to work through it it's
going to take time we may not be able to
do it all in one biennium but at least
this gives us an opportunity to begin
solving the problem it's going to take I
think a few years to do it because we
don't want to use up all of those
dollars because there could be people
who need enhanced Services there could
be people who move into the state so we
have to we have to be careful
and how far we take this but again this
gives the department the discretion to
take it whatever level that they feel
confident that they can do so they need
to manage their budget and Implement
their budget it's no different than the
folks who are going to graduate from
special education in in the spring the
people who are going to join the adult
system
how do you set all of those rates that's
something that the department and the
area agencies have done for for decades
it's all based on the individual's needs
their family circumstances what level of
disability they have how many hours of
services do they need it's a negotiation
between the state and the area agency so
that would all have to be worked out on
individual basis
so if we could maybe just move on to 608
real quick because I know you have to
get going uh we we support the we are
very close to supporting the amendment
that was I believe drafted by the
associate commissioner who represented
the department at the 608 public hearing
so just so you're aware the area
agencies and the department I think are
very very close to getting to a place
where we can come together on Amendment
for 608 that will representative
wherever you've brought this up several
times I think make it clear that we are
going to require piloting pending CMS
approval on everything except direct
Bill and conflict free
I mean that's really the issue in a
nutshell
and please yeah please yeah I thought
thank you for hearing us um Ellen McKay
and I'm the executive director of csni
which is the association of area
agencies and I would say that this
committee has very astutely picked up
the differential between seven one and
then the ongoing work and representative
Weber you're you're stating that
addressing the concerns on 71 with a
legislative solution could be difficult
I I did like your idea of having a
representative from the advisory
committee report out to the oversight
DHHS oversight committee as a balance to
the Department's Viewpoint that could be
but I think that um as Alex said the the
department has very much stepped up and
indicated
their willingness and ability to Pilot
the work subsequent to 7-1 which we are
very much in support of and feel is
necessary
for families individuals providers area
agencies to all feel comfortable with
those changes I will also for a moment
just speak to on the
the 7-1 go live there is a deep concern
about being able to pull that off and to
do it well and you know ideally
seamlessly I think that there's a desire
to hear the statement made you know if
we're not ready to go live we won't go
live
um if there's going to be if they're
going to be problems and to have an
agreement around sort of a dashboard of
some kind that can agreed upon
indicators of where you know
green yellow or red in terms of the
sense of are we prepared to go live
because it is such an enormous change so
there there is a great concern about
that but I think that as Alex said
working with the amended language
proposed by the department I think is a
solution that gets us to a place where
the piloting
of the work subsequent to 7-1 would
would be very helpful
hello my name is Matthew padaro I'm the
CEO for one sky Community Services
um
you know something that struck me from
when I hear I was hearing and I
testified it was rep McKay actually said
why is this so hard
and why this is so hard is because we
don't have enough people at the table
one of the pieces of information I can
give you is that Colorado who entered
into the same uh compliance issues we
did at the same time has followed for an
extension and received an extension so
we already have case precedent right now
that we could do this
um we had a compliance plan that was put
together that had all the stakeholders
involved in the state it was scrapped in
favor at amm
um
and why I think we don't want to go for
another uh extension or ask CMS for
another extension because it keeps
pressure on all of us to keep the bus
moving forward we are making changes to
our system that we're not going to
recover from come July 1st when it all
goes to pot we are going to be in a
situation where people are not going to
receive services and companies may go
out of business
and I understand what I'm saying is
alarmist
but I also want you to understand I'm
trying to tell you we're at the last off
ramp the reason we have uh DHHS coming
to the table to Pilot things now to talk
to us when they weren't before is
because this legislation came forward
we need the leverage in order to keep
them at the table it's very simple
if we can't have that that leverage I
need you folks to set up an oversight
panel and committee and I need you to
get knee deep and hands dirty
because without you
we're not going to be listened to
and I'm trying to prevent disaster
that's where I'm coming from I want
people to get their services
it doesn't need to be this hard
representative Leon came up with a
fantastic idea of a Fiscal Agent we
wouldn't need to change the rest of the
system that's already being done in
Florida through their CBC program uh
satisfying the needs for the DCF
um uh children they support it's the
same system so they use something called
sunbiz they provide payments they
validate the payments it doesn't cost
the providers anything it's really easy
simple to do their version of an area
agency which they call a CBC does the
same things that we do we check for
eligibility we provide oversight to the
vendor agencies we keep all the trains
running and people cared for in a proper
way they get what they need all sunbiz
does as the Fiscal Agent is cut the
checks and validates the services it
gets us into compliance it would take
less than a year I think we asked for
two years so that we can get all the
policies and processes put together it's
a very smart approach to it
um so thank you very much for reading
the technical manual
um the second thing is we can't come out
of conflicts uh free uh stuff because we
don't even know what our rates are
DHHS has muddled a m so much into the
conflict free and
um
it's it's been so entwined that you
can't separate one from the other at
this point it's an anchor it's going to
drag us to the depths
very clearly I want you to have that
analogy because it's not going to be any
of us it's going to be the people and
the families that we support and just to
put a fine point on it when people start
dropping their kids off saying I can't
care for them anymore those services
that are provided by families save the
state about 300 million dollars a year
so take our budget double it and add
some to it and that's where we're going
to be not to mention it's going to take
up all of our Hospital spaces so now we
can't have care for our uh our acute
care situations in our tertiary care
centers so
when we're talking about and
representing whatever you picked up on
it well we'll just kind of limp along if
not everyone is in compliance it's not
good enough it may not be perfect it's
not good enough one of my board members
Michelle came here with her DSP and she
sat here and I took a couple seconds for
her to be able to communicate out she
has a bachelor's degree and runs her own
business she's incredibly articulate
without her support she has no ability
to exit her home there there is no
cognitive delay
um that adds to that additional need
that would be there
so imagine yourselves similarly situated
not capable of going to the bathroom on
your own showering on your own being
able to operate on your own because we
decided that it was best to do what all
of our contemporary selves do we have no
children and who are not in the system
do because it will make our lives
administratively easier
we need something to apply pressure and
whether it's a bill or whether it's you
folks standing up for us we need
something because the conversations I
will tell you I never laughed so hard in
my life that when I got an email saying
we're willing to talk about things
it's not a response that you should have
I sit on the rate committee I promise
you I'm not listened to I think part of
it is because I'm a crank and I hope we
all know this but if you watch the
videos the very first resetting
committee I went to I said why are not
why are we not doing what the families
asked why are we not engaging them and
my response was we're accepting the
response I received was we accepted the
recommendations from a m
and I pushed and pushed and pushed and
that was the the response I got don't
take my word for it reveal it and when
you're looking at the two waiver systems
New York does a 11 15 demonstration
waiver and they actually have a two
separate waivers one for families and
one for for non-families
so individuals who are in the system on
their own in turn in traditional Care
Centers they capitate that at eighty
thousand dollars they have a waiver
system to get around that so we could
look at something like that and say okay
that's a system for us to be able to
look at none of that stuff to my
knowledge was brought up or reviewed
because when I asked a m about it my
response was just that's great please
send it to me
not having people who have the
experiences like I have like Ellen has
like the other Area Agency directors in
in the beginning is what led us to this
point you have families that have the
ability to have lived in other states
that can tell you about Services I've
personally worked in other states I can
tell you about Services there's a way to
do this and and again because we have so
much up in the air because of the a m
debacle that has been added into an
unnecessary change
it's almost impossible for the area
agencies who are in Conflict to come out
of conflict because the regs are
changing the rates are changing we don't
know what they are and how do we create
a business and hire people or fire
people or whatever we need to do in
order to do it so my suggestion to all
of you is to I guess either look at 608
and amend it to such that it requires
that CMS are DHHS go to CMS and
earnestly request an extension and I use
the word earnestly intentionally
um
and I think if we could get a Fiscal
Agent we wouldn't have to make all the
changes we're making we are making a lot
of hodgepodge pack work uh Patchwork
changes right now to our system so when
you're asking about implementation of a
m all the little things we're doing
right now is going to implement a m but
it's also so co-mingled into how it's
being done to change the uh our direct
bill that you know one serves the other
you can't untangle them at this point it
just needs to be either scrapped or we
need to go all in and hope we don't hit
a wall
thank you all right thank you that's
incredibly insightful I sort of have a
general question about where we're going
here and this is my first year so I'm
I'm really asking this just so I can
hear back so I had several things
there's sort of what we can do and what
we can't do as legislators so it sounds
like people are saying that it would be
really important to pursue
um
an extension past July 1 no matter what
which is really up to HHS
the second thing is um then we delay the
implementation of 608 to sort of
correspond to when that happens so in
here it's this amendment moves the dates
forward to January from July for this
pilot project and so maybe that needs to
even be different and correspond to
whenever you know say six months after
the
H the CMS
final date
and then
the other two bills is that we we've
talked about passing the bill for the
council with the amendment
and and maybe then retaining 317. so I'm
just sort of putting all of that out
there just to see where we are because
my head is has begun to spin
representative Weber
I just want to be sure I'm clarifying
because I'm getting different messages
from the three of you sitting at that
table there because one of the messages
was I think we're really really close to
an agreement with DHHS on 608 that would
satisfy both of us and if that were true
I think there would be a huge sigh of
relief except that we would also need to
hear from the service recipients to see
if it's okay with them
but if I read what
DHHS submitted it's a very a m Centric
program
and it doesn't sound like it's going to
be something that you're going to be on
board with so
I I'm just learning you to the fact that
I'm getting very mixed messages about
what our next step must might be because
if you guys thought you were genuinely
close to coming up with something that
will satisfy both sides
my reaction is phew I'll review that
when it comes uh but I'm not hearing
that as being a realistic expectation
given what I'm also hearing from the
folks at the table at the moment so I
think that Ellen and I represent
probably two various sides I'm not an
optimistic
um I I think Ellen's had more
conversations than I've had with the
bureau but I go based off of behavior
and not off of what is being said
um and what I've seen to date and I
think what you've all picked up is that
this has been
driven entirely by BDS
I guess I'd like to say that I think in
the true interest of disclosure Alex and
I represent csni the association of area
agencies is it fair to say Matt that
you're representing one sky a separate
Area Agency so there's a difference in
Viewpoint I do personally believe in you
know the ability to escalate the need to
invoke an extension with CMS through
conversations with you know we have a
tight relationship with uh well
an ongoing relationship with dltss the
associate commissioner we have a meeting
in place with the commissioner if things
are going
um
uh in a way that we don't believe it's
possible to pull off 7-1 we will
specifically ask for that if we feel
that we do not get a response that
um uh favors an escalation we will
proceed to escalate separate and apart
from that request to the commissioner
you know the reality is
um on 7-1 we need the area agencies the
provider agencies need time to model out
restructure reorganize re-engineer
processes it's a lot of work and we want
to do it right and I think that I I the
well and that's the question Matt just
to ask can we do that in three months
and I feel like we're at a point where
um I would say by the end of this month
it'll be very clear whether we can or
not and we will request an escalation
process around that I'm not sure that a
legislative solution of
um
saying that the department has to ask
for an extension is the way to do that
and so that's just that's a difference
in approach and I don't have the wisdom
to know the best way to proceed but I
know that we do have a path set in
motion to continue
um uh to have very honest solid
conversations with the department and if
we feel that we need to
significantly escalate we will so
um so yes there there you are hearing a
difference and I would say that yeah so
we do all agree on 642 I hope so so we
got we got that going for us
representative McKay
thank you very much microphone please
turn your microphone on
you think I'd learn by now
the uh
I've been quiet and uh as you've heard
Charlie McMahon and I have been working
on this forever and and it sounds the
same to me
what what I recognize
in the mental health field is stigma
and that it's a unspoken word
that perhaps a lot of us are suffering
from stigma and therefore inside of
themselves saying this is not a
population worth helping
which is a terrible thing
to say
there needs to be some some
place
that can keep this uh
dialogue going and my guess is that the
best place is the oversight committee
and
the uh one of our great members is
already a member of that organization
and the chairman is sitting in the back
row usually sits in the front row but
I think
if that can be understood as a major
organization that can help
to to keep this moving
while
we're still young enough to benefit from
the hard work of many people in the
legislature
I'm not pessimistic after all of these
years that we can't do something
but we can't if we don't
and I would hope that the chairman might
give us some indication of where he's
heading in terms of this responsibility
I watched my friend in the middle
agonize in the middle of this and I was
going to say something
and finally he did himself
but that antagonism is a is a reflection
of the seriousness of what what isn't
being done for this extremely needful
population so thank you for the chance
to say something after probably 20 years
of saying something thank you very much
thank you very much for that we'll have
representative Shapiro and then I then
I'll try and talk about what I think our
next steps are
it may not be necessary I just think
that we as much as we would like to get
agreement from all the parties clearly
that's not going to happen and I think
I'm wondering if it would not be better
for us to move into an executive session
because we have to make decisions based
on the information that we have and the
disagreement that we have before us well
thank you I'm not sure that we're ready
to move into executive session on all of
these bills that we had today but I
think that what I'm hearing from this um
let me I'll make my statement then I'll
see if you have additional questions
would be that on 642 hopefully
representative Weber could submit an
amendment at some point to change that
title and strike that first line it
probably will take enough time for us to
two lines those lines
um to pick that up next week most likely
that
we can discuss if we might want to
retain 317 instead but on 608 we'll see
any ad hoc work that wants to have
happen before we come in next week and
look at how to address that one next
week I think this has been incredibly
productive to get deeper into this
complex issue and then after that we'll
hear from representative polisov and
then we'll prob we may take up
um
it may make sense to take up
238 when we get into executive session
since we had some great agreement on
that
um
and then it will need some a short bio
break before we get started on the
remainder we will be breaking for lunch
um but we'll see what what business we
can get done so I recognize
representative polisov and then we'll
have representative Pearson as the
chairman of oversight
um thank you thank you madam chair I
have a question to the committee I'm not
a lawyer but if we look in into 6 42 and
lines
seven and eight I I'm open to the idea
of living just that sentence online
seven and eight but my question to the
committee is it specific enough and is
it flexible enough to what we are trying
to do and specifically like two
scenarios we know in some other in this
lesson as a
organizations have tendency of burn
through funds at the end of fiscal year
and definitely it's not the situation we
have today today we have a clear need
and and spent funds but in the future
like it's a safeguard and second
scenario actually what we just heard
from agencies
they want us to spend the sun spent
funds but they also said don't spend it
all in the first year leave something
for the future does this sentence
allow us that flexibility to leave some
thank you thank you those are fantastic
points we actually have a superpower
here representative Weber is a lawyer
and uh so with that we do have some of
that I think those are great points
maybe we sense that maybe we limit how
it's done but I'll leave that to most
likely all I can say is that if we just
leave the last sentence it allows all
the flexibility that anybody would need
it does not have a restriction but the
Restriction is the amount of money
budgeted overall
so
they can't go beyond that thank you
um and then we'll hear from
representative Pearson if you'd like to
come up thank you
chairman of oversight
thank you madam chair and committee
after the dust settles from your exact
sessions on these bills
my good friend representative Makai and
I will be happy to take counsel as to
what we might consider doing next that
would come under oversight and if
we're not ready on the 28th of March
which is our next meeting I think we
will be in April just want to say that
we can backstop this however you wish us
to fantastic thank you so much
thank you and with this um
so my plan would be to end this work
session move into an executive session
on
um
238 and then take recess for a quick buy
a break depending on the time
we do yes we already have that Amendment
um we may want to do that and um I
recognize we're coming up on on lunch we
do want to make sure that we can have a
lunch since this is a three-day week
where we powered through yesterday and
we're less certain on the floor we may
I know that I know that after this one
I'm going to need at least 10 minutes
myself to run out of the room so we'll
look and see what the time frame is
and representative love if you want to
come up since you're one of our
substitutes today thank you
thank you
let's see
uh thank you
I was wondering
I was told that was Southern Brewing but
it's it says McDonald up there
representative McDonald yeah
maybe she's had some surgery or
something I don't know what does having
not cap is that it yeah
they had one not long ago I don't like
it at all there's a line like the last
week with my vision oh yeah I mean with
black lines
no I used to have great peripheral
vision but now this time
chips
yeah so let's get open to the birds
I don't know how many years I've been
here but it's more than 20. it's a long
time
it's amazing because she's very low-key
thank you so with that I I don't know if
I officially close the work session but
I'm officially closing that work session
and I am now opening an executive
session on House Bill 238 and I
recognize representative Shapiro for a
motion
I move that we adopt
um amendment
0841 to House Bill 238. do I see a
second I representative Palmer
would you like to speak to your motion
um yes as we've already agreed to we
have
um
excluded one point under Roman numeral
four what was
um letter B has been taken out
um which involved
um including a council member on
as part of the selection process for the
contractor that has been removed
otherwise the amendment is the same as
the other Amendment
um and I think we have
um
agreed that this is a good bill because
it creates more input from the
um
community that is affected by the
disability
um
Bureau of disability
thank you very much would anybody else
like to speak to the amendment
and with that if the clerk would like to
take the rule the role on the motion to
adopt amendment
2023-0841h to House Bill 238.
David love is filling in for
representative McDonald
love
no I would vote I would vote last
because I'm the chairman
it's a good name
he's been working yesterday
weight loss
employers
I know that I just said to call the role
I think let's just pause this for a
moment let's do it let's let's hold this
executive session do a 10 minute bio
break and then come back in
if that's acceptable to everybody thank
you so we
yes we will be back
um at uh 11 42.
uh I guess foreign
thank you everybody we are going to come
back together and reopen the executive
session on House Bill 238.
um we at the time that we recessed well
I'll just give you a little bit of a
heads up we will finish that one we will
um also then open up House Bill 431 and
then we will take a lunch until one
o'clock
um so oh
on House Bill 238 we had already had a
motion to adopt Amendment zero eight
four one H by representative Shapiro
seconded by representative Palmer
um and is there any further discussion
are we ready to move into the voting
mode for the amendment
um yes and we are missing one member
he's helping somebody right now I don't
think that either of these will be
contentious enough to delay the votes
for his arrival
and with that if the clerk can call the
role
start with you yeah uh no start start
with representative
representative Cushman sure
on the amendment yes
representative Bill King yes
representative coppol yes representative
McLean yes representative King Seth King
not here represent Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosov yes
and representative love yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas
yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative Howard
yes
representative Murphy
representative Palmer yes
representative seller yes
and representative lamb yes
19-0 the amendment is adopted 19-0 do I
see a motion from representative Shapiro
sure I move that we
um
vote ought to pass on House Bill 238 as
amended by zero eight four one h
and is there a second
representative Palmer thank you would
you like to speak to your motion or has
that already been discussed I think
we've discussed it adequately fantastic
thank you very much
um is anybody else like to be recognized
representative Cushman
thank you
so I may be breaking with the rest of my
caucus on this boat I'm going to be
voting against the bill and not because
I I don't believe that the contents of
the bill have Merit I just have a
problem with Section seven I think this
is a dangerous slippery slope that we
should not be doing government remotely
I'm sure everyone has seen the AI deep
fakes now and this just puts us closer
to a place where someone could
you know mess with our process and it
takes away
from
you know being truly transparent by
having the Quorum in person and voting
in person
thank you are there any other comments
seeing none if the clerk could call the
rule on ought to pass as amended by
house by Amendment
2023-0841h and I know we have some new
people so that means you don't
necessarily need to follow the vice
chair because that's what she told you
in that statement
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes Representative
pelosa no
representative love
yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas
yes
representative Cannon yes representative
Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative Howard
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
select yes
representative land yes
18-2
the motion passes 18 to 2 where
representative Shapiro writes the
majority report
and I assume I'm sorry representative
if they agree it and if if they agree
but it can I I think the point is to
write a Minority Report so that the the
issue can be made part of the record
um were you planning to write a Minority
Report or no
yeah I will write a minority okay and
and with that Minority Report
um did you want to do an amendment where
it simply removed that change to the 91a
I can submit something and I would yeah
okay so that'll be with an amendment
simply to remove the 91a section so that
it's clear that our intent is to make
these changes but that's the one point
of contention
no consent calendar but it likely will
be a Voice vote on the floor
okay thank you
so just uh catch the motion
would be an ought to pass with a new
Amendment yes it would be an ought to
pass with a new Amendment I'll send you
perfect thank you and with that I close
the exec the executive session on House
Bill 238 and open the executive session
on House Bill 3431 I'll recognize myself
for a motion to adopt house the
amendment
2023-0750755h and I will pass that out
is there any second sorry I should have
passed them first
protocol I apologize it it was emailed
out previously but paper is good
second second from representative thank
you
so as this is being passed out I will
speak to my motion this is an amendment
that we had helped drafting with um we
had significant Health drafting
representative Thomas is in agreement
with this this addresses the challenges
that came up in the in the hearing where
we had some issues around allowing
people to cultivate before they had
their license and so it clarifies that
language and tightens it up there's also
some about the specific plants that are
allowed so that we can make sure that
make sure that the number of plants is
not excessive but also does not have
artificial types time frames that would
prohibit the number of young immature
but not yet able to be sexed plants so
that you may not be culling your only
effective plants for the strain that you
need in order to treat your medical need
this
this amendment um this amendment has
been reviewed as well at the department
and right because that's the appropriate
thing the same thank you
um reviewed at the department and at
this point has General General consensus
as far as I can tell would anybody else
like to speak to the amendment
Madam chair who moved the amendment I
moved the amendment no I mean who
seconded the amendment uh representative
okay thank you
thank you
and seeing no further question
um no further comment I would ask the
clerk to call a roll on Amendment zero
seven five five h
uh representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
representative pelosa yes
representative love yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative
representative Shapiro yes
representative Howard
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Selleck yes
and representative Leon yes 19-1 with
that the amendment passes 19 to 1 and I
move ought to pass as amended by by
Amendment
2023-0755h second five representative
um I think that this is contained within
the amendment as its replace all is
there any further discussion
it's representative Nagel I think as you
know I'm strongly opposed to this which
is really weird
um we we started out with three bills on
cannabis can you hear me people look
closer it might be better yeah we
started out with three bills on cannabis
and it was really weird this was the one
that I was going to vote for and I and
and after I listen to the testimony
um it they basically made the case
against this bill
as a little background
um I'm a pain physician
um I've actually wrote a chapter on
medical cannabis in my book
um I um probably have certified more
people for medical cannabis than any
doctor in the state so it's not that I
don't believe in it I've also been
fortunate on my NFL committee to work
with one of the world's leading
Authorities on medical cannabis so I've
learned an awful lot from him
um
one of the things that we I think we
need to really think about is
differentiating between recreational and
medicinal use there is a very good
reason and and I'm going to build a
little bit on what Dr knurk said there's
a very good reason
um you know why marijuana will never be
FDA approved and it will probably always
be DEA level one and the reason why is
that each plant
has roughly 80 different cannabinoids in
it and what very creates the differences
in quality ability is not the two that
we look at which is CBD and THC but all
the other ones
and for simplistic reasons we just focus
on THC and CBD which I think can be a
little bit dangerous
um but that is what we do
um
what I've come to understand and being
on the board of one of the dispensaries
is that I wanted to understand the
operation of a medicinal product
as well as I could so I said I wanted a
tour of how they make this stuff you
know so we went down to a factory down
in in Massachusetts and you and this was
from a science point of view this thing
is unbelievable you walk in there and
the guy that runs this has a PHD in
Horticulture
um every element of growing area has
sensors in it to control humidity and
temperature within like fractions of a
degree and a percentage and the reason
why they want to do that is they want a
product that's reliable and that um you
know that they know what's in it and
basically they're just controlling for
THC and CBD they're not controlling for
anything else and so in the end when
they distribute a product to somebody
that's what they know what they're
getting
um
my big concern came out was that when
one of the people testifying for this
Bill said that um you know she she cited
you know how specific these levels are
and and the other thing that really
interested me that she said and I agree
with totally our system doesn't work
because cost and access are a problem
and that's what this bill was designed
to do but then it occurred to me after
seeing how it's really grown and how a
product's developed on a pharmacologic
basis that the product that you create
in your own backyard not in a greenhouse
with such control
is not really a medicinal product it may
be a recreational one but it's not a
medicinal product and in the end after
listening to what she said I I just
changed my mind and I said I don't think
this is the right way to go
um there's better ways to improve cost
and access in this state than allowing
everybody to grow it and I if you wanted
me to go into detail how to do that we
can do that but but I don't think this
is the right way to do it if we were
talking recreationally go for it I'm all
for that but that's why I'm opposed to
it
thank you very much representative
representative Seth King
thank you uh chair Leon
is that right yeah okay
that's all right
um
my question for Dr Nagel is
this plant has been around since the
dawn of man
and um
do you believe that
it was never medicinally used for
several thousand years and the only way
that this plant could have been used
medically medicinally is once it was lab
grown I mean
really thank you
uh yes if you want feel free to read my
chapter because it answers everything
that you just said
um the problem that that the way I look
at it is that you know when we want to
give somebody something medicinal it has
to have a predictable predictability to
it
and one of the reasons that we get into
trouble
um you know with a lot of drugs isn't
necessarily their effects but their side
effects and when you give somebody an
unpredictable thing with the varying
amounts of cannabinoids that's when you
get into problem like we know that
childhood schizophrenia is increased in
incidents with these kinds of things
which is why I'm opposed to using it in
kids at all and that's another long
story
but I think what you want to do when you
give somebody a medicinal product it
needs to be predictable and at least
relatively reliable and and homegrown is
not
um and and that's why I'm opposed
in a nutshell representative silig and
followed by representative thank you so
much I I just in terms of thinking about
the
concept of making sure you have a pure
medicinal product and that you're
getting the same thing
um having a child who takes ADHD meds
and is given you know whatever
generic is available in the pharmacy
we've had recently had a circumstance
where the generic was switched because
the manufacturer is having issues
and so it's technically the same
medication technically the same dosage
however this one has completely
different side effects than the one that
the generic previous generic and so it
is a completely lab design product it's
a lab made product it's served in little
teeny pills you know and and has totally
different effect right
um in one case the generic that worked
perfectly and created the result desired
result the other caused an increase in
symptoms
um so obviously not ideal and so I think
focusing on it Is Well it has to be
perfectly lab grown to me doesn't serve
the purpose the goal is to help people
who have a medical necessity achieve
something that's going to help them
um and I mean I'm in favor of
legalization in general but I just think
that
saying do we need to recognize the the
value of making things possible people
who suffer from the conditions where
they need medical marijuana whether it's
because of Cancer Treatments or to
manage extreme anxiety
it's really beneficial if they have
access to it without having to get it
from illegal sources
thank you representative natarappam
thank you for taking my comment because
it's not really a question
um I've been so incredibly moved by all
the families that have come to testify
in front of us
um this is my fifth year on the
committee and we've heard
um these sorts of bills for many years
and
um
so perhaps this is not perfect but it's
the best we are offering at this time
and if in the future there's ways to
have
scientifically grown more perfect
medicine that's at a very affordable
price
uh closer to people's homes where they
can make access have access to it that
would be better but this is what we have
today and so I'm voting in favor of it
thank you representative kofot
uh yes I guess I'll just Echo the
statement that I think we heard from a
lot of people and specifically some of
the concerns that we heard were
um the affordability
um a lot of the people who are
experiencing pain are also out of work
or have limited capacity to work
um they're on very very tight budgets
but the bigger issue that I think we
heard a number of times had to do with
access and particularly because of the
limited number of dispensaries in the
state of New Hampshire people who are in
the Northern Tier of the state have to
travel they can only buy a certain
amount and they have to travel some
distance to acquire that so
um you know I think that it's reasonable
to
um
let people decide whether they're
homegrown
strand or strain of of cannabis is is
adequate to address their their their
pain or other other maladies that
they're dealing with
representative Palmer
yeah so
representative Nagel's Point all of a
sudden made me stop in my tracks and
then I thought of what the difference
here is between say something that we
have like our Hospital you can't bring
in your vitamins into the hospital
because we don't know exactly what's in
them so we're not going to administer
them in the hospital but here the
difference is it's not if these people
were going to grow marijuana and sell it
then I would absolutely agree that it's
not you don't the person the buyer
doesn't know what they're getting but in
this case it's the individual person and
one of the things in testimony and I
don't know enough about this was that if
they're worried about that they can go
and get their seeds that presumably
would provide a more predictable product
and grow that but I think the big
difference for me is that it's this is
an individual person's decision to grow
this and that makes it different than if
if it was a product that was being
offered
um thank you and I'll I will actually
add my comments as well uh the comment
about generics is definitely a key one
and biosimilars are actually even are a
lot less standardized than the generics
for uh for for Pharma standard
pharmaceutical products
um I do know several Growers uh in this
for dispensaries in other states they
developed a high level of capability to
highly tune their product far before
that it was a legal situation for them
to grow it so I think that those who
need a narrow therapeutic window will
probably take on the responsibility of
figuring out how to get that specific
strain but if aspirin ibuprofen and
tylenol I'll hit your pain need then
it's a little bit less specific so I
think that this is a great increase in
Access and we can always make it better
are there any further comments before we
move to a vote
no and with that I'll ask the clerk to
call the role on House Bill 431 as
amended by 2023-0755h
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kopal yes
representative McLean yes representative
Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel no
representative proposal yes
representative love yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Howard
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative selig yes
and representative Leon yes
vote first no uh I'm voting last as the
acting chair
good first
sorry
first but if we're okay we're not over
20 then we're good and uh representative
nickel do you have any objection to
putting this on consent
okay fantastic then we'll put that on
consent no objections um so we'll put
that on the consent calendar
um
so no Minority Report if it's on the
consent calendar
um and with that we will recess until
um is one o'clock one o'clock let's aim
for that let's try and be in our seats
at one so we can try and get another 10
another 11 bills done so that we can
stick to one day next week
so if that works thank you
the damage would just hang around
um thank you everybody sorry for being a
little bit late getting back um with
that I will open the executive session
on um house
Bill 299 that is prescription
prohibiting discrimination in medical
care
and I I will move ought to pass
a second
yes representative Cushman
um so this bill
is intended to get ahead of some of the
training that we're hearing about in in
medical schools some of the idea that
in order to achieve Health Equity
there's a matter of leveling the playing
field and that it's appropriate to deny
care to some in order to provide care to
others this is something that I had seen
as something in the abstract until this
past week my mother-in-law was told in a
facility that she had lived long enough
that she should have a DNR because if
she did not have a DNR
that that provider would be there that
provider would break her ribs the broken
ribs would Pierce her heart and she
would die then with the DNR
unfortunately some of this is that is in
California so I hope that that takes a
decade to get to here in New Hampshire
uh I I did move here from California and
sometimes I want to say I'm here from
the future and I'm here to warn you
because there's bad policy that happens
there that may have been well
intentioned but the consequences come
true later on
um this is an area where it's important
to make sure that
in an attempt to right wrongs we don't
create new wrongs
and that we are able to uh to address
these these situations
representative
um
to ask for a caucus
yes yes you can yeah absolutely sorry I
apologize I have a committee I have a
somebody
perfect thank you
so we're re recessing
yes we're going to recess for a caucus
um how many minutes 10 minutes
10 minutes sound good perfect thank you
foreign
um thank you for accommodating our
recess
um I am going to withdraw my motion of
all to pass do you withdraw your second
and we will save this one for a later
day
uh we will open the executive session on
House Bill 215 relative to the adoption
of Rules by the Department of Health and
Human Services regarding medication
administration by licensed nursing
associate assistance and I recognize
representative Nagel for a motion I make
a motion this bill ought to pass
thank you is there a second I'll second
four or second okay representative on a
second
ought to pass
and would you like to speak to your
motion representative Nagel I know I'm
catching you oh no it's all right um
this actually this bill was brought to
my attention
um by one of the heads of one of the
County nursing homes
um primarily this has a lot to do with
access to care
um as you know the label there's a labor
shortage
um in nursing homes
um it was their belief that um they can
train other entities I'm sorry I don't
have the bill in front of me so I don't
remember the exact name of the entity
um I don't know why I can't find it but
anyways you got it
down
yes
yeah listen you had it
oh keep going down down
licensed nursing assistance that with
training that they would be allowed to
distribute meds and it's basically an
access issue because they're struggling
to have enough staff to be able to do
that
um she felt very strongly that with
training that these individuals could do
that and that was the whole Genesis of
this bill
foreign
thank you representative Cushman
thank you
um so despite the uh changing price tag
on this bill I'm definitely going to
support it I think that
um it will end up not only improving
care for patients because nurses will
have more time at the bedside it will
improve nursing satisfaction and that
will help retain nurses in the workforce
and also help lnas Advance their careers
and increase their satisfaction and it's
also going to save us on
payments from the state because of the
um differential between the nursing pay
and the m a pay and I will say from
personal experience when I work on a
floor and there's an m a on one of the
carts
um it's very helpful and we get a lot
more time with patients and everybody
benefits
representative Palmer yeah and I would
say that I hope that this also enables
the nursing homes particularly the
county nurse homes to it to open up some
of their beds so we can get people out
of the hospital
you can representative Murphy thank you
and you know um relative to the price
tag I just want to remind everybody this
is only a policy bill it's not really
tagged any Financial note because this
basically just says it's my remembrance
of it
um that we are passing the policy that
if it proved
um it allows them to be reimbursed if
Finance appropriates the money to do so
so and thank you and if I recall
correctly they've already made an
appropriation for this so it's already
part of the budget package from the
Department
I agree with everything it's been said
sounds like a good idea I think we
should vote for it thank you thank you
and if there's no further comments um I
would ask the clerk to call the roll on
ought to pass on House Bill 215.
representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kopal
yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes representative
pelosov
yes
representative love yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Howard yes
representative Murphy
uh yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Selleck yes
and representative Leon yes 20 to zero
and without objection on consent
fantastic thank you and that closes the
executive session for house bill 215.
um
I would like to open the executive
session on House Bill 217 establishing a
committee to study the effects of
fluoride on fetuses in children
and so anyone would like to make a
motion
a representative
I'd like uh to make a motion it ought to
pass thank you do we have a second
a second by representative Cushman thank
you thank you would you like to speak to
your motion I would um so initially you
know when I heard this bill represented
I said well we're not scientists you
know what are we going to know about
fluoride whatever
um but I had a longer much longer
conversation with the sponsor and I
realized that what they would expect us
to do is to gather some newer
information about perhaps the dangers of
fluorinating our water which 22 towns in
New Hampshire do
only 22 and that there could be findings
that it is dangerous for uh pregnant
women and if you made your infants
formula you know as as I didn't worried
about lead pipes anyway
um so sir and several uh dentists
testified that there's better ways to
get fluoride into the population uh
sealants and whatever so I think a short
study committee would be a good idea for
this
so I'm I'm in favor of it thank you
thank you would you like to speak to
your second
no need to
I think that are there any further
comments from the committee
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
call the roll on ought to pass on House
Bill 217.
representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosa yes
representative love yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay no
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro
yes
representative Howard yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative selig yes
and representative lamb yes 19-1 so it
passes 19 to one are there any
objections to putting on consent
so we'll put that on consent thank you
and that closes the executive session on
House Bill 217. next I would like to
open the executive session on House Bill
425 FN repealing the statute relative to
Medical freedom and immunizations
um a recognize representative Cushman to
make a motion thank you I move that this
bill be inexpedient to legislate and is
there a second
representative thank you
would you like to speak to your motion
sure
we've had a lot of discussions in this
committee about
um medical freedom and immunizations
we've done some work on this section of
Law and I think that as it stands it
provides some reasonable protection
against discrimination by the state
um and I think that nothing needs to be
done to this law this year and
especially a repeal I don't think we
should be repealing it as it safeguards
um bodily autonomy
thank you representative Shapiro thank
you madam chair
um I voted for against this bill two
years ago and I'll vote against it again
today I think it's um
as we know better than anybody being on
this committee there's been many many
debates about the common good versus
individual liberty about Choice versus
public health and
um I think this was a bill
um that was damaging to our Public
Health efforts at the beginning of covid
and I think to be honest it's fairly
irrelevant at this point because I
believe that it was there was a ruling
from the attorney general that it only
referred to covid and
I'm not wearing a mask for the you know
one of the first times so I I think we
are in a different place and I don't
think it's that relevant but I will vote
to repeal
you will you will vote against the Ito
yes against the itl I will vote to
repeal the the original act thank you
representative Weber
and I represent while agreeing with
everything that representative Shapiro
said I will just say that I came to the
other conclusion
um I was one of the ones who did vote
for this when we passed it two years ago
I I did so with reservation but I did
think that we had limited it
in a way
that made me feel okay voting for it so
uh to be consistent I'm going to
continue to vote for it but
um I really see the other side of it as
well
thank you
um and one of the things that I'll speak
to it is specifically Limited in the
language to the covid-19 vaccination and
the department has spoken to having no
intention of having the covid-19
vaccination for the school children
however that's carved out so if they
chose to include that in the in the
schedule in the future this bill would
do nothing to limit that and I think
that at this stage in the game leaving
that one framework in there is not going
to cause harm and that by continuing on
with this it does show that
that there's there needs to be an
exchange when there's something that is
given is there any other discussion
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
call the role on an expedient to
legislate on House Bill 425 FN
representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes
representative McLean
yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosa yes
representative love yes
representative Weber
yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro no
representative Howard yes
representative Murphy
yes
representative Palmer yes representative
selig
no
and representative lamb yes
18-2
um thank you so the motion of itl passes
18 to 2 is there an objection to putting
it on consent
no objection thank you we'll put that on
consent avoid the discussion on the
floor
thank you and with that I'll close the
executive session on House Bill 425 at
Ben and open the executive session on
House Bill 528 FN requiring the division
of Vital Records to collect induced
termination of pregnancy statistics
it's the same one you said 528 it's five
oh five eighty two okay perfect yes
thank you occasionally I mixed those up
it was great with June and July on the
trading floor we had an amendment that
was circulated uh previously and I do
have a copy of that
somewhere in here
yeah we do need the hard copies handed
out before we start discussion if at all
possible because the amendments were
circulated late yesterday
the Amendments did come out earlier as
well but I thought it was better for
completeness to include all of those
that I had and we appreciate it
this looks to be I'll take one of those
as well this looks to be a split I hope
I got the division correctly
foreign
there's not an emotion but since we're
looking at this amendment um I will move
to adopt the amendment two zero two
[Music]
three-0392h to House Bill 582 FM
is there a second
I will second
okay thank you uh representative co-falt
seconds this so I will speak to this
amendment
um this amendment backs out a lot of the
personal details that had been included
in the initial bill the initial bill was
trying to figure out how to define these
lines within our our own statutes as
opposed to deferring outside so this one
with the amendment if you look to what
begins on line 21 instead of having the
extensive language about what would be
included it would specifically delegate
it to the CDC data specifications unless
they're inconsistent or contrary to New
Hampshire law so this would allow us to
then carve out anything that we needed
to in the future without
without future committees and future
legislate legislative bodies thinking
that we had intended to cleaver to bind
ourselves um to the CDC forever
this one would I'll ask the patients to
provide personal background information
voluntarily understanding that if they
wanted to provide their information in
order to help people understand what was
going on with abortions in New Hampshire
that could be collected but there was no
requirement to do so basically a chance
to let people's voice be heard if they
do want that information included but no
obligation to do so and this would have
this would have data protections within
there as well and it would also make
sure to say that only anonymized vital
record information would go from the
vital records department
so this is a way to come back to a much
better appreciation of personal privacy
that intention had been in the original
bill but it didn't seem to read true for
everybody as they were looking to the
actual language so I think that this
amendment now gives us a much cleaner
look at the information should we choose
to collect this data and become the 48th
state that does so
representative Shapiro
um I'm just not clear about one thing
there's been a lot of talk in this
committee about opting in versus opting
out and
um when it says online
patients asked to provide personal
background information at the provider
level may or may not do so on a
voluntary basis
are we talking about opting in or opting
out
that should be an opt-in this is uh
thank you that's a very very good point
um I don't think it's is it clear clear
right it is not clear
so I think it actually would make sense
thank goodness we have next week a
representative Weber
I I was going to just add to that that
if you know I I like the fact that it's
either opt-in or opt out either way but
I think that that when you get there
um you
are then making it making the data
useless for for statistical research
purposes because it's it's this who
knows who self-selects in which
direction and we've heard that argument
again and again about unless you're
collecting all the data the data isn't
really very good uh so there's that I
will I will say that I I think that this
amendment
overall is better than the original bill
so I I would be inclined to vote for the
amendment I would still be inclined to
vote against the bill as amended for all
of the reasons that we've talked about
before in terms of
um you know the data isn't very useful
at this point uh it's
randomized in ways that and it's it's
hackable so I'm still concerned about it
thank you representative Weber
um
so I will speak to the data quality as
well on that this uh this would still
collect that basic data required by the
CDC but the additional personal
information would be voluntary so in
that when you're doing a data analysis
on it it would be either information or
none provided so while none provided is
a less useful data point you could also
look and see that if if those Who
provided the data were just
statistically different than those who
did not provide the data that would be
interesting as well and a lot of times
data either can answer a question or
help us know what to ask that's one of
the benefits about how both proponents
and opponents of abortion itself both
both do see the value in data so
um
representative Shapiro yeah just uh
just to clarify I really don't
understand so what what is the
difference between personal background
information what what what
like if someone said they didn't want to
give personal background information
what information
would would be available so that would
be marital marital status and other
demographic information outside of those
that would be required within the CDC
framework there are data that are the
solid data points that are are necessary
to be required if you're a part of this
so the data collection we've heard about
Sweden that collects everything about
everybody but at least if we catch some
small part that gives us information
this is the intention to capture what
the CDC views as necessary data in order
to evaluate it while leaving the option
to include those optional ones that some
states do collect in other states do not
thank you I just want to mention that
um
we need some idea of how many of these
procedures are being performed every
year I think it's an indication of how
healthy a society is you know whether
they're raising their children or
choosing to terminate their pregnancies
um I think that even if there is some
limit to what it provides for us it will
still give us some insight and I think
it's important and I hope that others
would support it for that reason
representative Palmer
so that sort of gets to my question
which was I forget which state has a law
that basically just collects the number
and that's it and that certainly seems
like a reasonable data point because I I
agree that it would be nice to know I
mean
you know what other things do we do that
actually might reduce the number of
abortions besides Banning it are we
providing better day care so in better
our our young families in a better
economic position so they decide to keep
the child rather than that would all be
great but I I think I'd rather just see
this amend down to the point where we
collect the CDC data that's it we know
how many we know the numbers but we're
not worrying about whether we're
collecting other data that's
either
not going to be very valid or it's data
that could be
um could could lead to privacy issues
but
representative Murphy thank you and I
was just going to mention that um my
understanding is that massachusetts's
aggregate did only
um but I'm not sure that there may be
other states that also similarly only
get the gross number only which I think
would be helpful you know but I also
question it's you know necessity only
because we I'm not sure we keep any of
these Vital Records
um regarding other procedures that we we
tend to do in a hospital so I'm not sure
I still understand the benefit of this
but in reference to
um representative's question in
Massachusetts is at least one of the 48
47 that does aggregate data only
thank you representative Seth King
thank you
um
I'm going to be supporting the amendment
because it Waters down a bill that I
don't like
um
I would like to defend my position a
little bit and that is I am pro-life I'm
pro-life all the way to the point of
conception I believe life begins at
conception and one of the roles of
government is to defend innocent life
and we should be doing that at
conception that being said
I don't like the government collecting
information
about people even if there is some
anonymity involved
um I just don't like the government
collecting information like that what
this bill is and I I talked to one of
the sponsors of the bill when he
testified and I asked him well well he
said that the reason why Vital Records
should take this information is because
it's a death and therefore they take
they collect information on deaths and
they should do that and I said okay but
what about
non-induced you know terminations of the
pregnancies what about just miscarriages
and he said no we don't need to collect
that information and and I just thought
to myself well that's very interesting
because that's a death too and so we
should be collecting all of it and so to
me this bill is specifically
targeting abortion and If This Were a
bill to completely ban abortion I would
support it but that's not what this is
what this is is what is known as lawfare
it's it's
it's a roundabout way to burden an
industry that you don't like and I don't
like it when it happens sorry I think
you're getting a little bit too much
into motives we're not supposed to look
at the motives on that so you can talk
to more the data issue but okay well the
motives was was given during the
testimony so
um but anyways aside from that um
no um I don't like law fair whether
there's intent or not that's what this
will do is it will just cost taxpayers
money it'll increase the size of the
bureaucracy and it's not actually going
to stop abortion so for that reason I'm
against it thank you thank
you thank you on
um terminations or is it procedures that
could be also construed for example
some people with uteruses need to have a
DNC not for the purpose of terminating a
pregnancy but for other medical
medically necessary reasons and I'm just
trying to but it's a procedure that's
used for both right so I'm just trying
to understand
whether it's specifically termination of
pregnancy or if it addresses the
procedures thank you of Representative
Weber
it says specifically shall collect
non-identifying data on induced
terminations of pregnancy
yes thank you representative Missouri
yeah I mentioned it when the testimony
was being presented but you know when as
we know in this past election this was a
Hot Topic
um and I was trying to have a
conversations with constituents about it
with nothing to go on so people would
say well you know throw you could you
could throw at any number and no one
would know who's right because there's
no information collected for it either
you decide to make
um a decision either way on you know or
know how many are happening and all of
that so if my personal thing is I I
would find this very helpful for future
conversations with constituents so that
we both have what we need to have that
so I'm going to be voting for this thank
you
representative love
yes I'm going to be voting for this but
I'd like to share a little bit um
a couple couple different stories
um
I've been a member of Alcoholics
Anonymous for 32 years and I can't tell
you how many people how many women have
come to you know have shared with me
that they had an abortion and Damned
they drank themselves to death okay
alcoholism and drug addiction is a very
costly thing in society today
unless we have the statistics you know
the the uh you know the marital status
or you know the ages uh you know the
find out what demographics are having
abortions but maybe uh you know girls
from broken homes and stuff like that we
don't have to have a name put to it
but until that we're we're not going to
cure this okay and you know it was Bill
Clinton that uh that said that abortion
should be accessible and rare
we've missed the boat on that second one
you know uh we've got way too many and
we're not addressing the why you know my
sister had an abortion at 14 years old
okay uh my mother and father didn't know
okay it wasn't legal at the time her
boyfriend had access to one and uh once
again she was a girl that literally did
drink herself to death she was in and
out of Mental Hospitals her whole life
okay uh if we have statistics you know
that you know a bunch of 14 year old 14
15 year old girls in this town will you
know are having abortions well maybe
just maybe we can start doing some
education and maybe just maybe we can we
can avoid some of this stuff
I'm all for any type of Statistics keep
the names out but uh any we we need to
expand on this and and cure the societal
ill thanks
thank you
representative Nagel
I'm struggling with understanding the
amendment
um
so when we had the original Bill and and
I think the statistics are wonderful
until they get used or misused I I
struggle with Statistics in general but
it listed a number of things that we're
going to be asked I think this is
12 different items that were asked in
the original Bill and that's where the
problem ran in is that the people that
were opposed to this Bill said well
that's too many when I'm looking at the
amendment
I'm not sure what statistics we're
collecting
and um you know it seems to be an
open-ended thing to me am I wrong about
that
um thank you it's because it's those
this is replacing that list and that's
because instead of that list it is going
to the CDC guidelines on on best on they
have best practices for collecting
abortion statistics they have those that
they view as the bare minimum in order
to have a sample of data and understand
understand the scenarios around it so
this will be the bare minimum that the
cdc's requests the CDC has this and
it's it's one where it would have have
the information within there but then
there would be other parts that would be
voluntary that are the more demographic
based
representative Weber
now I'm really confused because I
thought that the uh personal background
information was different from the CDC
information
or is it the same as the CDC information
if if they can opt out of the CDC
information then that isn't good data
and if it's personal background
information that we haven't specified as
to what it is and somebody's going to be
asking people well do you come from a
broken home before they
allow a medical procedure for an adult
I just think that's inappropriate
thank you the CDC guidelines have um
have a whole Matrix of them some which
are personal information some that are
the other
there's there is already a breakdown in
that on the best practices that shows
which which are which this isn't
something where where where we're just
throwing things at the wall and trying
to say that we want to know you know
which years you didn't have Christmas
we're not digging that deep into
people's lives but we are looking to
those that they have found about
statistical validity and statistical
benefit in order to collect these data
and to do that not by us coming up with
a list but instead using those that they
have found to be valuable across the
other states and that they have found to
be asked and consistent where the CDC is
requesting that they be asked in a
consistent way so that these data can be
compared across States so that we can
understand the trends not just within
the states but on a larger basis
may I have a follow-ups so doesn't that
negate the the opt-out provision
the ability to opt out because they're
asked if they're supposed to be
consistent throughout
and we're saying well you know these
have to be answered and these don't have
to be answered or could be answered
the CDC has has optional questions
included so it would be the optional
questions
okay
um at this point I think perhaps we
should call the vote on this amendment
and and see where this amendment goes
and then we can see from there what our
next step would be
so with that if there's no other
comments I would ask the clerk to call
the role on Amendment 2023-0392h
representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative peloso yes
representative love yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
Shapiro yes
representative Howard
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes
representative select yes
and representative Leon yes
20-0 the amendment passes 20-0
um with that I'll recognize
representative Cushman for a motion I
move that we find HB 582 as amended with
Amendment
2022-0392 HB ought to pass as amended
2023 correct
2023.
and is there a second
representative Missouri
um I know that in the discussion we had
already talked to some of those
underlying issues around the bill I
don't know if there's any need for
further discussion or if we should go
ahead and have a vote
representative thanks I'd like to just
say one more thing to addressing my
fellow brothers and sisters in Christ
um you know uh King David sinned when he
even just collected a census on his
people
and there was a plague that fell upon
his people for that just a census
we're collecting more information than
that so there is a Biblical case to be
made that the government should not be
taking information on us in my fantasy
world the government would really not
care very much about anything we do in
our lives it would be almost
insignificant and
I am very much pro-life but this isn't
going to fix it and um thank you thank
you any other comments
um with that I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on House Bill 582 FN as amended
by
2023-0392h representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kopal yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King
oh
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel no
representative peloso yes
representative love yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay no
representative Freitas
no
representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro no
representative
powered no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no
Representative selig no
and representative Leon yes
it is eight to twelve motion fails the
motion fails uh representative
representative Weber
I'd like to move itl
representative
thank you
okay
and is there any further debate
I think just tell me though
oh yes the Italian the last one was
eight to twelve
thank you and uh with
as soon as your papers are ready
yeah
I
6582 yes
okay you ready yeah so I'm ready for the
clerk to call the roll on an expedient
to legislate on House Bill 582 FM
representative Cushman
no
representative Bill King no
representative Koval no representative
McLean no
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel no
Representative pelosa no
representative David Lowe
nope
and representative Weber
yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
represent Canon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro
yes
representative Howard yes representative
Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
Representatives uh Selleck yes
and representative Leon no
eleven nine that passed the inexpediate
to legislate motion passes eleven to
nine
um representative Weber he'll write the
majority report yes ma'am um is tomorrow
adequate yes where there's no there's no
session next week right correct we've
already met there's no session next week
so we have a session tomorrow so if we
can have all of the all of the committee
reports by noon on Friday since we'll be
in session most of tomorrow thank you I
think that would be very much
appreciated and I will follow through
with uh some of the promises I've heard
from the others it needs to be in by
noon on Friday so that we have these so
that they can move through the process
correctly
so if there will be a report noon on
Friday thank you and a Minority Report I
would assume of ought to pass is amended
um is there somebody who would like to
write that report
and if not I'm happy to write it
representative Cushman
thank you
and with that we close our executive
session on House Bill 582 FN and I'd
like to open the executive session on
House Bill 615 FN requiring independent
audits of reproductive Health Care
Facilities
um representative Shapiro
do you have a motion
I would make a motion to itl is there a
second
representative netting knotter up him I
need coffee I apologize
it it switched over there it's hard to
read on there thank you
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Shapiro
um yes
um
this bill will if passed would um
require
independent audits
um for a reproductive reproductive
Health Care Facilities
in order to prove that
um there was no
State money being used for abortion
services and
um
we heard from a variety of people that
extensive audits were already done for
these organizations
um
for or for
you know various reasons
um and so it would be duplicative
and also we saw that in the case of
earlier audits done by the Department of
Health and Human Services which
indicated that the organizations in
question were not you know were keeping
money separate
that did not seem to have any effect in
terms of the vote to provide that money
for Family Planning services
so
for both of those reasons I don't see
any sense in requiring something that's
going to be expensive and onerous for
these organizations
thank you would you like to speak to
yourself
are there other comments
representative love
thank you madam chair
um
the the largest reproductive Health Care
Facility uh in the state that does
abortions um has had lawsuits against it
and lost in the state of Maine and state
of Vermont same company by the way and
um you know whether they were
commingling co-mingling funds taking
Family Planning money and you using it
for for lobbying uh you know for uh for
payment of uh you know of uh
administrators in other states uh that
they they they they they play games with
the money uh they lost both those
lawsuits there was one in New Hampshire
but there was a deal struck uh this was
just prior to covet you know another
lawsuit
um the I I don't think they're entirely
forthcoming and we need to keep an eye
on them thanks thank you representative
Seth King
thank you I agree completely with what
representative love says um except I'm
against this bill
um
the audit aspect seems like a mess to me
um and whether the intent is there or
not this looks a lot like law fair
a straight up or down vote
on abortion
I would be totally in favor of but
that's not what this is this is just
more
um more meddling and
this could actually have the unintended
effect of legitimizing abortion further
because the industry is going to say
look you guys passed all these laws to
make sure that we didn't spend money
from this to give to that and we're
complying with that and not you know you
know now all of a sudden you want to
take away the right of abortion so you
know
to me this just seemed like it would
actually give ammo to the abortion
industry and further something I
mentioned several times the day that we
did testimony is that this is just an
economic principle that seems to be lost
on most people unfortunately and that is
all funds are fungible
if you give money to an industry even if
that specific dollar doesn't get used on
abortion it will be used for something
else and then the money that they had
elsewhere no longer needs to be spent on
those things now they can spend it on
abortion this was a big This was um this
happens all the time you know for
example if we give food to North Korea
then the North Korean government does
not need to spend money feeding their
people they can just spend all that
money building Rockets
even if this even if that food doesn't
get turned directly into you know
Rockets there that's money the
government doesn't have to spend on on
food now they can spend it on Rockets So
if we give money to the abortion
industry that's money that they can use
to you know build buildings and hire
staff some of that staff is going to be
used for lobbying efforts to increase
abortions so it's it's it's fantasy land
to think that we can audit audit their
spending and somehow segregate the funds
you're not segregating anything okay the
funds every every bit of money you give
to the abortion industry is going to
help further abortion period this is
just this is this isn't living in
economic reality and
um for that reason I'm opposed to the
bill I'll be voting itl thank you thank
you representative Palmer
yeah I'd like to just say a couple
things one um one of the things that
concerned me about this was there were
some agencies that were Health Care
Centers that provide services under this
um money that don't provide abortions
and so this would affect them as well
and we heard testimony to that and that
would concern me that here's an agency
that doesn't do any abortions but now
they're still going to have to do
another audit and cost them money which
then reduces their ability to provide
cancer screening and STD care and
prenatal care which we would like them
to do so that's one reason I'm well
that's basically it that's why I'm
opposed to this thank you representative
Bill King
so I I believe that there was only like
five agencies that they were going to
look at and all of them actually did
support
um however I'm going to also support itl
for the very same reasons that uh
representative Seth King mentioned is
that if you're giving them money
and they're using it to put to you know
use for keep the lights on it's hard to
say that they're not using the other
money for or other money that they're
getting so I think auditing is kind of
fruitless
thank you
um and I will make a comment as well
part of this bill is was to provide a
path to get to approvals from the
executive Council and I think that was a
lot of an attempt to by the sponsor to
find a way to in a good honest effort
find a way in order to bridge this Gap
so I think that that was the the stated
intention behind this bill
um I would like to call a two-minute
caucus
if I may or if there's a no discussion
of Representative Mr Shapiro I just want
to um
I just want to acknowledge your
statement and
um that I agree with you that I think
um
you know even though representative
Edwards was somewhat critical of some of
the organizations involved during his
presentation I think it was a good faith
effort to try to find a medium ground so
that money for Family Planning Services
would get through I I would just add
that
when we heard about the expense of these
audits it seemed like that would nullify
this rather small amounts of money for
Family Planning that would come from the
state but I I want to I want to also
acknowledge his good faith effort to
um find agreements so that this could
that those funds could
um find their way to people
services for people thank you
oh and if I can call a two-minute caucus
back in this corner with the Republicans
thank you
foreign
and with that we've come back from our
small two-minute caucus thank you for
indulging us
um and unless there's any further
discussion I think we're ready for the
clerk to call the role on inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 615 FN
representative Cushman
no
representative Bill King yes
Representative kofal no
representative McLean
no
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri
no
representative Nagel I want to make sure
I understood we're voting for Ito
yes
Representative foloza no
representative love no
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Howard yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative solid yes
and representative Leon no
13 to 7.
motion passes okay representative
Shapiro you're going to write the
majority report
yes you did
and uh the minority
no uh thirteen to seven another non
consent um is there a minority reporter
now
we don't we don't need to write one
thank you and with that we close the
executive session on House Bill 615 and
I will open the executive session on
House Bill 69 which is relative to
direct payments and membership-based
health care facilities and I have
amendment to pass around
and she says this is being passed around
um
this
all IT addresses is the last two lines
that instead of it speaking to it being
paid by the
uh played directly by the patient my
concern I can talk I can talk about my
concerns to it but that's what the only
change is
so so that I can discuss it with that
I'll make a motion to adopt Amendment
2023-0803h on House Bill 69 is there a
second
representative McLean
and I will speak to the amendment one of
the big opportunities from a cash pay
and membership-based model is that it
provides a different way in order to
provide care and charitable care right
now is a challenge within our hospital
system because there's so much unpaid
debt and there's so many costs from that
charitable care that we're moving in a
system towards more Medicaid coverage of
that but we all know that Medicaid
underpays and we also know that as a
function of how actually I don't know if
we all know but Medicaid has the option
to pay six percent less than the other
lowest payment so it's not possible that
if a birthing facility allows a prideful
mom to pay a hundred dollars for her
birth because she has to pay something
and that's all that won't hurt them that
Medicaid could come in and only
reimburse ninety four dollars for
everybody else so those rules the way
that they're set up up does provide a
way in order to undercut it
by changing the language to say build
directly to the patient this would mean
that if some that if somebody wanted to
just make contributions to this facility
in order to cover other people's care or
instead of a GoFundMe people decided to
make payments towards a facility this
would not be prohibited by law this is a
way in order to make to to find a way to
have health care facilities that would
operate not in the third party payer
system and entirely independent of it so
that if that were to spring up and
Blossom in New Hampshire it would be
possible and charity would be something
that would be embraced
this model has worked in other areas
there's actually a nurse practitioner
facility It's associated with Azusa
Pacific University out in California
that has a very very strong nursing
program and through that they have they
have a cash pay facility and it's more
than just a direct care they have they
have more so that it arrives beyond the
idea of direct care so what this
amendment would do would just be to
change some of that definition of direct
payment I think that if you're opposed
to the idea as a whole this doesn't
change your opposition in to the general
idea and I hope that this moves towards
a way that can allow people to express
their charity and and care for another
one another
in a safer way than GoFundMe scams
so with that representative Weber
thank you I have a question because it's
been ages since I've paid a lot of
attention to insurance coverage out of
my own but way back in the day there
used to be things that we had to pay for
out of pocket no and then a
uh an insurance company reversed us and
as we've been told several times today
dollars are fungible uh so I guess my
question is are we sure that the way
this is written
takes insurance companies and their
payments entirely out of the loop and
I'm not persuaded that it does so I'm
going to vote against the amendment as
well as against the bill
a lot of the power of insurance
companies is the power to negotiate and
if they're not the ones being billed
there's no power to negotiate and
there's nothing to obligate an insurance
company in order to pay
um
so this is not something that mandates
any coverage or any inclusion of anybody
with an insurance company and the way
that managed care and the way that
insurance has moved it is very much
based on those negotiated rates so even
if you're working at another another
facility
if you have one that is not part of it
and is not negotiated there's not as
much coverage as well so I would expect
that this would be excluded from
insurance plans because if they're
choosing not to do this then it wouldn't
be included and I I don't see this as
making it accessible to insurance I see
this is making it accessible to to
charitable care whether within the
family or within the community
representative Seth King uh thanks I
just have a question for you in your
Amendment um maybe you already explained
it and I didn't catch it but the only
thing that's different from the original
bill and the amendment is the very last
part there and is not reimbursed or
otherwise paid paid by a third party can
you just give me like an example of of
what would happen with the original Bill
and like an example of how it would work
with your Amendment and just what the
differences is I mean maybe you already
explained that I just didn't catch it
I'm sorry oh thank you I'll actually
give you a semi real world example my
mother-in-law was in a skilled nursing
facility that was Cash pay
um and so she was the patient but we
were the ones who paid so it was paid
for by a third party
that's an example
that's an example of a FL of a potential
flaw with the original bill that the
intention was to do with third-party
payers but as the daughter-in-law and
the son we are third party to that
individual
um representative Weber
so
I get that piece but the other thing you
said was that this would allow charity
care and other things and
um for a charitable donation to be a
charitable donation you have to donate
to a 501c3 or other qualified entity
and that has nothing to do with payment
for services because it actually to be a
charitable donation can't be for a
service you received or that's directly
related to you it's why you know when
you pay for you do your subscription to
W to the public broadcasting they deduct
the cost of the mug that you get back
from your contribution so uh this
doesn't have anything to do with
contributions it does have to do with
the situation that you said where there
might be a family member paying the
bills on behalf of somebody but I I
think we I I think if if we're holding
it out as
I'm not seeing the I'm not understanding
the charitable relationship except for
the charitable good Notions of somebody
else I think you can just make a
donation but I'm I'm still
anxious that this might be
a way
of getting building and getting dollars
back from
an insurance company because
you know you pay the dollars and you
submit the claim and they'll pay you
whatever they decide to pay based on all
those negotiations that you were talking
about which is perfectly clear and I
don't know whether that happens or not
but the fact is that because I don't
know
I'm still going to vote no
uh
thank you representative dangle I think
just to build on that by definition
these are not non-profit organizations
and I don't think that you can make a
donation that certainly tax deductible I
mean if you want to pay for somebody
else's carry you can do that right
you're right thank you thank you
representative sorry did you have a your
hands no longer up my oh it has been a
long week so far get ready for tomorrow
representative Shapiro I think you you
already employed or said this that you
know if we had
that this this changes things and
clarifies things
um but that if we in principle if we
were against the first bill um we'd
likely be against this bill and I think
two of the principles involved that some
people would see different ways
um are one that this
could involve cherry picking of of
people who can actually pay and leaving
other providers who have to give
charitable care who have to take anybody
who comes to their doors a greater
percentage of people who are under
reimbursed or unreimbursed and so that's
a concern of mine
so I'll be voting against the bill
representative McLean
yeah I mean I think
um if you have reservations about the
underlying Bill representative Shapiro
you know I think you're correct but with
respect to the intention of the bill
which is to uh you know bring forth
transparency and to alleviate
administrative uh burden uh with respect
to the provider this amendment
accomplishes you know both of those
goals as well so I am going to support
the amendment because I think the real
debate is going to be about the
underlying Bill itself so
thank you and I will speak to our
definition of charitable I think
representative Weber was talking to the
legal and taxable definition of
charitable I was talking to those
charitable people who used to show up at
Kmart when it was in business and pay
off people's Christmas club or those who
would go and pay off people's school
lunches because uh this it's an appeal
to people's people's better better
selves and I think that we do see that
in action quite a bit so I think that
this this bill is written in optimism
that people do want to care for others
and then there's people who deal in in
the idea that they've seen that fall
short enough times that they believe
that we need a different set of
safeguards so that's not a matter of
anybody being wrong it's just a
difference of of how to approach the
same problem and making sure we get high
quality affordable care to people
representative Seth King thank you
another question here
um one thing I like about the wording of
the amended bill is
it just seems to me like the original
bill is untenable because it says and is
not reimbursed or otherwise paid by a
third party but that seems totally
unenforceable to me I mean how can you
how can how can the government ever know
if somebody pays your bill for you after
the fact so that's since it's
unenforceable
it seems like that shouldn't even be
there and that's why I support the
amended Bill and so I think the real
debate would be on the the bill itself
but I think the amended bill just makes
sense from an enforceability point of
view so thank you
Is there further discussion
um if not I will ask the clerk to call
the roll when he's ready on Amendment
2023-0803h on House Bill 69.
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative profile yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative pelosa yes
representative love yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay no
Representative friedas no
representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro
no
representative Howard
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no
representative Selleck no
and representative land yes
10 to 10 motion fails
representative and the motion fails so
the amendment is not adopted
representative McLean I'll recognize you
for a motion
ought to pass on
hb69 as introduced
and I'll second
um is there a further debate or did we
already get to the core of the issue oh
sorry representative Palmer and then
representative yes so my concern and a
I'm sort of vaguely remembering some
testimony my concern is sort of
unintended consequences of
um sort of for-profit organizations
moving into the state and I think
somebody mentioned before cherry picking
and so while I like the idea of you know
like if somebody goes to the hospital
and somebody else wants to help pay the
bill or that kind of thing it would be
great to have that happen and I'm not
sure that it doesn't happen a lot now
and there certainly are concierge
practices in New Hampshire that only
take you know like a monthly payment
already so I'm I just I'm worried about
the unintended consequences and would
like some reassurance either in modified
language or somebody who's a better
lawyer than I am to
clarify that
sorry if I can just get to a little bit
more clarification
um do you have a problem with concierge
care when it gets into the healthcare
facilities
um
well actually I don't know of any
examples in facilities mostly just
private practices and there's some
controversy there
um there's the one that I know of in
Hanover it's two you know great doctors
who do a great job and the problem for a
lot of other people is that it works in
Hanover because there are enough people
in Hanover that can afford it where it
wouldn't maybe work in Claremont or in
the North country you know North Country
so
you know
but I'm just my point there was that it
it does exist
thank you representative Seth King
thank you again
um
when we heard testimony on this bill
everybody whether they were poor or
against it admitted to the fact that the
current system is really broken it's in
really really bad shape and that's
affecting everybody uh Rich poor young
old everybody's being affected by this
even the employees that work at these at
these institutions
um they're suffering and as a result of
this really horribly broken system
people are opting out my wife is one of
them she's a nurse she worked in the
hospital and other in other cares and
she just got sick of it and and I know
this is happening not just in this
country but around the world and and
it's just a it's a it's a vicious cycle
and we're spiraling down and something
has to be done and this allows people an
option to just opt out of that whole
system it's like it and we we allow this
for other Industries I mean if you want
to open up a shop and not accept credit
cards you can do that you can just be a
cash only business and you might have
some struggles you might have some
benefits but we at least allow them the
freedom of doing that here this allows
people who want to just cut out the
middleman and just work directly with
the consumer and I think that's a really
nice thing and the only real argument I
could hear anybody saying against that
is that they're a they want to keep
propped up this zombie industry this
industry that is for all intents and
purposes dead but it's being kept alive
through government Fiat and
that's that that's gonna hurt that hurts
everybody and it hurts our care too and
they're not getting the people aren't
getting the best care and so yeah there
might be a short period of time where
there's concierge care for for for
um cash pairs only but you know that's
just life I mean everything that ever
comes about starts off concierge I mean
when the CD player first came out it was
like two thousand dollars for a CD
player but you know within a matter of
years they were ubiquitous everybody had
a CD player they'd they'd give them away
if you wanted one so yeah there's there
there might be a little hiccup at the
very beginning where it's concierge care
but it won't be long before we've cut
out the middleman the every person can
afford to just pay for their medical
bills just like they do when they go to
the gas station and our care is going to
be better people are going to be happier
that would just be such a wonderful
thing and and I'm just sorry that people
are so afraid of keeping a zombie
industry careful you're getting going to
object very strenuously to the use of
that term because
well I just eject strainlessly to the
use of that term there are many people
who are working very hard in that zombie
industry and they should not be
stigmatized I wasn't okay fair enough
but I wasn't trying to stigmatize
anybody but it's it's just an industry
that um
it's past its time thank you fair enough
thank you representative McLean and then
representative Murphy
thank you madam chair uh I just kind of
want to speak to the motion a little bit
I mean we had a lot of great debate
during the public hearing on on both
sides of this issue but but I want
everybody to to remember that what this
is just essentially doing is building on
the primary care legislation that we
passed out of this committee two terms
ago and was passed by the entire
legislature and I just see it as an
opportunity to bring real transparency
and and real competition to the industry
and there were concerns
and I don't want to minimize those
concerns you know representative Murphy
asked a question he says well you know
is this cherry picking and it's
something that some of the other folks
highlighted on and I'm not going to Sure
code it it absolutely is I mean there
are certain patients that are going to
gravitate towards that but just because
that's the case it doesn't mean that
it's a Theta complete that the hospitals
would be denied access to those patients
in fact what it does do is it encourages
uh the hospitals to compete also another
you know
Point brought up was was by Paula
menahan at the hospital Association and
and I agree with her statement when she
said that the critical access uh
hospitals are hanging on by a threat I
mean she's a very effective
um advocate for her Association and the
fact of the matter is to reinforce that
point right after that Greg Moore got up
from AFP and he said sends to critical
access law passed nationally back in the
1990s 200 critical access hospitals have
closed and at the core of that I don't
think what's driving those closures and
what's creating that burden necessarily
is legislation like hb69 I personally
believe that the the threat is coming
from an increasing Reliance on Medicaid
and I think there are many people that
that agree with that the reimbursement
rates are are weakened I think that
while Medicaid has its place and I've
been on social assistance in my time I
don't think Medicaid was ever designed
to be a life sentence and to have the
penetration into the Health Care
Marketplace that it has right now we
have a quarter million people in this
state
um on Medicaid and we're looking to grow
that that's one in five one in six
people in the state and so if you look
back when Lakes Region Hospital went
bankrupt the Attorney General went to
the division of charitable trusts and
they asked them they said we want you
guys to do an audit because we want to
understand what happened was there you
know a violation of the board with
respect to their duties and basically
they came back and they said there's
none of that I mean everybody was doing
the right thing and maybe in the case of
Lakes Region there were some decisions
that were made in hindsight maybe
shouldn't have been made but one of the
things that came out to me when I was
reading through that report was the
assertion by the CFO at that time that
the hospital had an over-reliance on
Medicaid with this lower reimbursement
rates and that that was a model that was
going to lose the hospital millions of
dollars a year and then it was not going
to be sustainable so I don't think that
HB
69 is is the problem that is going to
break the back of the Health Care system
in New Hampshire
um I think if it does and it just
highlights the the weakness of the
system I think it's part of the solution
actually by opening the states up
um to new modes of delivery one of the
comments that Miss minahan also said was
hey you know the hospital Association is
very open to having new people come in
and but all that we ask is that they
play by the rules but I propose that the
rules really are a part of the problem
and that is why we have not had a new
hospital in the state of New Hampshire
in 30 years so hb69 doesn't get rid of
all the rules but it does get rid of the
of the all-payer model and and some of
the burden that comes with that so I
don't see it as the end of the world
um I see it as an opportunity to explore
new loads of delivery and and I hope
you'll support it thank you madam chair
thank you representative Murphy
uh thank you and I
as I've mentioned before when presenting
a bill and I appreciate representative
King's you know angst with our current
system because I also have lived in it
and I understand the anxieties
associated with it having said that and
I've said before we don't have a health
care crisis we have some great health
care providers in the state taking care
of our patients we do have an
operational and systemic wide you know
um uh administrative you know difficulty
with medicine but a bill like this is
really
very important from a theoretical but
also from a very practical point of view
there are a lot of unintended
consequences one of them is as
representative McLean mentioned in Paula
minihan
is that this will be a Death Note for
small Community Hospitals and it has
been
so for instance if you are a small
community hospital and you have a margin
of less than one percent everybody is
breaking out the champagne they're so
happy that they got a positive margin of
one percent unlike the insurance
industry that may get up to about 20 or
whatever
to get a positive margin in a critical
access hospital is extremely difficult
they have to take care of everybody at a
critical house one of the requisites
is that the emergency room has to be
open 24 7.
these private you know uh these private
businesses that take cash only you can't
call them up at midnight with your sick
child and take them to see them because
they're just not available they are
private practice and what that does is
that they have to go to the emergency
room of the critical access hospitals
which have to staff at 24 7 and as a
result they are now essentially cherry
picking as was mentioned if you have a
similar situation where you have a
freestanding MRI unit your hospital may
not be able to if they drain that
resource away that income that comes in
to a critical assets also or even
Dartmouth Hitchcock you know these are
Big Ticket items that they need to keep
the business afloat unintended
consequences you can pay more in one of
these facilities as a result you're
going to siphon off some of the
workforce that's already at a critical
shortage in a lot of these small
hospitals and the big hospitals the
other part of it is that this payment
that they put forward doesn't go to
their deductible so indirectly when all
of a sudden the patient needs something
a bit more
um involved more tertiary care they then
have to Pony up their deductible again
so what I don't understand is yes I
agree that the system operationally may
have its shortcomings but this is not
the solution it's only a potential
significant problem for many of the
hospitals in the state that are in
significant difficulties right now
um
in as a result of not having this
applied to the deductible the patient
may then get a double whammy at the end
they've they've paid the private you
know business or whatever that model is
but then when they get sick they're
going to still have to pay the
deductible that could have been used
otherwise so
um I appreciate the frustration with the
operational part of Health Care not the
delivery of the professionals but I I'm
fully opposed to this sort of uh Bill
thank you thank you representative
kofalt
uh yeah so a couple points um
one is I think there's been a lot of
talk about critical access hospitals
and you know I I guess I'm gonna
um
sort of frame this a little bit
differently which is that if we allow
this kind of
pre-market Healthcare facility
people might choose that product because
they feel like they're getting a better
value
um
if if the answer to the problem of
people might choose a better product is
to make sure that that product is not
available
then the system is woefully broken
and I think that that is true
so if the problem is that critical
access hospitals Community Hospitals are
operating at very very low margins there
is indeed a problem there
I don't believe that the the solution to
the problem is making sure that they
don't have any competition
so that that concerns me greatly having
said that
I don't actually believe that this would
create substantial competition for
hospitals that
are for critical access hospitals in
particular let's be honest what this
would do is it would encourage
facilities to open in the Southern Tier
of the state
that could either be destination
hospitals I think when we had the
hearing there was some discussion of you
know going to Thailand or Costa Rica or
other places for certain kinds of
surgeries because you know what you're
paying getting good quality care it's a
fixed fee so these become either
destination
Health Care Facilities or they become
sort of magnets Regional magnets that
would draw potentially draw patients
from from around New England
those sorts of facilities are probably
not going to open in Colossus County
okay
um
as to the question of paying a fee and
and then a deductible I can tell you
that I have heard plenty of stories and
I I think in my own family we have seen
this situation as well where paying out
of pocket
is cheaper than paying the deductible on
the insurance
that's crazy
but it's true so when somebody says oh
well gee you're gonna have to pay more
if you do direct pay I'm going to
actually dispute that I'm going to say
that there are cases where you're
actually going to pay less if you do not
Avail yourself of your insurance if you
go direct pay
um the surgery center of Oklahoma which
is sort of the poster child for this
kind of free market Healthcare
um
post therapy schedule online you know
exactly what you're paying
we just don't have that kind of
transparency in in uh
in in most health care facilities
um so you know I see this I see
opposition to this bill as as a kind of
protectionism for uh for for critical
access in Community Hospitals I
understand that there is a problem there
that problem
should be addressed I don't believe that
stifling Innovation is the appropriate
solution to that problem
son of Shapiro
yes um I think we've um
we've heard talk about this hurting
critical care hospitals and maybe some
would think it would be
um hyperbole to always be kind of crying
wolf that these hospitals are going to
close and
um
I'm guilty of hyperbole once in a while
um but I think the reality is I have an
article in front of me um you know about
um not not only hospitals closing but
losing certain services that are really
important to rural areas like obstetrics
and I have an article in front of me
that says that in the last three or four
years 90 89
my wife says I exaggerate everything so
I didn't get that much for going from 89
to 90. but 89 obstetric units around the
country have closed and I know that's
true I don't know if they've closed yet
but there was one announcement that a
frisbee Hospital in Rochester closing
their obstetric units and I know that
there was a comment I think it was
representative King said whenever this
changed
I'm paraphrasing there's disruption and
things kind of come back to an
equilibrium eventually
um
and you know I think there's some truth
to that but I think we need to keep in
mind that in the meantime this potential
harm to real people and
um
that frequently it's the poor people and
people with less resources and um
so I don't want to stifle inter in you
know entrepreneurialism and I I don't
want a stifle change I think we're
always in the position of deciding
we vote Yes or we vote no and there's
certain value to voting yes and certain
value to voting no and
um
I'm going to vote no on this clearly
because I think it it does
create a two-tier system and it does
create real damage to real people
potentially
um
through those unintended consequences
thank you sorry I'm representative
Cushman
thank you madam chair
I am very passionate about this issue
um I it keeps me up at night
um I think about it quite often and
I just want to touch on a few of the
points that have been brought up
um you keep going back to this word
cherry picking
and
um
and and then saying that we're siphoning
employees and there was a mention of a
two-tier system I would argue that we
already have a two-tier system
and one is the group of people who March
to the beat of the
um you know
um standardized American Medical system
and there are people who do not and
there are health care workers who have a
different view of health and Health Care
also and both of those
um groups are
disenfranchised by the current system
quite a bit and so one example is
mandates every hospital has to accept
CMS therefore you know has to engage
with the centers for Medicare and
Medicaid and and therefore they have to
mandate coveted vaccines for their
employees and so disenfranchising all of
those employees and arguably maybe those
employees would be feeling
you know the positions at these new
facilities if they didn't have that same
mandate
um
so potentially not siphoning but
providing an opportunity for nurses and
others to re-enter the workforce because
a lot have left
the issue with the deductibles that's
that's a you know buyer beware you you
know that your insurance isn't covering
this it's not going towards your
deductible and you're seeking this care
for you know your own reasons and you
know meeting your deductible is not one
of them
big problem I see in the healthcare
industry right now is that the patient
is not the customer the customer is the
insurance company and the insurance
company
and the hospitals negotiate rates and
then insurance companies offer a
discount to
services and that's what you're paying
for when you get insurance or if you
enroll in Medicaid you're not paying for
it but you know taxpayers are and you
probably have contributed to that too at
some point in your life
um
the whole thing is a house of cards
that's one blow away from falling it's
going to be insolvent the national debt
is increasing
more than we can even keep up with and
faster than we can keep up with
um
the the Congressional budget office has
been looking on how to deal with the
deficit and they're suggesting we reduce
Medicaid roles and you know it's just
the whole system is bleeding from every
orifice and
something needs to change this is one
step to allow an alternative to maybe
come up and satisfy some of the need in
the market that's not satisfied
um
I think that
if it if it proves to be effective so
for example and I I'll wrap up shortly
but to digress back to representative
Murphy's
um concern that you know con or maybe it
was uh representative Palmer over in
Hanover the concierge medicine you know
not everyone can afford it and in the
North Country they won't be able to
afford it and I think you're talking
about direct Primary Care
um but there is a there are
cheap direct primary care doctors you
know it's sixty dollars a month for 12
visits and the doctor comes to your
house at one of the direct primary cares
and they're in the North country and so
I think that this is an opportunity that
could alleviate some of the needs of
people who are
financially struggling
um and maybe don't want to engage in the
current system for whatever reason or
maybe they just see that it's a lot
easier when your doctor has time to talk
to you because there aren't those
insurance
requirements for documentation that keep
them away from the bedside and they just
find that the care and the access is
better
um and that there are cost benefits also
and I just think that this is something
that we need to offer people
um we all admit that it's broken we
should just give this inch and open up
the market a little bit
right now who's currently in there all
the current hospitals like it's it's
protect it's insulated by law
and
there is opportunity for alternatives to
come up and help alleviate some of the
stress and I just hope that you guys can
uh support that
representative Weber
I'm just wondering I don't think any of
us are going to change our minds here
and I think we're getting well into the
weeds of the much more Global issues of
the Health Care system and government
operations and everything else
um and I certainly can't
tell anybody
not to go on talking but
um I I'm just going to express my hope
that we can very soon get to a vote
thank you representative I I think that
it actually goes a little further than
that as some people see that this
actually is a solution to some of those
macroeconomic issues but I do agree that
this discussion while has been very
informative I'm not sure that it's
changed many Minds
um and we probably should be filling up
the papers with op-eds but I will
recognize that Representatives at the
king and then after that it will call
the roll I think that's all right thank
you for allowing me to make a couple
extra points
um sorry and if I can just say just make
sure that you keep kindness in mind with
your words yeah it'll be short
um
um I would just ask people what is the
conservative position the conservative
position is to maintain the status quo
the liberal position the progressive
position is to do something new that's a
forward thinking and then also
um to address some of Murphy's
representative Murphy's concern sorry
representative sorry representative
Murphy's concerns
um which are valid concerns that there
are certain money makers for the
hospitals like MRIs and there are other
things that cost them money and if
people are cherry picking and only
building MRI machines in private
facilities that the system could go
bankrupt it's a valid concern but I just
want to mention a couple other things
that in a more free market setting
actually works all the time so for
example gas stations they don't really
make their money from selling cash they
make it from selling concessions movie
theaters they don't make money from
selling movie tickets jobs they make it
from concessions Las Vegas as a whole
they don't make their money from shows
and magic and theaters and stuff like
that they make it from the gambling so
it is totally reasonable that
um
that uh private private hospitals
can end up picking up the slack if
hypothetically the critical access care
hospitals did go under that the Private
health care facilities would very much
pick up those so-called losing
losing operations operations that cost
the money they'll pick it up anyways
because they want to gain the customers
and they might actually be able to make
a profit on those things so I I think
the the the the the short-term concerns
are real but
um
if you have faith in people and the free
market and that people will supply a
demand then there's no reason to
long-term worry about this and and I and
I do appreciate the fact you gave me
another word on this because we have a
chance to actually make or some real
change here we honestly with just a
couple of democrat votes this this could
change how health care is done in this
state and so I'm asking at least some
Democrats to switch over and I think it
could happen
maybe not in this committee but maybe at
large because this is
this is a very important issue and we
could make a lot of strides for actually
providing real Health Care to people in
need thank you thank you and with that
I'll ask the clerk to call the role on
ought to pass on House Bill 69
representative Cushman
yes representative Bill King yes
representative Cobalt yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosa yes
representative love yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay no
Representative fredis no
representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro no
representative Howard no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no
representative Selleck no
and representative lamb yes and 10 to
10. 10 10 the motion fails
um is there another motion
Madam chair I don't know whether we are
required to do another vote on itl and
have that fail as well or can we just go
go ahead and say that the motion has
failed and that there'll be a minority
or they'll be two two reports if you're
happy to do that I'm happy to do that as
well I don't think anybody's going to
magically change their numbers
we can save the two minutes so if we
just do the do the two statements on a
10 to 10.
oh oh no we can't no no we need we need
to spend that time according to the
draft well I'll move itl in that case
is there a second
from uh there you go I thought we'd done
it once before but
and in a moment I'll ask the clerk to
call the roll
all right
a lot quicker than I wanted to
all right ready yes
um representative Cushman no
representative Bill King no
Representative co-fault no
representative McLean no representative
Seth King
no
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel no Representative
peloso no representative love nope
representative Weber no oh yes
[Laughter]
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon
yes
representative Nutter Upham
yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Howard yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes
representative selig yes and
representative Leon no and that is 10 to
10.
thank you and who will write the itl
report
I would love to volunteer representative
Murphy
okay
thank you
fantastic thank you and with that um
this closes the executive session on
House Bill 69 that gets
uh sorry and the out the
so and then the art pass
um report would be representative McLean
um the next bill that we will be taking
up is House Bill 323 I'm going to
distribute an amendment and I think that
we should take another be back at
um 3 29 3 30 so that we can read through
this as well because it does have some
rewrite to it and it was sent out last
night and we can take care of our
necessary coffee and other items so we
can get names correct so thank you we'll
be in recess until 3 30. we're you're
going to hand it out first oh yes please
I told you I need coffee
foreign
[Music]
and we won't be going past five o'clock
we're at eight so we want to try and
make sure that we're not required to
come in on Monday all right
um I'll be comfortable if we get through
at least 12 or 13 but we delayed some of
the long ones so let's try and get to at
least 13.
I think that's oh that's fantastic well
we'll enter okay
what's it called again when you can't
make your decision it's no decision
without recommendation
um thank you and welcome back
um we are going to open up uh I'm going
to open up the executive session on
House Bill 323 relative to establishing
a committee on emerging medical
Technologies
um I think it'd be most appropriate for
me to move the amendment
um and then we can discuss it would that
be the right procedure
representative Weber I always just
discussed it before moving it
particularly when I there were thoughts
of needing to amend it but okay then I
will defer to your I will defer to your
experience thank you
um
seems that I may have passed out my copy
of this but our thank you very much so
when we discuss this emerging medical
Technologies committee
um quite obviously this came about from
our late departed friend Catherine
Rogers
um I I failed in not including that in
the rewrite of it because obviously
she's somebody we want to honor and
that's something that we would
absolutely want to include going forward
um my background is an implantable
medical devices and my husband's is in
cancer research so I also automatically
assume that biomarkers for cancer would
be one of the topics of this and in
drafting the amendment I failed to
include biomarkers in there as well so
my intention would be to redraft this
amendment with reference to our our dear
departed Catherine Rogers and also to
include biomarkers within this
um
so those so if we were to look at this
through the lens where those are
included in this amendment I want to
talk through why these changes have been
made and why I think that this would be
a more effective committee I guess one
other note representative Weber has also
made made mention that the committee
members that they should be appointed
one by the speaker and one by the
minority leader and the same for the
alternates and I think that that is a
great idea it's better than specifying
members as as part of the parties
because we may have a scenario where one
party has the people who should be on
the committee and if there's agreement
between the speaker and the minority
leader
I love it when there's agreement so that
we should leave that option open
so by narrowing down this committee it's
so that it can be more targeted about
what's going on it can still bring in
all of those resources all of those
stakeholders all of those committee
groups that are relevant to the topic at
hand this this was brought in
specifically looking to biomarkers but
frankly emerging medical technology is a
lot broader than that and in our hearing
we did have discussion of that
um right now there's a big move to move
clinical research out of just the
hospitals and also into Community
settings which is quite fortunate for us
because Dartmouth is a fantastic
academic center but that has been our
main location for clinical research and
the amount of clinical research that
they've been doing has decreased in
recent years just because of all the
different issues that are going on in
the world by
having one of the charges of the
emerging medical the emerging medical
Technologies committee expanding access
to clinical trials in both academic and
Community settings that would be a way
to figure out how to reduce whatever
barriers we have perhaps see if
see see how we can make sure that they
have the right review irbs in place the
institutional review boards everything
else that's necessary in order to bring
these to Market if this is already
handled by Private Industry all the
better but if there's some hurdles where
we need to be a go-between then this
would be a committee that would have
that option of serving as a go-between
in order to either talk to departments
talk to boards talk to Commissioners
talk to other stakeholders and see if we
can find a solution before we get to a
legislative one but still have that
option open to us
um and
a large part of bringing emerging
medical Technologies you know we talked
about cherry picking I also talk about
early adopters quite frankly early
adopters are the ones that that Finance
Innovation for everybody else behind
them it's a little bit tough when you're
looking at these high cost high-class
new new technologies but we also want to
make sure that there's Compassionate
Care programs as well and that's one of
the things that recently the FDA through
some of the rulemaking changes have
largely shut down a lot of the
Compassionate Care that used to be
offered by the pharmaceutical industry I
don't know that we can necessarily
address that but if we identify that as
a large reason why our underserved
communities are not getting
compassionate access to pre-market drugs
and drugs that would benefit them there
would be more standing for this
committee to bring others in in order to
send that appeal up through the through
the appropriate channels to the FDA than
just having a random group of
legislators that aren't charged with
this task try and raise that to the FDA
and also removing barriers because it's
quite possible that we have significant
barriers both in our roles and our laws
that are limiting some of these emerging
medical Technologies but as we lift
those barriers we also need to look at
what happens when you lift them I was a
medical device analyst and I was there
when the drug eluding stent so the
cardiac stents started killing people
because they were flaking off with the
coating nobody had expected that they
were going to flake off so long so
people weren't on anticoagulant therapy
later on
fortunately it was caught early and some
great Pathologists were doing work in
order to find that I obviously would not
say that this committee is getting into
pathology or anything else but looking
to see who else has some information if
we're starting to hear problems of
people in our state harmed by some
technology that it may be in a position
to ask questions I'd say not even 99 out
of 100 times but 999 out of a thousand
times there may not be a role but
charging this com this committee with
the opportunity to do that in that one
in a thousand or one in ten thousand
chance could have a major impact on the
health of granite Staters so including
that within the scope I think would be
would be reasonable and helpful
I I also know of the risks of
implantable devices and how sometimes
the way that that's adopted it may need
a little bit more guidance from the
Board of Medicine and other and and
other overseers in order to make sure
that those who are adopting this new
technology are doing so with the right
level of training right level of
acknowledging of what's coming out of
these device manufacturers who send
representatives to help make sure that
they're implanted correctly as an
analyst there were plenty of devices
that had to be redesigned so that they
wouldn't be implanted incorrectly
and if we see if we end up seeing that
here in New Hampshire it would be good
to to to be able to be an early warning
system if there is suddenly an increase
in more morbidity or mortality that is
seen in any of these I reck by being
separate from it
um this gives us a bit of an opportunity
where we're not captive to the whole to
the whole hierarchy
and it's good to be able to have an
outside voice because you don't it's
very hard for people to raise a concern
about somebody's senior to them and
while this hopefully is never used
having this Avenue would be a way to
help protect the health of citizens of
New Hampshire
and that would be the signal say the the
available safety signals
um I know that if you aren't involved
um in this area that term safety signal
seems a little bit odd but for those who
understand looking at clinical data and
The Real World experience and and that
information that comes around you can't
Define what a safety signal is but when
suddenly you get outcomes that are
unexpected uh generally there is a
signal that you can find
and it's quite possible that we could
strike section three which is lines six
and seven on the back page about
refueling the appropriate non-disclosure
causes
the biggest concern there was just that
we had the experience
um with with the Manchester the
Manchester experience and if people are
being unable to speak about what has
gone wrong and then they're unable to
discuss the problems that it may mean
that that help doesn't come for the next
person who would be injured so that was
my intention including that line if
those two lines are too problematic I'm
I'm not wedded to them but I I did think
that it was was reasonable to make sure
that these agreements aren't prevent
preventing us from preventing harm to
others in the future
um that was actually one of the things
that was in the one of the Board of
Medicine charges I believe in the longer
committee was talking about that um
and it is one of those issues that we
need to make sure that everything is
balanced appropriately
and then studying the barriers to
expanding the presence of emerging
medical technology companies and their
suppliers in New Hampshire right now we
have absolutely Cutting Edge drug device
combination with Army in Manchester
um that place I love the advanced
regenerative medicine Institute and
they're doing groundbreaking work in
bringing cells and Scaffolding and
signals in order to grow new tissues in
new organs
we at times had had more manufacturing
for some of the device companies here in
New Hampshire but that has moved out of
state and my friends that have worked at
those have moved on to other Industries
I would like to see if there is a way
that we can encourage some of these
industries to come back to New Hampshire
and that would be fantastic for our
people because these are generally high
paying jobs and then other issues
surrounding emerging Medical Technology
if you're going to have a committee
let's make sure that their hands aren't
tied that they can't get into something
else because we don't know what the next
problem will be
and obviously as legislators making
specific recommendations regarding
legislation or investigation would be
one of those areas where we would be you
would hope that if legislation is needed
that this committee could actually draft
legislation as that committee
so this only needs to meet once a year
and it is a very large broad charging
but when there is a need it would be
able to come together mobilize and do
this if we look at my oversight on
biomarkers then we can bring that back
in and that's a discussion that needs to
be had right now because we have
biomarkers there's some that are still
only at the pre-clinical level looking
to biomarkers was part of the reason to
add access to clinical trials because
until we have enough clinical research
going on especially in the community
setting it's hard to know which
biomarkers prove most efficacious and
most beneficial and some biomarkers are
actually a signal not to use a drug so
they're very very important and the more
data and research the better so this
overall dovetails to bring this all
together so that they can attack that
issue but they're also able to deal with
other issues that could be helpful this
past summer we were a little hamstrung
about what to do with all of the
breaking news and this would have been
one way to ask some questions
so representative Weber
thank you for going through that so
thoroughly because it's really brought
me several other questions
um if we have a committee composed of
three people
that meets once a year
boy is that going to be a heck of a
meeting
because we have given them
actually I I I don't think that any of
the things that you've added here were
necessarily precluded by the other
formulation
so I think that it all of this could be
studied under the first formulation
uh but I'm beginning to think that maybe
saying that it's going to meet once a
year is
so that's at least once a year not just
once yeah I I get it but still in all
um as as somebody who has been involved
twice in committees to remove committees
that have not been particularly useful
committees and I I do understand that
it's it's entirely a function of who
gets appointed to the committee and how
proactive they are so in that respect
and it's certainly the way the original
bill was written and the original bill
had
the potential for having as much stuff
in it I just I just bring that to
people's attention uh my only concern is
that you know this is a lot to chew and
um maybe the committee will pick and
choose but it's a lot to chew on
um as as currently drafted and it's
more of a mandate for all the extra
things
than the original language of the bill
had
I just I'm just signaling that as a
thought
thank you what a change of the word
shout to May on line 23 get to that real
intention that these are all options to
the committee but not mandates
I think that
would be prudent
thank you
um
and then representative Shapiro
yeah I hope you'll indulge my ignorance
about this whole area you talked about
Compassionate Care and how there was
less of that than there used to be
in clinical trials for medications
aren't those generally
paid for by the the drug companies that
are doing the clinical trials or were
you referring to something else thank
you during the clinical trial it's paid
for by the drug manufacturer but there's
a time frame between when the clinical
trial ends and then when it'll be
approved and especially when you're
looking at drugs for terminal diseases
or if you're looking at orphan
indications there may be some where I've
known of some drugs that are in
development that only five or six people
have a specific need and there are data
to show that the overwhelming benefit
would be to offer it to this terminal
child but the way that the FDA rules
have been written it precludes some of
that so this compassionate use is not in
the in the clinical trials and it's one
of those where the drug companies do
want to provide it they've simply been
prohibited from doing that and so we can
come to them not from the people looking
to make all the money but the people
looking to serve the people in our state
and it'll be a different voice that may
be more efficacious I see thank you and
also the other question is
um second to the last line section two
of this actual take effect October 1st
2028 that's so that's the repeal of the
ACT that's the end yes um so we're
talking about this bill this committee
meeting for four or five years and then
making a decision about whether to re-up
yes okay good yeah so it will not be a
phantom committee 20 years in the future
good thank you thank you representative
Palmer yeah I was just looking and you
were talking about adding in the um
biomarkers and I'm just wondering if you
want to leave it more General so that
not only biomarkers but whatever else
comes up that we aren't aware of now
could be
included I mean there was just listening
to the whole thing about crispr and the
first woman who's been cured of sickle
cell and you know so there's another one
not that there probably is a lot of
sickle cell in New Hampshire but you
know what's the next thing going to be
um thank you we do have it and it's not
huge but we do have sickle cell here
um so the reason why I thought that
biomarkers would already be well
included is because we do have other
issues surrounding emerging Medical
Technology as deemed relevant by the
committee and to me it's supremely
relevant but
doesn't mean that I'll be around for
this committee doesn't mean that I'd be
chosen for this committee but that would
allow that so um and part of the reason
about having biomarkers specifically
called out is that Katherine Rogers
biomarkers were very critical in the
diagnosis and treatment with her cancer
sorry representative Canon
I was on this special subcommittee that
reviewed this whole effort and the thing
that we did flag was that there's a lot
of great Technologies but some of it's
moving as slow as some glaciers
and that we needed to monitor it
part of it was that the technology and
what it does but it's also the impact on
the state as far as who's going to pay
which is what we're discussing here as
we as those products are brought to
Market and are we going to have to worry
about Medicaid are we going to have to
worry about oh which insurance company
all right so part of part of this has to
be the awareness of the committee and
and
my guess is one time a year is not
enough
and but it is going to have to keep
track of a number of Technologies and
conferences and a number of other areas
to contribute yeah no thank you and that
actually was one of the areas that I had
been concerned with with the original
scope because if you were to follow all
the conferences and all the Publications
relevant to the area
um we'd probably need the entire
legislative body just drained up and
competent on that I covered a very very
narrow subset of implantable medical
devices and even with that I had to
narrow it further
um I I was attending a dozen medical
conferences and they never overlapped
with a lot of other analysts so it's
it's such a complex area that
it was right for Burnout from trying to
cover all of that data because as it is
I get mid page today but I can read that
maybe once a month when that email comes
through
if I believe that the original Bill said
at least annually
um and it's it was the same language in
the bill so I I didn't want that we
might want to change it to maybe
quarterly at least quarterly I think
quarterly would be good just for our own
Comfort level
I'm sorry representative Nagel
you have a few refers oh sorry who did I
miss well representative Murphy put his
hand up first
oh you recognize me though yes all right
fine
I mean one of the interesting
testimonies that we had heard that
prompted a re something for me was this
is almost an impossible charge yeah and
um was that what you were gonna say oh
darn sorry
it's lent I shouldn't have done that but
um
[Laughter]
I I just I have a couple questions that
that are you know that we're almost like
not in an executive session here I
is this already being done this state in
some way how do other states handle this
issue
um are we is this a first in the nation
type effort um how do other people do it
I mean those are all my questions
regarding this because this my thinking
about this was you know a technology
comes in bad things happen which is you
kind of already raise and that may be
the focus of something like that it just
seems the focus is too broad
um thank you I think I think that it is
a broad Focus but
um it's a matter of it being allowed to
focus on representative marketing no I
was gonna Echo what uh representative
Eagle said but I I regardless of
changing Xiao to May it is seems like a
monumentous task to do
um and I wonder if it should go to not
only quarterly but maybe doubling up on
the number of uh Representatives that
are on the committee I mean this is It's
a sizable task and I'm just thinking
that wow you know even if we change it
to may you know it's still there's a
broad spectrum of data that we have to
take a look at that's all
willing to go to four and two
representative Weber did you had
something or no
no I think I think it's
I think it was sort of subsumed in some
of those comments so okay
yeah is that Representative Bob kofot
hasn't spoken on it yet
so I guess so I was very interested in
the mention of regenerative regenerative
medicine because I think that's one of
those areas that uh
is
going to be growing rapidly in the in
the near future and has a lot of promise
but I guess for me the the line the line
that stands out here is line 29 on the
on the amendment removing barriers to
access for emerging medical Technologies
um
I mean practically speaking you know
this this committee is going to be
composed of people who are
um who may or may not have
medical expertise per se but as
legislators we can propose legislation
that removes barriers and gets
government out of the way or or in
essence you know paves the the way for
uh for Innovation to happen here in the
state I am
a little bit
concerned that you know we do have a
proliferation of committees and
commissions and uh
although we have not yet met we have a
committee on commissions uh that is
going to be uh meeting in in April to
get rid of some of the excess committees
and commissions that have not met in
quite a long time having said that I I
do believe that this is is worth moving
forward with
um I think it's an opportunity for us to
solicit input from medical professionals
to understand what are the barriers how
do we get out of the way how do we pave
the way for Innovation and
um you know and and move forward with
some of these life-saving technologies
that uh
you know that are are coming at us
rapidly and you know we just need to
make it possible to innovate
representative McLean
um thank you uh Madam cheers I'm just
wondering about the mechanics of how
this would work the three people who are
chosen even if it goes to six people
maybe they're medical maybe they're not
MediCal so how do they identify what to
attack who just to solicit
um is there a reason that this is a
committee and not a commission where you
might be able to bring some people in
that might kind of guide the direction
um and that's my only thought
um thank you actually if I can speak to
that and to the other one
um part of it is this they would still
be able to bring people in for those
discussions
um and that that flaw around the people
who are on there and what their
backgrounds are is also one that's
common to the underlying bill
um this was to try and craft it into
something that
wouldn't be so deeply focused on the
day-to-day publication minutia
um but could zoom out a little bit so
that it could then choose selectively
and then dive down from the 50 000 feet
to whatever level of inquiry
representative Weber and I would just
say that my experience of committees and
commissions is if you get a commission
with 26 people on it then the 27th 28th
and 29th are going to come here and say
why weren't we on the commission
so it was framed in the first place as
these people shall be invited but it
shall not be limited to if you actually
put them on as voting members you will
never get a quorum and getting them
appointed is a Herculean task
so I have seen the seminal one was and I
can't remember her name but a wonderful
uh very effective representative
Republican who started in the house and
then went to the Senate but she did a
committee and there were five members on
truancy and she managed to bring in
every single population who might be
affected in any way from school through
truancy officers to all of the home
school people came every single time and
put in their input and how are we going
to track all of this and she had she
must have had 40 or 50 different people
Plus at least 20 constituencies who were
there for every single meeting because
it impacted them they knew it would
impact them and you know one of the
things that we have seen with some
committees is
um
occasionally they're set up to favor one
particular goal and this one is Broad
enough that I think
uh that that wouldn't happen but
sometimes there have been committees
that have been uh captured by their
appointed non-legislative members to
further an agenda to make it easier to
further legislatively their agenda and
that's not necessarily a bad thing
but it's something I would look at a
little more carefully than
otherwise
and to speak to the speed of
regenerative medicine coming to us in
New Hampshire back when I was on Wall
Street I wanted to be the best person on
stem cells so back in 2008 I went to
Case Western Reserve University some
some
tissue engineering course for two weeks
because I thought those were around the
corner those are the products that
they're working to bring to a platform
that could potentially move towards the
market in Manchester in The Mill Yard so
you don't know which barriers there are
so it's a challenge so I'm hopeful that
this is something that if we amend it to
include the reference to return the
reference to representative Rogers
change it to two members of the Senate
four of the House of Representatives
move it to a may add biomarkers and make
it quarterly that that
would address the issues that people see
with this amendment and if that's the
case then I can have that redrafted for
us next week and this would deal with
some of the issues from the summer
so
anybody have anything else I needed to
add to that representative not not to
add but I like the forward thinkingness
of this bill you know it it's not
um so many of our bills were solving
problems but here we're looking for
Solutions or I think it's a great idea
thank you
uh then if there's no other concerns
then um we will recess the executive
session on House Bill 323
um until next week um we'll be noticing
in the calendar specifically what which
days I'm hopeful we can get through
enough bills so that we only have one
day next week and with that I will open
the executive session on House Bill 454
relative to the membership and Reporting
responsibilities of the Examining Board
of Medicine
um and I represent recognize
representative Cushman for a motion
thank you I moved that
house bill
sorry 454b
ought to pass
and is there a second
I will second
yep thank you would you like to speak to
your motion sure
this bill was brought to us by
um representative Jess Edwards
and it creates a position
um sorry like going off memory
it adds two
um
two of the public members to be
on sorry any member of the public so
it'll add an additional public member to
the board and then
one of the public members is going to be
designated the public transparency
Advocate it's to try to bring
some openness to process have someone on
the board just ensure that the way that
things are going is with a mind to
transparency I think it's a pretty
simple change
and um
I think it's worth bringing to the house
floor
thank you I'm representative kofot would
you like to speak to your motion
no I I just I I would Echo the the
statements that representative Cushman
made it it it it provides greater public
participation and transparency so I
think it's it's worthy of uh were there
worthy of Passage
representative Palmer
that's right my only comment is I'm not
necessarily opposed to this but when um
representative Pearson was uh testified
um I think he testified on all of these
ones about the medical society I mean
the uh
Board of Medicine thank you
um is that the other bill is is uh 322
which established the committee to look
at all of this and so I'm just wondering
whether that's the bill we want to focus
on and then bring it back rather than
making a change and then having this
committee come up with other ideas for
it for changes
that's my comment thank you
and I will make my comment on this one
of the issues with the news this summer
was that there didn't seem to be
transparency and people didn't know how
to be communicated with around those
emerging risks we need to make sure that
this is done in a way where it doesn't
harm our doctors it doesn't harm our
hospitals and especially doesn't harm
our patients and having a public public
transparency expert seems to be a
minimal intervention in order to let
them see if there's something that they
can find as opposed to looking from the
outside and so personally
um with a combination of
making sure that new Innovative devices
that there's a way to check up on that
with the Board of Medicine if there are
problems and combined with having a
public transparency I think that that
addresses the issues that um brought our
state to the headlines last summer
um and would be able to do that without
creating that Commission on the other
rules representative Pearson is a
co-sponsor on this bill as am I with
representative Edwards on this so it was
was one approach to do that on a light
touch
representative Shapiro it seems to me
that one of the things this bill does is
it it says at least two of the public
members
um
shall be a person who is not or never
was part of the medical profession and
that seems like a reasonable idea to me
to not make it a
Club of just medical professionals who
might be self-protective so that seems
like a good idea to me it seems like
when we were talking about this bill at
the hearing
nobody could really figure out how this
quotes transparency Advocate would
actually get information from you know
how information would come to that
person of the kind that we weren't
getting about this doctor in Manchester
so I'm not really sure how that works
but doesn't really matter to me that
much it's just you know I would be in
favor of this bill because the spirit of
it is to try to open things up and make
it more transparent and
I'm not sure how effective that position
will be but I I think I would support
this bill anyway thank you
representative Nagel I I think to answer
that question that's where the other
Bill comes in is to figure out how
such and such a hospital will deal with
the Board of Medicine For example there
was no requirement that that hospital
shared that information with the
hospital but once that information is
solved hopefully with the other bill
then this person's job becomes more
effective
representative Weber
and I am remembering that Mrs Casey my
sixth grade teacher would have told me
and we talked about it last time that we
should have made it shall be persons who
are not because it's at least two of the
members shall be a person doesn't work
but that is the kind of thing that can
either be fixed in the senate or by
enrolled Bill Amendment because it is
merely grammatical in nature so I don't
think we need to hold up for uh
um I don't think we need to hold up for
an amendment and if we are expecting to
get as far as I think we were hoping to
get
um we need to move along so
would you like representative
yeah so just in response to
representative Shapiro's question about
how how would that public
transparency Advocate there is a line
added to Statute in towards the end of
the bill and I don't have line numbers
in front of me right now but
um that essentially says the the reports
of that public transparency Advocate
will be made part of the public record
so I think that there is a mechanism in
place that that helps to at least
increase transparency to some extent
that are we ready to call the roll
uh then I would ask the clerk to call
the role on ought to pass
bill 454.
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative peloso yes
representative love yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
I think I heard yes right okay thank you
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Howard yeah
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative select yes
and representative lamb yes
we'll need a zero um it passes 20 to
zero any objections to the consent
calendar
and I see representative Cushman would
be doing a lot of writing I'll write the
my the committee report on this one
with that I opened the executive session
on House Bill 322 relative to
establishing a committee to study the
New Hampshire Board of Medicine and I
recognize representative Bill king for a
motion
yes House Bill 322 is a bill that
establishes a committee to study the New
Hampshire Board of Medicine
and I would like to make a motion that
we make this one in expedient to
legislate even though my great friend
representative Mark Pearson is the one
pushing this one through I did have some
discussion with him and we just needed a
second and then you can speak to emotion
for a second
thank you and now you can you can speak
to the motion representative King all
right
sorry about my eagerness
um
so
as I mentioned
my good friend representative Pearson
Mark Pearson
put this bill forward and
um you know
he has kind of admitted that there's
duplicate bills that are doing similar
things and we just talked about one as a
matter of fact maybe two
So based on redundancy I would I would
like to find this one in expedient to
legislate
thank you would you like to speak to the
second or is that included in there
it's further discussion
representative Weber I was just going to
ask a question which is
um if there is another one other than
these two what's the third one
it's in another committee and yeah oh
okay thank you
representative Palmer
so this isn't so much
I
I think that the state of Vermont just
went through a whole sort of
reorganization of their committee
and
I guess my the reason I'd be in favor of
starting this so I'm not I'm not gonna
go nuts about it is just that there was
some sort of tricky issues about how to
balance getting better transparency with
maintaining peer review
and it may be that we sort of wait and
see what happens and come up with
another bill next year but it's it's an
issue that um I mean there's a very the
fine line is
um
transparency versus making it possible
for things to be reported in a hospital
so we can we can correct problems before
they become bigger problems or um and
and I just want to make sure that we
don't lose that but again maybe it's see
what this does to the Board of Medicine
see what happens over the next year and
then come back with something to look
more closely at that
representative Weber
and following on in that vein I just
want to put forward
without
really taking a position one way or
another would that mean that it might be
more
um
sensible of us to retain this bill in
case we need it in the fall or whether
we sh rather than a straight itl which
then means you have to bring back
something substantially different next
year
um
I think I think that that
I think that that may be reasonable um
but
if that was something the committee
wanted to do we could do that with uh
the person moving and seconding
withdrawing their motion but I I don't
want to force that on anybody one way or
the other I'm I'm comfortable with
either
um
not sure if that's if that's something
where the
yeah I would like to withdraw my motion
to uh in expedient to legislate and make
it retain all right thank you and this
and our second was uh representative
Resort do you agree with that as well
with John thank you
I think that that was a excellent point
if we want to vote on the retained
motion I think we're ready to call the
roll there
we are
you're tasked with everything on this
bill okay so did you make a motion to
retain yeah I just saw you
one fell suit good job
you're amazing
okay uh representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative cofo yes representative
McLean
yes
representative Seth King yes
Representatives who are yes
representative Nagel yes
representative pelosa yes
representative love yes
representative Weber
yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative
representative representative Shapiro
yes
representative Howard yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes
representative selig
e
I was on Leon yes
and the vote is 20-0
and so House Bill 322 is retained in
committee
um
representative kofot do you have your
Amendment for House Bill 408
I I do not have that I thought we were
going to defer that to another day
that's what I wasn't sure so I wanted to
check to check with you
um so and we do have the amendment ready
for house bill 342.
um so I'll open the exactly what's
happening to 557. oh sorry um and let's
defer that one as well
and if you I'll open the executive
session on House Bill 342 FN relative to
lead testing in children and uh
representative Shapiro has an amendment
that'll be distributed now
for those keeping track at home this was
our 11th bill that we're moving forward
on we started relatively late and I'm
not sure the feeling in the room if this
would leave sick if we ended it after
this one this would leave us 16 bills on
Wednesday I'm hopeful we could get to
another one but remember we did spend
two and a half
two and a half hours this morning in the
work session so I think that it would
would require work on our part we could
still be feasible for one day next week
I don't know if there's any disagreement
about whether that might be feasible I
think we should try and get through as
many as we can today too to make next
week better
yeah I was just going to say I mean
pushing through till five I mean we did
we did talk about five o'clock yes
that's the end time so yes
so um if you'd like to tell us a little
bit about what this amendment does
representative Shapiro sure should I
make a motion first you can make a
motion I will
make a motion to adopt Amendment zero
eight four two to House Bill 342. and is
there a second
representative net arapham
so if you'd like to speak to your mom
yeah so what this bill does is um
it takes a requirement that um
Physicians test
Health Care Providers test young
children for lead poisoning and it um
it makes it requires
um day cares
um
programs for young children
and
schools for children up to six to
um
document in the in their um
to document in their physical exams that
are um forms that go to the schools and
and daycares to document whether the
children have actually had a lead
blood lead level taken
um
so that's what the original Bill did
there was some concern on the parts of
daycare providers that if
um
if they were required to document this
but the parents didn't get this done
that they would in some way be
um
dinged for for this so the the amendment
really just
says that if for the school district's
end for the um
daycare providers that if it has not
been done and if it is not it's not
indicated on the original
forms that the
providers will be responsible for giving
parents information
about the
that this is supposed to be done and the
dangers of lead poisoning and they will
document it in their records and they
will then have been done their Duty
um
so I know that it was Henry vayu who
spoke on behalf of the day care centers
saying that this could be a problem and
my understanding from representative
Murphy who is no longer here is that
she's there oh she is
that she talked to him and she was good
with this and the Department of Health
and Human Services was good with this as
well
thank you
would you like to speak to your second
um yes just a moment so we had a lead
Bill last year or the year before and I
cornered for pediatricians out in the
hallway after and I am because they had
cited that the testing
the numbers of testing percentage of
people children being tested had dropped
and I said so why is that and they said
because the they had a little machine
that did a finger prick that would test
for the lead levels and they'd all been
recalled and so the only way to get a
blood draw was a big blood draw and you
know I was the mother of the
four-year-old that we had to hold down
so
um hopefully that machine has been
reinvented and along with initiatives
like this we can get back up to a good
level of lead testing
so it wasn't just
poor parenting or daycares not following
through but a mechanical failure of of a
testing machine
for further comments
on the bill for the amendment I'm sorry
on the amendment
seeing no further comments on the
amendment I will ask the clerk to take
the rule role on Amendment 2023-0842h
representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Copo yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative yes
I'll get that eventually
representative love
yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yeah
representative Howard yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative select yes and
representative land yes 20-0
and I'll recognize representative
Shapiro for another motion yes I will
make a motion that we vote
otpa on House Bill 342 amended by
Amendment 0842h
a second by representative thank you
fantastic
would you like to speak to it or do you
feel that it was spoken to with the
amendment I would just say that um this
does not change the requirement for
um blood testing which is all
um blood level
blood lead level testing which is
already in statute it really just talks
about
um recording this when a child goes to
school or to daycare and the reason as
representative Nutter Upham said is that
um
the amount of people actually being
tested the amount of children actually
being tested had gone down and this is
an effort to up those numbers and that
there's also an exemption for parents
who for some reason did not want their
children to be tested
I have concerns with this bill and some
of it uh you heard when I was
questioning during the healing that it
feels to me from the graphs that we get
that instances of this problem
um are not
as prevalent as they used to be and this
morning I heard about program to get rid
of uh lead pipes and definitely we have
quite a few programs to get away from
lead in painting even in all the housing
and also uh knowing that
these are already some
testing and this bill just plain to
force people into testing the totally
exist I have my concerns with this Bill
thank you thank you representative
um
directly to you we were told we have the
oldest housing market in the country we
have a pathetic program for lead
remediation compared to other states so
I think there's I don't know about lead
pipes but
um I think there's a great need for this
as so many people live in older older
older homes in this state
thank you representative Canon
um as a
facilities director for
Child Care Early Head Start and Head
Start facilities in the Stratford County
area
a couple of our buildings are old
and although the the walls and the trim
has been painted a number of times
they've essentially encapsulated
existing lead pen paint underneath
when a child
that is in a classroom in the building
is tested later
and test positive for lead
the entire building goes through
a an intense
search for where did is it did they get
the lead from the building
and that may result in the actually
emptying out the building of the kids
while that testing is accomplished and
and trying to figure out also
or other kids in the in the building
affected this program in doing this
would limit
the additional testing required and the
impact on a small business that is
trying to take care of children for
people in their area so I'm all in favor
of
this Bill thank you representative Weber
and I just wanted to point out that the
the exception because we've we've talked
about opt-ins and opt outs and all those
different things but the exception on
this for a parent is is absolute uh 130
a colon 5C which is what was referred to
in the bill the existing statute
requires all parents or legal Guardians
to have their uh
child tested for blood lay level at the
ages of one and two but then it says a
child shall be exempt from this required
blood level testing if a parent or legal
guardian objects to such State Testing
and provides a statement to such a fact
so all they have to do is say
I know that lead testing is required
recommended but we're not going to so it
leaves all of the power of the testing
in the hands of the parent
thank you
representative Cushman
I'll be brief this is a mandate I don't
support it I would rather see the law
repealed
and that is all thank you
thank you representative Bill King
yeah I I um
I have mixed feelings about this because
I think the testing is good for the kids
and for the parents if it's all about
addressing the the lead issue in the
child
but what ends up happening is a witch
hunt starts as soon as you get a
positive test
and to representative Cannon's point
they're going to shut down a building
everybody's going to go in figure out
where the lead is they're going to go to
the landlord I actually have a
constituent that's being evicted which I
don't think is legal but she's actually
being evicted because her child tested
high on lead and it could have been at
Grandma's house
um you know there's there's numerous
places you can pick up lead my fear with
laws like or bills like this and the law
that we currently have in place I'm with
representative Cushman that really needs
to be repealed is that it creates a
Witch Hunt and therefore I can't support
it
thank you
representative
um
six years ago I went apartment shopping
for my daughter and her husband who were
moving up from Louisiana and in
Massachusetts where
um
a landlord has to prove that the
apartment has been LED remediated if
they're going to rent to people with
children
so that's a standard that New
Hampshire's not going to be able to be
up to for a very long time but this is
about
safety and health of our children and I
mean I can't read off
the dire consequences of lead poisoning
but maybe some of the doctors in our
room could if we wanted to so I think
this is a small step to keep children
safe
and of course it's a terrible
inconvenience for landlords and and we
had a landlord speak in front of us
probably last year who said any program
that the state of New Hampshire any
amount of money that they could offer to
help towards lead remediation would be
so welcomed so I think
that's where we should be working is to
find more money for lead remediation and
not say well let's not test the children
so we don't know so
thank you other comments I actually will
make some comments as well myself
um I don't know if you know yet but you
probably will soon I watch way too many
Forensic Files and I remember Sunday's
child she was a refugee child in
Manchester who died unexplainedly until
they found out that she had elevated
levels they investigated everything
around where she was and then they found
out that she liked to spend time on the
porch and so she had Pica and she was
flaking off pieces of of paint on the
porch
that was in Manchester it hits home it
absolutely is an issue and I do agree
that what we need to do is be focusing
and taking our attention to make sure
that we can figure out ways in order to
solve those problems I think that we
have we do have the requirements in in
the statutes
when we have this and we add yet another
form for our yet another line I really
really appreciate that this does include
it removes any punishments on the
facilities and the schools it makes it
very clear again that this is up to you
but here are the hazards and here's the
information
um
but we're gonna have written materials
that are printed out by the department
to be handed out I actually went and I
tried to get some nice informational
handouts to distribute from the
Department we don't print many just
because the return on investment for the
printed materials is on the lower side
and
I feel for these kids I feel for these
situations but I feel like we might feel
like we've done more than we actually
have by passing this and so that's why
I'll reluctantly be voting against it
but I do I don't think that it actually
furthers our goal of dealing with that
core issue of lead in in the housing
stock and that we also have issues of
you know toys that are coming in with
lead paint so you may have gone through
the entire house displaced a family and
then you find out that they're chewing
on a rubber ducky that they got off the
internet that's covered in red lead
paint or the old one that we had that
had the lead nugget fall out of the
bottom of the rubber ducky that we had
from my mom because it finally was loved
enough that that piece fell out and
we're nerds so we test our metals
so it's a complex issue but I'm not sure
this is well intentioned it moves a lot
further but I'm not sure that it does
what it does so
representative Palmer yeah I just add
that I was just looking things up and
the lead lead poisoning is
twice the national average in New
Hampshire so it's it's a significant
problem here and maybe this doesn't take
care of the whole problem but at least
we maybe will get a better idea of where
the problem is and I certainly agree
with the whole idea about needing
better programs for mitigation so that
people don't get displaced but it I
seems to me like this is a reasonable
place to start so we know know where the
problems are
we may have a reasonable people disagree
sort of one that we may want to vote
move to voting on
um is that I didn't mean to cut you off
representative but if we're ready to
move to have the clerk call the roll for
ought to pass as amended by
amendment2023-0842h
representative
representative Cushman
no
representative Bill King no
Representative cofo no
representative McLean no
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel yes
Representative pelosa no
representative love no
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon
yes
representative Shapiro
representative Howard yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative selig yes
and representative Leon
representative lamb I'm sorry yes uh
sorry no
no
. so the the motion passes ought to pass
as amended
um
would you like to write the majority
report representative Shapiro and do we
have a Minority Report
I'll take some of the others off with
your plate but I'll give you the
Minority Report
you'll do The Minority Report fantastic
thank you very much
um
I know the next one on our list is 406
but we're going to take another look
um to an amendment on that one
um so I'd like to open the executive
session on House Bill 114 relative to
the age at which a minor may receive
mental health treatment without parental
consent I have an amendment to that one
that I will pass around
and I will make a motion to
adopt Amendment
2023-0036h on House Bill 114. is there a
second
I'll second to speak it was a second
Mark okay perfect representative McLean
so I will speak to the amendment
um
minors and especially teenagers in those
difficult high school years really need
somebody that they can trust to talk to
and a lot of parents want to make sure
that there's somebody that they can
trust to talk to as well especially when
they know that there's guard rails
around that conversation just to make
sure that nobody's being influenced in
one way or the other there's a
definition of non-directive counseling
from the American psychology Association
that is what is on lines 13 through 15.
basically it says that you're there
there to listen there to talk and there
to have basically have a safe place to
experience your feelings your emotions
and your challenges in order to be
counseled but not guided this this is a
difficult thing to wrap our head around
because good medicine is non-directive
counseling
you would want directive counseling
about how you're going to get rid of
your cancer but when you're dealing with
with personal issues that's less of an
issue this is something where you want
to know that who you're going to is
going to listen to you and not steer you
in any certain direction
it's simply good practice
this is also an area where you may look
at this and say
that there's areas where you'd want
directive counseling I definitely want
to direct somebody against suicide
but do you want to Loop your parents in
at that point because if you have a
child who is suicidal the parents quite
frankly I think the parents deserve an
opportunity to make sure that that child
knows that they're loved and they're
wanted and that they're supported at
home because they may or may may not
change the situations in which their
child is and may or may not change how
many eyes are cautiously looking around
a corner to them just to make sure that
they're not leaving them in a situation
or leaving them unsupported after a
particularly challenging encounter
there's so many parents that at least on
that that side where if they had only
known there's something that they would
have done differently
and lives are left destroyed when you
get to something like suicide that the
parents really should be looped in so
prohibiting non-prohibiting directive
counseling
um in that case
I don't think that we should be looking
at without consent of the the parents
Guardian
so um basically this is to make it
you know I I think make a big
Improvement where we can get a lot more
agreement on this because there's so
many other issues where we do argue
um but this getting to non-directive
counseling should be a lot less
contentious representative Weber
well my first problem with the
um
the definition that's given here of
non-directive counseling
is that it seems to me that it would
um prohibit
the
counselor from saying
from exploring with the kid gee is there
a way that we can include your parents
in this discussion which I think ought
to be
a very primary exploration
but if if if you're not
um and and I think that would be both
giving advice and actively directing the
therapeutic process and the intended
outcome
if a
therapist was
working at getting the minor to explore
ways of
approaching their parents talking to
their parents including their parents
or repairing a relationship with parents
so
um without with only a layperson's
understanding of the English language
that would be my concern
and and I I do I mean we agree that that
having
familial involvement is
very much to be hoped for
representative netting up
them so I'm a psychotherapist and
um non-direct this is impinging on my
practice
it's
not a real thing non-directive whatever
and I think it's kind of come up because
parents have been so concerned that
therapists are talking their children
into being gay I mean that's where I
think this terminology came up from
um
when I and I have worked with a lot of
children and I'm I'm not going against
the parents you when you're counseling a
child
um you meet with all of them yes you
know what's going on here what are the
problems what are the solutions
um how are we what are our shared goals
creating a treatment plan that involves
the parents
um sometimes I've had contentious
parents where the child is living with
one and the other one was abusive but
I'm obligated as a therapist to meet
with that parent as well
we had a conversation earlier today
about
um
many of us therapists some parents think
that we keep a Verbatim
notation of everything that was said
during counseling which we don't it
would be impossible and I wouldn't
record it because I think that's an
invasion of of privacy but
um
um representative you had a wonderful
saying about the presumed best intention
of parents
um in a bill earlier and I feel that way
with therapists that most of them
have the best interest of their client
and the client's family atmosphere and
the and the clients
whole milieu in mind so I don't think
this is an unneeded bill
um
Amendment so
um and I you know I'm happy to talk more
off the clock because I know it's been a
long day but um you know you have your
best outcomes with a client when you can
involve their
family with them I mean you have an hour
a week with them they have all the rest
of the time with them so when you can
affect effect effectively a family
structure or maybe how they interact
with each other that's going to have the
best outcome for the child so I I don't
have to be more diplomatic than I want
to be here
um this is kind of threatening language
to a therapist
um that is is not needed
all right thank you thank you I guess to
respond to that this was to try and
Bridge a bit of that Chasm my opposition
to the bill as written is actually the
same thing as yours that the best
outcomes come when the family is
involved so having an easier process in
order to have this therapy specifically
cutting out the family was my concern
because it's hard to work with those
parents when they're not part of this
process and that they are not
um there's not consent from those
parents so this was my attempt to bridge
a gap in order to find something where
maybe we could all get agreement and
then move this thing through with
enthusiastic consent support but that
may not be the kid that appears not to
be the case so maybe it makes sense for
us I don't want to limit what anybody is
saying but if there's if there's a
significant difference of opinion on
this amendment perhaps it's worth doing
a vote on it seeing where it lies and
then playing on yeah is there any
opposition to that happy to help rewrite
an amendment that you would like to
rewrite an amendment with me before next
week to get to that yeah yeah let's do
that okay if you have representative
McKay
could you put your microphone on
Christmas
perturbed by this legislation that I am
totally opposed to the legislature
prescribing
Psychotherapy practice any more than I
would tell Dr Murphy how to do his
business and I would wouldn't have a
clue as to how to do that I don't think
the legislature should be be so specific
as to prescribe a specific type of
approach a Psychotherapy is a licensed
practice and it's licensed to several
different groups including social
workers and psychologists and so on
that this
assumes that the legislature knows more
than the professional licensed person
as to how to practice their their
profession I I think it's heading in a
very dangerous Direction and I certainly
would oppose it thank you would you be
willing to work with representative
another
my good friend
um my good friend from Nashua
um to see if there is an amendment that
would work
um so that we can see if we can come to
something for next week we'll take a
look at it always willing to work with
my friend but the end result as far as
I'm concerned is already there
thank you so that's not a very positive
first
thank you and representative Selleck I'm
sorry I just want to contribute just as
a parent of two teenagers
um and someone who went through therapy
both as a teenager and as an adult
the therapist's goals for all have been
driven by the need of the client and you
know so that if my kid needed guidance
one of them needed school specific
guidance and ideas about how to navigate
School situations
and so she would have absolutely needed
her therapist to direct the process
because the issue was she didn't know
how to navigate things from the first
place and so to to take that ability
away from the therapist would have
completely negated
the goal of her being in therapy
um now I was aware obviously she was in
therapy
um but had she chosen to go find a
therapist to work with without us I
would have been incredibly grateful for
her to get the support that she needs
and and I'm the kind of parent who loves
my kids no matter what
um I'm also a former teacher and know
how many kids don't have parents who
love them no matter what and helping
those kids find resources so they could
have safe spaces to talk about the
Dynamics
um was crucial and and finding them ways
to help them stay alive and make it till
their 18th birthday when they could
choose to do these things whether or not
their parents were involved and so you
know I'm in favor of the original bill
but this amendment to me puts children
in danger and and so that offers me
concern and I'm happy to come in if you
want me to consult with you at some
point either by phone or in person I'm
happy to contribute to your committee
representative Shapiro yeah
um
I I appreciate your effort to kind of
bridge a gap between two very important
principles that there are mature miners
who would benefit by being able to
consent to their own treatment and the
fact that the best treatment includes
is relational treatment you know is
affects
um people's life relationships and the
family is the most part of that the most
important part of that so I appreciate
the effort to
um bridge that Gap I think
you know the problem I think is that
well when you know when there was
Freudian analysis and people lied on a
couch five days a week and somebody sat
behind them and people talked about
their fantasies and their dreams and um
you know
the I the idea was that there was a
neutral screen the therapist was
supposed to be completely neutral you
weren't even supposed to see them but
you can't tell me that going into a room
like that and lying on a couch and going
through that process doesn't influence
the situation I think it's impossible to
be completely
non-directive I mean I think the very
Act of engaging with someone
changes the process
um and so
I can't really conceive of any other
amendment that would bridge the gap but
if there was some way to
let miners
consent to their treatment and at the
same time encourage
involvement of the family
without prescribing it I think that you
know if there's some way to find
something like that I would I would
think that that would be a good thing
thank you I actually do want to speak to
one of the things that representative
Selleck brought up RC Lake brought up I
I think that what you're seeing is a lot
of students who feel that their parents
don't support them because there's a lot
of parents some of those are ones that
truly don't support them but there's
other ones that don't unders don't
recognize that so figuring out some way
to bridge that Gap in not the ones who
know that they have loving parents and
the ones that know that they have
unloving parents because both of those
are true but somewhere in that muddy
middle there are plenty of kids that
don't understand how much their parents
care because their parents aren't good
at communicating either and
acknowledging that just because you
don't think that your parent cares isn't
doesn't mean that that's necessarily the
truth I guess I just want to make sure
that these kids don't feel hopeless if
that's what their perception is
yes thank you so I
I'm literally talking about kids and you
know I haven't had to make the calls to
dcyf on behalf of those children
um whose parents couldn't accept them
for who they were whether it was a
difference in religious views or whether
it had to do with something else
but if kids feel truly feel and believe
in their core that they can't talk to
their parents and can't even express to
them that they need help
giving them a way to access it because
maybe what will happen with their
therapist who is able to direct the
treatment it to some degree is that the
therapist will say wow I hear you saying
your parents don't love you because they
expect you to keep your room neat
let's break that down and think about
what's really behind it and maybe they
can help them see past those things that
you know adolescents are adolescents for
a reason right they're prefrontal
cortexes aren't fully developed you know
but giving them a a way
in my mind giving kids any light in the
dark
is so much more important than the
potential risk of leaving them in the
dark and and it's just crucial to find
ways to help kids and if we look at all
of the studies now the impacts of covet
and the isolation and the impacts of
social media
the levels of anxiety and stress for
children are so high that just helping
them find any access whatever that may
be is crucial
thank you I guess um I'll take that
comment my other part is I didn't know
I'll take your comment and
representative
uh thank you I'm skeptical about I think
underlying bill goes too far but
speaking about this amendment and what
the representative select said I would
agree that a therapists need to
detect the process but it's a question
of definitions a difference between
directing the process and electing a
child and they're definitely a directive
ways ways to do therapy and
non-delective ways to do counseling for
example
can say okay think about your problem
put positives
signs on the left side of your list put
negatives on the right side of your list
now think what you should do so the
therapist definitely
direct the process but he or she doesn't
direct the child's decision to make so
definitely
there's a way to to be non-delective but
give the kids light in the dark they
need help them to get rid of anxiety
while doing non-directive counseling
thank you I think I'd like to see if we
can do a straw poll to see
how many people just
left any Amendment many ways and if
that's the case then there's no need to
spin our Wheels we can vote and then
move forward so is there anybody who is
just going to be in support and not not
take not go with any Amendment because
if that's the case we might as well go
ahead and vote on the money or is that
is that appropriate representative Weber
it's perfectly appropriate but I I can't
tell you whether I would accept an
amendment or not till I saw the
amendment I mean the the concern that I
have is I'm entirely in sympathy with
everything that representative whose
name I cannot pronounce and I'm sorry
because I don't remember names anyway
and I really am very sorry about that so
think how awful it is with pronouns uh
but what I am very aware of
well one of the things I think that what
you're talking about is covered by the
ethical and standards of practice
uh under which
counselors of all different kinds
operate because what they are supposed
to be doing is helping the individual
achieve
the individual's goals but so that
there's that on the one hand but what I
do know is that
the way you phrase any question
matters and
you know you
and the way whatever a therapist chooses
to say next is in some way a direction
and I I will give you one example I used
to be a guardian for elders who didn't
have anybody
familial or or otherwise related and I
could go and say to an elderly woman
lying on a hospital bed
do you want to have an operation this is
this is the operation and she would say
no I don't want to have an operation and
if I said
Dr Smith your doctor
recommends that you have this operation
she would say oh all right and sorting
out
whether you know what her motivations
were
and whether she truly
understood and and to what extent she
understood what she was answering and
and telling me what she really wanted
was really hard so
I'm not sure that helps at all but it's
it's it's what informs my concern and I
would rather leave that
my choice is to leave that decision to
those who have put in an enormous amount
of professional time and training
suggestion to what you were suggesting
if we do a straw poll of those who would
just vote against the underlying Bill no
matter what is amended on it because on
principle we are against
giving away parents rights over their
children might prove
that we can vote on this now I think
maybe what I should do is just withdraw
my Amendment and then we should just
move to another motion so I'll withdraw
my amendments and she'll Mark
representative McLean while you're
withdrawal okay and I do think we've
discussed this issue quite a bit I'm not
sure if there's anything else to add oh
sorry we do have a motion
um ref does representative Shapiro want
to make a motion a representative McKay
I'm not sure who would like to make a
motion on this one
yeah
I'll make a motion um I move that we
vote ought to pass on House Bill 114.
we get a second should I have instead
had somebody move on itl so that we're
not closing off our other options should
itl not pass
we're not closing off our options either
well because if there's an ought to pass
and it doesn't if somebody wants to
reconsider anybody can move
reconsideration as long as the chair
hasn't sent the bill off to the clerk's
office regardless of how they voted okay
perfect
I would just say it's fine with me
either voting either way first but
sure okay
a second we'll go
actually let me look at my computer and
see what my mouth I'll second his motion
if that's helpful
I'm looking at my cheat sheet to say
what my expectation
um actually that
okay
um
well I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
on oh yes I'm sorry representative South
King okay thank you sorry
um perhaps
um if I had spoken earlier we could have
saved time so I apologize I find myself
in the unenviable position of
um going against my vice chair and
siding with the opposition party on this
bill
um
I can understand why
um with the amendment you would want
something that you could more likely get
behind however uh therapists at least
the majority of them are not paid and
run by the government so
um if they were paid or run by the
government I could sort of understand
more or less controlling what they're
allowed to say and do but since they're
not controlled by the gov or not run and
paid by the government I feel like
anything that would restrict their
speech would be inappropriate
we're we're speaking to the original
Bill not the amendment at this point is
that correct yes we're speaking to the
original okay fair enough so
um to get back to the original Bill the
reason why I support this bill is
because there was a time that kids
um used to be able to say it's a free
country I can do what I want and I don't
think they say that anymore
not too long ago kids used to be able to
bring guns to school and that was
totally fine they used to be able to go
to a vending machine and get a pack of
smokes and that was totally fine we have
totally over regulated what children are
allowed to do nowadays and so when it
comes to this bill
this is simply allowing them to talk to
other people at the end of the day
that's what it comes down to they're
allowed to talk to somebody else and um
I fully understand the culture wars that
are being waged I'm not happy with what
the left is doing but if you haven't as
a parent uh instructed your child by the
age of 16 about what's going on in the
world and they decide to go and do
something else by the age of 16. tough
so that's why I support this bill you've
got 16 you've got by 16 you've got
plenty of time to instruct your kids in
the way of the world and if you haven't
done so by 16 then they have the right
to go talk to other people so that's how
I feel thank you
thank you um okay uh representative
actually representative
question so if you if if the closest
psychologist is a psychologist in your
public school isn't he or she is paid by
government
actually yes if it's school psychologist
it would be ah thank you
yes representative Freitas yes thank you
um I got a master's degree and our
program was Kyle Rogers who was the Guru
at the time in non-directive counseling
and I feel like that Seth King has just
said these young people need someone to
talk to and the object behind this
program was that you visited with them
and talked with them into the house
things going in you got a conversation
started and you went from there so that
that's how it began with no Direction
just to a meeting and a thing but it was
interesting that seems like it's new to
the people at the table today
thank you representative uh yes yes your
friend from Nashville my friend from
Nashville um this a similar Bill to this
came up a couple years ago but the age
on it was 12 which made me bristle and
although it was cited that you could be
treated for STDs at 12. I
14. okay
anyway so um I am I couldn't imagine
taking a 12 year old client without
their parents knowing or 13 year old or
maybe even a 14 year old but I'm
comfortable with a 16 year old I mean
people can quit school at that age the
old no not anymore not anymore nope boy
I'm comfortable
I am comfortable with the age of 16 of
course you can get married with court
permission with the Court's permission
at 16.
um so
yes children need someone to talk to and
if we operate from the premise that
therapists are trained professionals
that will behave in professional manner
I think this is a good build to go
forward thank you um and uh I was hoping
representative and then representative
Cannon
so um
actually I had a conversation with the
sponsor of that bill which was would
reduce it to 12 and
part of her concern was that she knows a
lot of people who do not have parents in
their life at all
young people who are living on the
street having a very hard time of it and
need somebody to talk to so part of her
um
advocacy involved these talk therapy
talk therapy programs
um so
you know I struggle with how do we
balance
Meeting those needs how do we balance
Meeting those people where they are with
at the same time saying that you know
parents parents have a uh have a right
to be fully full participants in their
children's lives
up until 18. 16 is again I think we're
we are getting into a kind of a gray
area here my I I will fall on the side
of the line that says
a 16 year old is still a minor they're
still living in their parents home and I
will fall on the side of that argument
that says
you know parental rights Prevail under
those circumstances so having having
said that I I understand and and I
certainly accept that a 16 year old is
is more capable of making that decision
than a 14 year old or certainly a 12
year old and
um
you know it's unfortunate that we can't
you know sometimes we have to
give in one area to solve a problem in
another area and I'm not sure how we do
that I'm not sure how we help those
those folks that that representative
Klein Knight was
specifically concerned about but uh I
will be voting no or no on the on the
OTP motion representative Cannon
one list
um this past fall in the summersworth
school system we
we passed a a bill to support
transgender kids in in the high school
but it required that their parents were
working with them
um
for them to go through through a
transition process or whatever but they
they had to have support from their
parents but that left a number of kids
who don't have support from their
parents for anything
um in the Lurch with what do they do
there's no place and to have
this bill in place to have the ability
for them to decide that they really want
to talk to somebody that can help some
of that process because they can't talk
to their parents and they could talk to
their teachers and a counselor but
that's not necessarily the teacher or
the school counselor's job if the
council the counselor's job may be to
help find them someone whose life a
licensed therapist that they can talk
with this this bill would help do that
thank you and representative Freitas yes
thank you again for taking
um I just want to comment that the most
of the elementary schools that I taught
him had a counselor in the building so
now you're talking eight-year-olds
nine-year-olds going to the councilman
school now was not a therapist counselor
but it started the ball rolling so um I
just want to defend that that can be
thank you representative McKay thank you
microphone
remember to push the button my
reaction is the state involving itself
in
a a
professional practice I don't see
legislation telling doctors how to do
surgery or how to do this that or the
other thing that's what concerns me and
that this opens the door
for more legislation when I when I feel
that after there are licensing boards
that are very strict I used to sit on
one
we're not doing the amendment just the
bill underneath that allows kids that
are 16 and older yeah mostly what I'm
saying is that I dislike the the state
involving itself in the mental health
practice or any other professional
practice and then that's where I get so
upset by this because it opens a door so
it's any part of it uh I don't like
thank you and I think hopefully we're
ready I think we're ready to call the
roll
um if the clerk gonna call the role in
House Bill 114 the motion is ought to
pass
representative Cushman
no
representative Bill King no
Representative kofo no representative
McLean no
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri
no
representative Nagel yes
Representative pelosa no
representative log no
representative Weber yes
representative McKay just to be sure
could I ask what the motion is again
ought to pass
yeah well on the bill on the underlying
bill
I'm against uh
against the bill too
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
wait representative Shapiro yes
representative Howard yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Selleck yes
and representative Leon no
11 4 9 against
the motion of ought to pass
um
is successful
um and this will go on the regular
calendar obviously
um representative Shapiro are you going
to write the majority report or would
someone like somebody else to
sure I'll write it but um representative
Nutter upon volunteered to write a
different one
um on the lead Bill the lead Bill the
lead Bill okay
and you won't be doing an amendment
because we just have to go yeah no
Amendment because we passed the bill I
just want to be clear it's late yes
absolutely and representative would you
write The Minority Report for us on that
thank you
and with that
um I think we've we have gone through 12
bills I would call this a resounding
success since it was approximately a
half day
um so we will we will continue all of
these executive sessions to Wednesday at
9 00 a.m on the 15th it'll be noticed in
the calendar is there representative
Weber
question would be are we also going to
have a potential session on Thursday if
we don't get them done on Wednesday
sincerely hope that we would get through
16 bills
however
with the best will in the world
we have taken breaks we have talked and
it's all very productive
uh so
I am concerned about truncating things
and my hope would be that we could get a
room on the Thursday because we don't
have a session day
and we could notice on Thursday a
continued hearing from Wednesday if
necessary hope that we don't need it but
have it in case of need
wait wait we can do that I think I think
we've been asked not to do that but we
will we will try and do that so I mean
I'm I'm well it's just a suggestion but
if we can we can't I will I will see
what we can do to secure a room in order
to overflow if necessary but if we all
we all come ready to uh ready to accept
that some of these bills are going to be
divided and maybe Madam chairman yes is
there is it possible to I don't know if
this is appropriate can we start earlier
it's scheduled on the notice I just got
today it start at 9 30 on
is there any reason we couldn't start
earlier
remember that some of us drive a very
long way I do as well yeah just thinking
that if you start half an hour early and
just intend to get through it all I mean
were you proposing 8 30 yes
thank you
um to avoid Thursday
is there are there problems
I already get up at four o'clock in the
morning to be here at nine so okay then
I think I think probably nine and that's
just coming through with serious
intentions to get this done
so we will move it to nine o'clock
instead of nine thirty um it should have
been nine o'clock
foreign